Just 6 hours 11 minutes in and what are they talking about? They're
talking about lying. Okay, so look at the way JTO who's insane
by the way. JTO is such bad faith. He's absolutely blocked. No
interest in talking about human. He lies. He twists things. He's
This shows this whole video is just JTO. Obviously, he's crazy.
I don't know what his neurology is. I don't know what his category
is yet, >> but he lies for the time.
>> Jesus Christ. I am like the worst
>> What did he do?
>> Uh I don't Well, I do kind of know. I did. I've made
fun of her for some things.
Like I had that tweet where I made fun of her for being BPD and
saying she was going to like spiral on Destiny.
>> I mean, she went really hard on me and I haven't said
[__]
I've done absolutely nothing. But she thinks that I'm very mean.
So I'm like
wondering why cuz I'm not being mean to her or anyone that she
is particularly close to. I imagine that she cares about. So,
I'm like, where the is she got this like impression from?
>> Okay, so we're hitting play. We're going in on the Britney
video again. >> Let's go. >> But then he's so funny
the way he accuses Tom of lying. Watch. Oh, it's so good. Okay,
then Stardust is in the panel. And then some guy in the blue
shirt. I don't know who that is. So, Tom, I think his name I
don't know this guy's name is, but he's another guy who's going
after Tom. And then Star's there. I don't know why. I love Star,
but God bless you.
>> WSTLK and Windsor. And >> we managed to get 5
seconds in.
WSTLK and
Win and Wellie and Wary. Okay, you just put all of our names,
but I don't know who Winse is. Or maybe I'm missing it, but somebody
was just like W's. Everybody's W. Okay. >> Sometimes she
just like the be on a panel to show up for no reason. I don't
know why. Very weird category. Stardust like a weird category.
I don't understand her. And then like Okay, so then there's Kyla
who's this third party trying to come in and figure out what
the drama was. And Jtock comes in and JTO says, "Oh, Tom has
talked about how he's a pathological liar." Look at the way he's
saying that. Right. And as a nerd divergent kid growing up, which
Tom is, do you know lying in nerd diverency? >> Okay, compulsive
liar is apparently what I should have been calling him. >> Coincide,
but do you also know that according to recent studies, and I
pulled one up just from Wisconsin, 71% of people argue that or
say that they lie once to two times a day. Lying is so prevalent
in culture that a pathological liar isn't what Tom is. And Tommy
even uses it wrong, guys. Well, pathological liar isn't the assumption
of what we think it is. It's saying you have a pattern of behavior
consistent and chronic. But when you and I often think of pathological
liars, we're actually thinking of who the [__] did
I marry? You know the series who the [__] did I marry?
She calls him a pathological narcissistic liar, which sounds
like it's malicious, which sounds like it's insane, which sounds
like he's gaslighting her. >> Tom is a person who lies,
but all people lie. So if Tom's a pathological liar, then all
of us are pathological liars because everybody lies, right? >> What
is the logic for?
>> We are. >> Everyone might lie, but some people
can lie a lot more. Like that's the point of that, isn't it?
I >> Well, and he's lying like consistently like a lot
like around a specific topic. It's not like >> That's why
that's why I just said
Yeah. It's not a white lie you told >> what I said with
more words. Good job. >> There we go. We did it. Oh, don't
tell your boss what you did the night before. Girl, go to work
and pretend you had my grain or your period. Don't tell him you
drank all night. You lie, girl. Okay, so Tom calling himself
a pathological liar is probably not what it means in a sense
of narcissistic pathological liar of like oh my gosh, you know,
he could just be saying literally like, "Oh, a girl asked me
like what was I doing last night and I was playing video games
all night all night and m I told her I was at church." That's
a lie. If he does that every day, he's not a pathological liar.
So again, I feel like this is a miscatization, but possible.
Compulsive liar. Okay, compulsive liar is different from pathological
liar in my mind. It okay, all shades of blue. The shades of lying,
right? Is different from um fear-based liars. It's different
than growing up growing up in a home in which every time you
told the truth, you were punished. So you learn how to lie, right?
All of that is different. Plenty of good people just have trauma
from growing up in a religious home and like end up lying because
they don't want any backlash from people they're not close to.
Ever hear about people who like you need to break down their
walls for them to tell you the truth? So again, which category
is Tom is the question. So here's let's watch. >> Yeah.
An interview with you.
>> I mean, I don't super care which category he's in. The
point is he's in some category that lies so consistently and
so much that I can't trust almost anything he does most of the
time. So there are other options to lying, right? If you say,
"I don't feel comfortable talking about this. I can't tell you
like the answer to this question or I don't want to." Like there
are always other alternatives to just like lying about everything.
It's
>> with you with you and he's told you he's a pathological
liar before. >> Okay. So they go it's with you, Kyla. They
he talked to you and he said to you he was a pathological liar.
Tom's a low. His audience is going to tell him to up >> I
think he said used to be. Was that Did you talk about that when
you were when you were in addiction? >> So Tom says, "Yes,
when I was in addiction." He's his audio. Okay. >> Seem
to know that.
>> All right. Talking about Wait, did you not talk about
how fun it was to set to play the game and lie to people? >> Did
you talk? Did he say how fun it was to lie and play the game
and d Okay. >> Manipulate them. I thought this was a whole
thing. >> Yes, that's what >> on my stream. >> I
believe that we I what I remember while I don't remember. My
remembrance of the stream is that when we talked about it, he
was talking specifically about his experience as an addict. And
like I don't think he was saying it as a I could be wrong. And
so Jay, if you have like a clip of like me being a [__]
dumbass and Kim being like, "No, I still think that this is awesome."
My understand like a lot of parents will have like a like kind
of like that story we covered the other day. We'll have a trans
or gay kid and they're like, "You've always been a liar. You've
always lied to me." Well, yeah, I'm going to lie to you about
being gay, bro. If like the consequence of telling the truth
is that I get punished. And parents will use that against their
children and say, "See how you've lied? You lied all the time
when you were a kid." It's like, "Wo, I lied because if I told
you the truth, I would have gotten beat or punished or sent to
bed without dinner." You know what I mean? >> A lot of
category of lying. People try to like like >> set up for
like making Tom seem like a victim. He's none of these things,
right? He was just a criminal who committed a lot of crime.
And I guess like he was an addict, which sucks, but like
we don't know Tom's backstory.
And we've never spoken about him being an addict at all. So it's
like trying to give the valor of all these people that might
have had like trauma from being beaten because they were like
gay, which is something he just doesn't have. It's like why is
she speaking about these things like they could be something
that relate to him?
>> The really unfortunate thing here from my perspective
was I didn't I didn't know this was going to happen. So I couldn't
go through and like find stuff if somebody had said can you go
find the places Tom lied like during this drama. I know if I'd
had like a day I could have found like a hundred times where
he did little lies didn't check information just continued to
like explicitly misrepresent things to people because he thought
he had compartmentalized information. So, he did it a whole bunch
during this drama. I just didn't have the timestamps to go in
and go through it. So, I was just giving the examples that other
people had of times where he's talked about lying or like much
larger lies he had. So, I was just like going through them because
also because
we broke down. I was like, "Yeah, Tom lies a lot." And Aerodite
wanted me to find ex or give examples of him lying. >> And
it's like, >> yeah, also like a lot of a lot of addicts
don't become criminals. I just
>> I don't
I really don't like this narrative that's get pushed. What do
you mean? Maybe a lot of addicts are not
>> Um I mean a lot of certain kinds of addicts. I would
say most people who become like crack addicts become criminals,
but it like it doesn't excuse it. I'm not trying to say it excuses
it. Um I'm just saying like there probably is a really high correlation.
I mean outside of the obvious drug possession between being a
criminal and being an addict. Oh, you're such a little liar.
But like, why am I even lying in the first place? >> I've
never even watched.
>> Yeah. Okay. But there can be correlations between like
certain groups of people being more likely to be X, Y, or Zed,
right? But it's not really helpful to constantly ascribe those
two things as being something we speak about at the same time.
I don't think it's fair. There are plenty of non-addicts that
are criminals. There are plenty of addicts that aren't criminals.
And I think to be
exc it's almost like setting up a victim narrative so that you
can excuse the fact that he was a criminal. It's just like weird.
>> Look at him like he's a victim. >> Yeah. A victim
of what is I would like to know.
>> Of yours.
>> Me. I called him a little weirdo cuz he's a little weirdo
and that's it. Like I'm fine with the idea that hey this guy
was addicted to pills and now he's like kind of better. He's
made like he's sober. He's making something like good out of
his life maybe. I think that's fine as a narrative and you you
could even go as far as saying like we should try not to judge
him by the things he did during his addiction now that he's not
exhibiting any of those behaviors. Right? My issue is that like
my my understanding of him as a liar came from interacting with
him over the course of this like drama. Right? That's that's
where my understanding of him as a liar came from. But obviously
there were just a whole bunch of things where I realized like
I had to check him on everything he was saying and there were
things that led up to that. But I didn't have the time stamps
or any examples from this drama to give because I didn't know
any of this was going to happen. So, I was going to things that
I was unsure about, but I'd heard about after, you know, we got
into this drama and people sent me all this stuff from like his
past and all of these weird inconsistencies about his career
and and all the things he said on stream. So, that was why those
were the examples I had in text. So, those were the examples
I pulled up.
>> Yeah. Also, I would say like the things that he was
speaking about when it comes to the crimes he committed.
Britney later goes into how small time these things are, but
what they are is they it's organized crime, right? This wasn't
something that was done on an impulse.
Um, this wasn't something that happened like a few minutes before
they were like high and they decided they planned it. And organized
crime is worse.
And I feel like it's kind of poor to like put that on addict
behavior, but I don't know. What do I know?
>> I didn't even watch the full context of the screen.
These are people who are willing to tell Tom, I have an accusation
against you, but I've never watched the full context. I just
think you're a liar and I think this is what I This is so dis
disrespectful and bad faith. This is bad. When people aren't
willing to do the research, this is what I'm saying. And watch
the way Jay stop >> I wasn't I wasn't given any time to
do the research. I was just told, "Hey, you should come on this
stream." And then when I said something that I truly believe,
and I know, listen, I know because of how often people message
me during this drama to point out all of Tom's lies both during
and before it. I I am completely confident in this. I just was
pulled on out of nowhere, out of the blue to be brought on and
speak on it. And so I was like, here are the things I recall.
And then people kept sending me stuff and I was like, yeah, I
did check in on this, too. This is really weird. Yeah, this was
also really weird. Anyway, so why assume someone is lying? Because
when somebody makes a claim when they have a fantastical story
like they like he sent his girlfriends or he sent his girlfriend
to somebody's house to figure out where their stash was and then
they raided that house as if they were SWAT. They rolled up in
SUVs with SWAT gear on and raided that house for drugs. Are you
kidding me? Show me any evidence that that happened. Show me
anything consistent about that story. Where'd your girlfriend
go? Your girlfriend was there. She told you she found out where
the stash was and then what you like broke in while she was there.
Would they not realize, hey, we talked to this other drug dealers
girlfriend? Would your girlfriend not get killed if this was
actually high stakes drug?
>> Wait, that's >> they don't believe you then don't
affirmatively call him a liar. I'm calling him a liar based on
his lies, not on that. I'm saying those are evidence. That's
evidence of him being dishonest. And I said as much in the stream.
I kept saying, "No, all of this strains cil like none of this
seems believable." which implies I don't believe him. The lying
stuff came down to how he acted during the drama. And once we
actually started talking about it and and people started messaging
me and telling me all of the things that he was inconsistent
about, I was like, "Yeah, I remember all of this." But at the
time, I wasn't planning to go in here, so I didn't come with
any timestamps for that.
Obviously, we got to the list and you just saw it on full display.
So, what did you think he's lying about? Like exaggerating like
the the details of the crime to make himself sound
>> Uh I mean that whole that girlfriend um drug dealer
story thing that's Mona Lisa, Lil Wayne and Kendrick Lamar.
I swear it just sounds like a lot of these uh stories are like
literally from like pop culture. >> Yeah. like a true detective.
>> How long was he even in jail for? >> He said 13
months, but I think he he did 13 months in like a jail, not a
penitentiary. He did a much shorter amount of time in a penitentiary.
>> Wow. My brother went to jail for 2 years and his was
way Well, to me it seems way more minor, but hey.
And it was only one instance and it wasn't organized cuz they
actually But
>> Yeah. I and I just for everybody to know he she keeps
calling me like evil and like that I'm a liar and that I'm just
trying to stir drama. I didn't try to get back in that I didn't
try to bring that [__] up. I didn't try to bring
any of this up.
>> Yeah, obviously I asked him that frugals. If you're
breaking into other people's stash houses, I assume you're like
dealing a lot of drugs. hell.
>> I mean, I guess it's possible that he Yeah, he committed
a lot more crimes than he was actually prosecuted for.
That's That's possible.
Although, that would make it exceptionally stupid to be talking
about it on a live stream if there are crimes you haven't been
like prosecuted for.
It's like, hm, this seems stupid.
It's like, you're not OJ Simpson. Uh, you're not going to be
writing like a best-selling book to bank off of your stupidity.
I I don't know. >> If you're breaking into a stash house,
you are just a junkie. Are you insane?
What junkies are breaking into stat uh stash houses? Wouldn't
that imply like a lot of drugs there and potentially a lot of
money? Maybe not a lot of money because they'd probably fared
it out every day. Would there not be a ton of drugs in a stash
house? Is that not the point of a stash house? That not be somebody
somewhere they'd defend with like guns and [__]
Yeah, he explained it as like a competitive crew of people selling
drugs, right? That he used his girlfriend as bait or whatever.
>> I don't know. It was a weird story.
hold on. The just so we're clear, the the claim isn't that he
just broke into a stash house. The claim is that they rolled
up in SWAT gear, pretending to be SWAT, and then broke into it
under the guise of police. that is a like organized operation
that I don't believe a bunch of oxy addicts would would actually
get together and make
>> Um I mean okay addict Jessica you're not thinking he
is actually doing the Hollywood thing. I am not doing the Hollywood
thing. He made up a Hollywood story.
He did this while he was working at Subway
by the way.
>> Right. Firstly, obviously it's easy to doubt that he
did a good job at anything or he wouldn't have ended up in jail,
but that doesn't mean that people can't function well as addicts,
right? It's it's there are plenty of people that take all these
drugs and they go through life and that is they function completely
fine.
It's I mean, you know, within reason of what fine means. They're
not homeless. Plenty of people that are addicts have jobs.
this idea that like I mean everyone's watched House. Is he like
addicted to Vicodin? He like functions, doesn't he? Like he can
be addicted to painkillers
and still like have a job and like function.
It's not like um
I don't know, psychedelics or shooting up on heroin would be
a bit different.
I don't know.
Okay, hold on. Hold on. We may have photo evidence of Tom actually
pulling off this heist. >> I believe we we might have video
evidence. Hold on.
>> No, no, no. >> Whoa.
It's in there.
>> Is this the exact situation?
>> Is this how it went down? >> Start moving. >> Come
on,
>> guys. Is this what happened? Is this how it went down?
I'm absolutely going to get copyright struck for this, by the
>> All right, 30 seconds in and out. 30 seconds in and
out. >> In and out, guys. In and out.
>> Watch it. I'll nuke you, [__]
>> Where's the bald one? The Tom had a lot more hair back
here. Okay, you guys can't tell this is Tom.
>> you guys, there's no way you can't tell this is Tom.
>> I see it.
scene is the best part of the whole season. It's really good.
Oh, Ginger is bald. Yeah, you're right.
I don't know. Like,
also the training day scene.
>> but let's let's skip a bit over whether we care about
how much he's lying about embellishing like details to make himself
seem cooler cuz like who cares really about that stuff?
I want to like see listen to the unhinged comments in
Uh, wait. The unhinged like Britney's unhinged comments. This
>> whole drama literally like snakes his way out of it
and in it again and then doubles down but like refuses to do.
Look how he does it. Oh, I just didn't even watch it. I just
didn't even watch it. But he's accusing Tom of like the worst
things. That's what I'm saying. Stop talking to these people.
They're just bad people according to Britney's values because
they're not willing to engage in any form of good faith and they're
not worth the communication. But let's pay attention to how the
conversation goes.
>> Let's hear. >> I've seen like a 20 second clip
here. Go ahead, Dave. Uh the part that he's referring to is when
you two were talking, he starts talking about a job that he had
and his boss asked him a question and he lied to his boss. And
then when he was thinking about it, he's like, "Wait, why the
hell did I just lie about that? There was no reason for me to
lie." And then he goes on to tell you >> by the way, that's
a phenomenon I see on Tik Tok all the time. Like when I lie about
a perfectly reasonable or unreasonable thing that like someone
asked me, why did I feel need to lie? This is why I say so many
things are trauma or there's a reason and the why can be answered.
So Tom's going to answer it. He has a really good answer for
it. Kyla has a really good answer for it. But look at the way
that they don't even care about the answer. They're trying to
use this to prove that Tom is somehow like this like malicious
like mischievous like horrible little like chronic 4D chess player
liar in the community when it's literally the
Tom isn't perfect, but he's not the one trying to play 4D chess.
>> He's a liar. >> Britney is doing is saying
>> Well, he was justified.
>> I don't know.
>> What she's saying he's not he's not like organized in
a mechelian type of way. He's just an idiot. It's like uh
>> I mean, yeah, I am saying that I'm Britney and I might
be saying something
>> He's she But she's basically saying that like it's totally
understandable and okay that he's lying, which is like, okay,
you could you could say that, I guess, but then the whole point
of this part of the stream is that Erodite's challenging me that
he's a liar. Yeah, cuz they're making you justify why you don't
believe his stories.
It just seems so weird to me. >> Which, like, listen, there's
Queen's doing a whole stream right now, a whole full content
stream based on why he doesn't believe those stories.
So, I mean, there's a lot there. This guy has said a lot of and
he's going to keep saying a lot of there's a ton of stuff from
his YouTube channel.
Sorry. There's a ton of stuff from his YouTube channel and it's
all going to get dug up. It's all going to get looked into. And
I know I know the lies are there. I like they just are.
Especially the stuff around his job. I know there's a I got told
about a stream around his like his rhetoric coach where like
it's the same kind of lying where like he says something and
the person asks him about what he just said and he says I didn't
say that. And then he maintains that he didn't say it for like
the rest of the stream.
It's just like it's >> it's wild the way he always
I'm struggling to care.
>> He's already admitted that he's a liar.
>> Well, so what what Aerodite and Britney's contention
is is that he admitted he was a liar while he was like he was
saying I used to be while I did drugs while I was an addict.
Well, it's like
>> remember this situation is that if he had said I'm a
pathological liar and like I kind like enjoy the thrill of it
and ended there. I think that would have like put us some really
really massive red flags.
>> I just want to make understand did he talk about it
in a past tense state while he was actively addicted and saying
that that was something he did >> and now in recovery he
doesn't do the >> I don't know if it had to do with the
addiction part of >> I don't know it has because you didn't
watch the clip. You're so excited to take people down. This is
what I'm saying. Red flag. People who are excited to take people
down off a 20 second clip.
How malicious is that? Huh? How malicious is that? To only watch
clip content and then to completely take
>> uh is what true? I didn't really listen. All of the
things I was asking about, I was being told and some of them
I I hadn't been uh like some of them I hadn't seen, but I just
I had people messaging me like, "Don't forget to bring this up.
Don't forget to bring this up." And if I knew about it or if
I'd seen like any indication of it, I just I was just like, "What
about this?" >> No, I mean like the excitement where you're
like, "Oh my god, I'm so excited to take Tom down. Like what
is she talking about? >> I literally didn't ask to join
the stream. In fact, I said I don't want to join the stream multiple
times to my chat. Hey, I don't want to join the >> What
is she even talking about? Like >> I moved on from Tom
content. I didn't farm it. I specifically moved on and said,
"Hey, I'm not going to do that anymore. We're moving on from
that." And there was a lot more content there, by the way, that
I never ended up going over cuz I was just trying to let this
guy move on with his life. >> And you were like sick and
like groggy yesterday. I literally I was like I had the worst
headache before before I even knew the stream was happening.
I think I was like I have the worst headache right now. I was
Anyway,
>> literally I didn't want to join. I didn't want to be
a part of it. >> Went out of context. Isn't that beautiful?
Isn't that so? They're telling on themselves. They're literally
>> Then after I didn't want to join. I had nothing prepared.
I had no idea this topic was going to come up. She's like, "Look
at how how psyched he was and how he had like all of these examples
ready to go. I didn't. I was just being like texted stuff or
like sent stuff in messages and I was like, "What about this
one, Tom? What about this one?
>> Do not engage with these people. They are literally
confessing to being bad people. Do not engage >> portion
of the thing. I think this was separate, but I could be wrong.
I literally have to click right here. I
>> Is this all manufactured for content?" No. When I originally
said the pest thing, I didn't stream.
I think I literally had just thought about making a channel.
Sorry. When I said it the first time, I said it in chat in uh
DGG chat before I even had a channel registered.
It was just like a funny meme. We're all joking. We're all like,
"Hey, it's kind of weird how you do this thing with all the girls
Destiny used to hang out
Which, by the way, I will point out again is super funny cuz
now I do basically that stream.
I believe in conspiracies and start thinking all the streamer
space, all the drama in the streamer space is manufactured. No,
I did this while I was a viewer. This all blew up from [__]
I did while I was a viewer. I had no financial incentive to do
any of this >> a while ago. It was like a 20 second clip.
I watched it like a while ago. Wait till you see the [__]
clip. Wait until you guys see the [__] clip. >> To
be clear, um, if it was just while he was addiction, um, I want
to be really cautious. I'm super not comfortable smearing people's
character just by >> seven. You're right. He does lean
into >> Addiction alone and to say that that like eventuates
into their sobriety, it can sometimes. So, I'm not dismissing
it as like a source. I just want to be like, you know, >> there's
also major props to Kyla. She did really really good during this
discussion. heist stories that seem to change constantly. >> I
mean, this is >> why he went to prison. Tom, were you doing
grand theft like grand lararseny when you went to prison? Stealing
>> So JTO starts the sentence off with and the lies he
told the stories he's told and then look at the way he's doing
it. He's twisting just like he did in the conversation with me
for 5 seconds. He tried to do that told sometimes. So I'm not
dismissing it as like a source. I just want to be like >> there's
also major props to Kyla. She did really really have to listen
to this heist stories that seem to change >> I mean >> why
he went to prison. Tom, were you doing Grand Theft like Grand?
>> So I didn't say he was lying there. I was basically
saying I find the story incredulous. Tom, you want to fill me
in on what is actually happening there? >> Arson, you went
to prison stealing >> So JTO starts the sentence off with
ooh and the lies he told, the stories he's told. And then look
at the way he's doing it. He's >> I said stories. I didn't
say lies. >> Twisting just like he did in the conversation
with me for 5 seconds. He tried to do that. J has tried to twist
my words so many times. I'm like, "Oh, you're one of those people.
You do the twist.
Do the twist. Oh, okay. Okay. You're a twister. I get it. He
does it every time he talks to people."
You and Queenman both are incentivized to make him out to be
a liar. Okay, Jacob, you can join Discord or ban. Uh
You are going to be hidden. And when you join the discord and
join the room, uh the waiting channel and we actually talk this
out on stream. Okay, that's when you will get unbanned from the
YouTube chat. Good luck.
>> And he's super bad faith about it. People shouldn't.
This man is obviously trying to culture, guys. Stop talking to
him. Ignore him. Stop talking to him.
>> Uh, he seems to think I'm doing this with Queenman for
some financial incentive. And if he wants to come and make that
argument in Discord, we can do
But otherwise, I'm good. >> Is she saying you're cloud
shark? >> Yes, I was stealing jewelry from >> Yeah.
I don't understand why, but she did. She says it a ton in this
that I'm a cloud shark.
>> Okay.
Is that why you went to prison? That's one of the times I got
arrested. That's not the time that I uh went to prison. But the
um yes, the clip that they're talking about literally they show
me talking about like when I was 18. This is 17 years ago where
I'm talking about like improving like >> 17 years ago.
He is talking to Kyla about the person the consciousness he was
17 years ago >> having to change aspects of my life being
an addict for a long time going to prison then getting out and
having to like relearn how to be a normal person and having to
change like a lot of bad patterns that I learned >> which
we all have to do. All of us should have a story about our life
in which we learned to stop bad patterns. And if you don't, then
you're not doing any work on yourself, which tells me you're
the problem. >> And I'm Yes. And I'm talking to you about
like how it is that I had to change these things and that I was
just kind of like a compulsive liar that I would just lie about
things that I didn't need to and that I had to relearn like how
to not do that anymore. But they literally take that clip and
each time say, "See, he literally admits that he's a pathological
liar. How did nobody notice this at the time? He admits that
he's a pathological liar." Every single time somebody plays a
clip instead of saying, "Oh, this is a clip." So instead of top
and this is one of the things I hate about this space or that
space uh that space this space that space but not our space our
space is different our space is good that space is that they
don't want to know about the consciousness they don't want to
hear about change so here's Kyla trying to have re >> I'm
actually totally comfortable with Tom changing and I'm totally
comfortable dropping his compulsive liar bit
but like I just want to make it clear the compulsive liar thing
was before I knew about that quote
like I thought he was a I thought it was pathological but I guess
I I started to think he's a compulsive liar before I was aware
of that clip.
yeah, I don't know. I don't know what to tell you guys. >> Really
important in-depth conversations about a person's consciousness.
Tom is being vulnerable. He's sharing a part of his life. And
then here are these people who are taking that vulnerability
and twisting it in the ugliest way because they don't believe
him and don't like
That's a very specific category of person. It takes a very specific
category of person to one, not have empathy, but two, to take
somebody who's talking about a past version of themselves that
has learned something and to literally say that's how they are
now. to say like, "Oh yeah, the ins and I only watch a 20 second
clip of it. So, oh, I didn't see the full context." So, >> for
him talking about like himself from 17 years ago, maybe he's
still doing this. That's never what they say. They always say,
"Look, he literally admits to this." >> Uh, am I going
to get redirected for this raid? Is it going to autod do it to
>> I hope it doesn't. >> Am I able to share into
your >> She raided Wick and I'm hoping it doesn't auto
raid me over to Wick.
>> So, just sent me a clip. Um, do you mind if we just
watch the full context? So, wait until you see the full context
because I don't fully remember this conversation. Um, can I share
into your into this call? Is that possible? >> I just want
to ask Tom point blank. Did you actually imitate SWAT to rip
off other drug dealers?
>> Was this why you were actively addicted?
>> Yes.
And selling.
>> Okay. Hold on. Someone's got apparently a good clip
here.
>> Otherwise, you'll slip back into that like construct
thought. Like if you're yelling at me because your construct
says I'm bad, then like you're not having a five conversation.
Otherwise, >> Dan, that is not as good as you think it
is. I usually trust your opinion, but that is not that is not
a funny tweet. I'm so sorry.
>> Look, there are spectrums. So, when Tom talks about
his relationship with drugs, addiction, um, jail, that's a specific
shade of blue. What regular society has >> but Oh, Dan,
but thank you very much for grabbing the whole VOD just in case
we need it. Love you, buddy. Thank you.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Thank you so much. >> relationship
with this thinks when they think about addiction is they have
a vision in their head. So when people talk about addiction or
prison or something, they have a thing in their head that pops
up and that's what they think it is. And if Tom isn't like that,
he's lying. But you guys know there's a spectrum to people who
go to prison. There's a spectrum to people who are addicts. There's
a spectrum to being homeless. There's a spectrum spectrum. Spectrum.
Okay. So again, which shade of blue are you? Right? Is Tom the
light blue shade talking about prison and addiction or is he
the dark shade blue and then he's the other dark shade blue?
It's like, okay, which ones? And then that's the problem is like
nobody understands that we're there's like so many being addicted
is not a monolith. There's so many different kinds of addicts.
There's so many different kinds of relationships you can have
with addiction. There's so many different kinds of people who
go to prison. There's so many different kinds of people who are
felons. There's so there's the really really toxic kind that
like don't recover and go into cycles and use it against people
and actually are willing to harm people for it. There's a kind
of people who happen to have addictions that will sell their
children and slavery for drugs. Hey, Tom is one of the more,
and I don't mean to downplay his struggle, one of the better
off kinds. Tom got a very good hand in terms of his addiction
relationship. like Tom is probably a better off addict than other
people. But then the problem is is like if you don't if you downplay
or make sure that you're not one of the extreme cases, then people
go, "Oh, then you w you weren't really even addicted." You didn't
even struggle. It's the same thing with like with mental health.
Oh, well, you can't be
>> I don't know who she's unless you are like level three
or you can't be borderline unless you're wor
of them are still the same. Well, not a lot of this. They either
don't believe him or maybe he sensationalizes it sometimes or
maybe he downplays it sometimes because each community hears
it different. That's my life. >> Well, he just he sensationalizes
everything. If he downplayed any of his stories, that would be
interesting to >> right? Should I play up the fact that
>> just going to go grab some painkillers? I got a headache.
>> Okay, they're setting up this and if so, let's make
sure you guys can hear it
where Robin starts off his her first date with Ted.
my boss something and seconds later being like, "Sh, I don't
know why I just lied about that. That was stupid." Like I I literally
just made that up. >> Hold on. I want to hear that again.
I >> remember like actually telling my boss something and
seconds later being like, "Okay, so it doesn't specify the something."
Angry says, "Jock is too stupid to understand the difference
between the word compulsive and pathological." I'm not convinced
he's stupid. I'm convinced he is purposely in the game to smear
people into >> Oh boy, that one might actually be true.
As we discovered about 10 minutes ago or 20 minutes ago, >> lie
about people, but he could just be stupid. I mean, he could be.
If J is dumb, then like I totally get it. But >> Oh, I
know. I'm I'm I
think a lot of people have this issue online. I've never once
in my entire life been insecure about my intelligence. Like I
don't care if people call me stupid or um
I've had a lot of success in like very very cerebral fields.
I don't need to be told I'm intelligent by other people. Like
something other people struggle with. I'm not even like that
smart. I'm just saying like I I'm I know where I am on the intelligence
totem pole. It's not at the top, but it's high enough that I'm
not concerned. >> But I don't know if he's dumb or if he's
doing it on I think he's doing it on purpose if I'm gonna be
honest. I think he might be malicious. I think he might be a
malicious actor in this sphere. And I think he's trying to pull
people over in order to like make drama content cuz guys, there's
got to be that category of person. There's always the category
of person that could dedicate their whole time online to being
like really really toxic. Chuck Logic, JTock, they're all kind
of like together. If you're a drama, like a real drama streamer,
like all you care about is like telling the worst lies about
people or smearing people or tearing down, then yeah, like I
just think like they fit into that category probably. >> Yeah,
dude. I don't know.
uh I don't even know how to go into it. Like I had all of the
information on Tom like provided to me over time that I could
have gone and done the same stream that like Queen's doing where
he's doing like a whole Tom Lur stream again. I could have done
those streams. I explicitly didn't. I don't know why I wouldn't.
You think I don't make I make ton of money covering Tom right
now for some reason.
>> You take offense to being called malicious by like Britney
is doing now. Yeah, I do. Sorry. Go ahead, Cherry. >> Yeah,
it's funny because I've seen Tom have a conversation about this
after the after the fact that it all happened or whatever. And
he has the most disdain for some of his closer friends, some
of the people in his community.
He didn't sound or he didn't um hint to the fact that he felt
like really poorly towards you and Kelly, but that seems to be
where everyone else's anger is like directed at. Like Tom debates
for a living on here. I don't know why she's acting like this
is the most offensive thing and that Tom should cut you guys
off. It just seems to me.
>> Yeah. I don't know. I like I said I'm starting to feel
bad because I just don't know if Tom actually wanted to do any
of this and I do feel like sorry it is compulsive. I feel like
like getting pulled into this he's going to start like doing
the same thing where he is making up again and I don't think
he actually wants to be there doing it. >> So I just I
feel bad that he's even here having this discussion.
>> So I yeah I tried to move on from it >> Why I
just lied about that? That was stupid. Like I I literally just
made that up. My bad. And uh them looking at me like I was the
freaking weirdest person in the world. So embarrassing to >> Would
they be like small little white lies or was it everything? Like
they would be both small little white lies and big lies to get
out of situations. >> Yeah. Sometimes it wasn't even like
big lies to get out of situations. It was just lie just like
just for something interesting cuz I enjoyed the game. So like
when I was selling drugs and all that, there was just >> it
it was part of the game is to like manipulate everybody else
around you. So we had a crew. >> Yeah. It's called politics.
That's why people who are in politics, I look at you specifically
cuz that's what you're doing when I listen to YouTube. I I watched
a little bit of this. I remember this. It's called politics,
guys. It's just called politics. >> Behind the scenes,
are people in politics, specifically political YouTubers? That's
what they're doing. They're absolutely manipulating everyone.
They're lying. They're getting people on their side. They're
emotionally manipulating. That's why I don't like that bubble.
That's why I'm going to go to the bathroom really >> Do
you I'm going to leave this running,
>> Yeah, you're good. >> I'll be right back. >> I
just My values don't like it. I don't want to play this game
with you. I don't want to force D chess you. I don't want have
to think about what you're tweeting or whatever. Oh my god, you're
so anxietyinducing. No. if that's what these people are doing
and they think we're all doing it and we're not. And that's the
problem. They think everyone is doing it because they're doing
it. That's why I don't want to engage with these people because
I'm not doing that. I'm literally not trying to play for chess.
I'm not trying to DM people and get on other people's sides.
I'm literally just trying to live my life. >> But we weren't
like we were always trying to get over on each other as well.
And we were always trying blue backstab each other. And um we
were also doing like different um I tell stories about like where
there were other drug dealers that I was friends with that I
would get my girlfriend to tell them we broke up and see if she
could go over to their house and then she would go over and hang
out with them and then she would text me and be like, "Hey, their
drugs are in this spot." And then we would pull up in SUVs and
like SWAT uniforms and break in and take all their drugs and
uh and leave like we were the police and um crap like that. And
so yeah, we were always like trying to get over on one another
as well. >> He straight up took that story. True detective.
Everybody says that to always try to uh get over on one another
and eventually you were just like streaming. >> Ripley
says, "Britney, I think there's a shade of blue politics that
you engage with." Yes. So I engage with like activism, donations.
I engage lightly in like researching for my own. I'm a voter,
so of course I engage in politics as a voter, but I don't engage
in politics meaning like playing politics with people. I don't
do that. But that's a game I used to be in and I just couldn't
handle it. It was too toxic, way too bad. Nobody was interested
in getting better. It was very ugly. Like lots of ugliness. Just
ugliness from people. The worst side of people comes out in politics
when you play political games. Um but the way I engage is as
a voter, of course I engage in politics. I'm a voter, right?
Like I vote
>> webs that weren't even connected to something in hopes
that they would be connected to something way later down the
line that would help you. And so yeah, you just ended up lying
for for no reason sometimes, just thinking it might be something.
>> Okay, I'm guessing that's the end of the clip, right?
>> That was the clip. He's telling a very normal story.
I think we've all had stories about our teenage or our life.
Everybody I know had like a chronic lying teenage phase cuz like,
you know, you just like lie to adults, you lie to authority,
like who the [__] cares, okay? You go through your
life, you do your thing, everyone's got a lie they told, right?
He just told a very normal story about a person in a position
in which it makes sense. and like 17 years ago, 18 years ago,
15 years ago, 14 years ago, 10 years ago, just like a different
part of who you are, right? >> Uh there's the whole thing
about him doing the SWAT stuff as well, which was unless that
was in there. >> That's what I just talked about. >> See,
Jaw goes, "What about all the the SWAT stuff?" And he goes, "I
just talked about that.
I'm not really following all along that much." I've seen >> I'm
not I'm not really following along as much. Like Jason is like
the worst category of person ever. >> As I as I said when
I was going to start that whole thing, I was on the verge of
throwing up for a lot of this.
I was not doing super well
at all. >> Yeah. I mean, she also forgot that I said that
like I hadn't been doing a bunch of stuff because I was ill,
right? Like she quized me on the Only Fan stuff and it's like
I don't want to like be advertising myself anyway, but there's
an additional reason that I don't want to. It's because I've
been ill for months and I'm not updating anything. I was like,
I don't want a bunch of weirdos writing me essays on Only Fans
when I've been inactive on there because I'm ill. And she just
doesn't remember any of this stuff. It's weird.
>> Yeah. I mean, I guess she's her whole thing is going
to be like, "Oh, you should take it down if you don't like it."
And it's like, okay, apparently people have to take >> It's
not liking it. It's just like people go through periods of inactivity
because they got like other [__] going on. I don't
know. Yeah.
All right. >> Everybody I meet falls into Jaw category,
Chad Logic category, like a very specific category. I'm like,
"Oh, you you're the cesspool. You're like the virus and all of
the already traumatized communities that go in and make it 10
times worse for everybody >> before though." So, >> okay.
Okay. So, um I feel like I So, basically, just so you know what
I saw, Jay, he basically um he mentioned the SWAT stuff there,
how he would like call SWAT on his bros and his and whatnot.
Um, and like pretend that there's like a drug bus so that they
could like reach and like get the drugs. We used to dress up
as SWAT and break in. Like I bet it was also like I don't know
if you guys grew up like like you do things but then it depends
on like what version of the thing you're doing again. What shade
of blue are you engaging in? Cognitive dissonance. You said do
you did you have a boyfriend from Canada? No. Did you No. Where
did that come from? Why did you think that? Is that to me? Are
you talking to me or somebody else? That's so random. I have
not dated anyone from Canada. That would be fun though. I hear
Canadians are great but I'm married so never mind. That would
not be fun >> with them. I think that was you dress up
as SWAT. That's what I heard. Is that the SWAT stuff you're referring
to, Jay? >> I have no idea. >> Okay, gotcha. Um,
okay.
what's the purpose in this clip? Maybe you can. I'm not >> point
out that he's making up stories that are so unbelievable that
literally nobody believes him. >> Literally nobody believes
him. >> True. Nobody thinks that actually happened. Literally,
nobody thinks that actually happened. This is completely made
up. >> You don't believe that drugdeing addicts were pretending
to be SWAT to break in to steal each other's stuff? Yeah, just
like I don't believe he was a cat burglar who stole a bunch of
from
>> He doesn't believe anything about Tom's life. But instead
of just saying that, he spreads rumors. He gets people against
him. He puts on trials. Why are we even having this conversation?
People like they're allowed to not believe you
>> Which people?
>> Like, who really cares that much about Tom? That was
like his majorly big fan beforehand that we've turned against
>> I have no idea. Um, I literally stopped covering it.
And when I stopped covering it, Tom sold like a 100 viewers.
So, I don't know. >> Yeah. Like, who are these people?
That's so stupid.
>> Sorry. Hold on. I'm just
I went out for lunch earlier today and I have like take out that
I brought back home. So, I'm just trying to finish it right now.
>> Just ignore them.
Don't do that. They do like
>> I had a piece of naan and then I was spooning stuff
onto it so both of my hands were busy. >> Trials. They're
like little witch hunters. These people are like literally the
worst kind of people. Like why didn't you just say in my opinion
I don't think that Tom is telling the truth. Okay, cool.
>> Kelly, some chatters think you look bald right now because
of your um your headset covering your hair. >> You can
see her hairline. >> Yeah, I know. I understand.
>> I had a headache, so I took my hair clip >> Crucifixions.
He like tries to like paint Tom in a light that's like not accurate.
It's like he That's what I'm saying. That's not normal. Not let
me rephrase. It's pretty normal. It's not healthy. Healthy people
do not like without evidence smear people. Even the evidence
that Jaw He's Amber Heard. He's Amber Turd, bro. He's literally
Amber Heard. The same evidence like Amber kept trying to use
just like solidify Johnny's like innocence in a way cuz I know
it's a spectrum in so many ways. It reminds me literally this
reminds me of like a very specific category of people where they
their evidence proves Tom is
>> It literally
exonerates Tom. >> Why are we Amber? Well, I just believe
>> We need that on about
>> I literally have no idea. >> Well, then just say
you don't believe him. Don't say there's evidence. Don't say
there's tons of people. It's all a
>> Aside from his parents.
So, as somebody with who's worked in the addiction field, I'm
not going to lie, none of this is like really shocking to me.
Um I I don't know if it's true. Um I've definitely been experienced
to my clients doing significantly more extreme things than this.
>> Let's let's go beyond the addiction stuff then. Um Tom,
can you tell me about your work? >> Oh, that's not working
anymore. So, let's do something else. Once you get down to it,
there is nothing actually to paint Tom as anything other than
like a normal person who's just having normal people problems.
>> Is a rhetoric coach. M >> okay this is other my
other favorite part of the concept so you know jobs are made
up so I'm just going to preface this he's going to make the claim
that Tom lied about being something he's >> guys jobs are
totally made up >> and unless you're breaking the law you
can say you're anything and it's fine cuz bubbles is going to
be the argument >> not okay do you guys know the meme on
Tik Tok where it's like how do you have a different title for
um like your job to make it sound better you know how people
do that okay I did this when I came into YouTube I asked my priest
friend I was like I need a job title for my job because I don't
really know what it is and people want a name for So, we made
up a job title, professional conversationalist. I've moved away
from that now because I just want to do a YouTuber stuff, but
people want me to have a title. They're like, "Hey, what's your
title?" People really like titles.
categories the way my brain does, right?
>> But in general, like jobs are made up. What's the difference
between a nanny and a babysitter? In my bubble, huge difference.
And other people's bubbles, no difference, right? In my bubble,
oh my god. A nanny is completely a nanny is a salaried worker.
Let's get someone who makes talking about bubbles >> streaming
where going over debates. >> To be fair, she's talking
about bubbles as a way to excuse Tom's behavior and how he lies
about what he's done for work, right? >> Yeah. You need
to get better with the skip button, buddy. I don't know what
to >> Okay.
All right. >> And coaching people on rhetoric. >> Yeah.
Cuz people want you to have a fancier title instead of just calling
yourself a YouTuber because they don't think YouTuber is a job.
And then you can like that's what like people do is they branch
out into different. That's why I'm like just stick to YouTuber.
>> Okay. You never intimated anywhere that you were paid
to be a Reddit coach? >> No. The job that I worked was
in linguistic marketing for franchises that owned a bunch of
different restaurants and in that yes that's like the the job
the only job that you could >> [__] I want
refer to but no I didn't get
>> Um hold on. K says Jtock speaks with such confidence
then confidently admits his ignorance in the situation and people
still listen to him. That's what I mean. Wait, what? >> Watch
this guy and >> so not like confidently unconfident like
hey I don't really know. I don't have my time stamps here. I've
literally not prepared like this is the whole time and I'm clearly
like I'm asking him about this stuff
cuz I don't know and I want to hear him say it because after
this I'm going to go look up a bunch of the [__]
that he said. Like I'm going to go look this up.
Like that. That was my whole goal here was to get him to say
all of these things that I'd heard about, get him to give a firm
answer, and then I can go and look.
>> Kelly just wants to rewatch the same video. I mean,
that's what I don't want to do. That's why I want just to go
to get a bit better with the skip button. >> Well, so I
didn't watch very much of the Britney stream and I was a part
of this conversation. So, the point of me being here is to evaluate
what Britney's
Yeah, but some she rambles a bit and like there's nothing lost
sometimes in skipping uh where she's talking about bubbles, whatever
the else I don't know. >> I am. That's why I say it takes
two to be in a toxic relationship. If you're willing to engage
with Jtock, there is a part of you that either hasn't learned
or is new to his content or is just as toxic as he is. I blocked
him, by the way. He's blocked. I don't want to engage with him.
Oh, I should block him on Twitter, too. I'll block him on Twitter.
I'll remember. Okay. I already blocked him on YouTube. I'm going
to block him on Twitter. I don't want to engage with you.
>> Okay. cuz I already know what kind of category of person
this is. And nope, the rule is do not engage with these types
of people, right? Do not engage. They are insane version of insane.
>> I've never done this where I like feel the need to talk
about how insane or bad people are. Like just I just labeling
someone as bad in general is such a bizarre concept to me. It's
like I don't know these people well enough to determine if they're
like bad or good. Like all I know is there some stupid drama
online. It's just like she's so strange. I mean, I know she's
not the only one in this community that does it. It's like, I
don't like this person, therefore they're bad,
>> but as a concept, it's very weird to me. I I don't know.
I don't get it. >> Sure, she's conflating me with other
people who do drama in this space and are much looser about like
what they'll cover um in terms of like potentially doing harm
to people. I don't think those are bad people. I think a lot
of them are very funny people. And I think probably
if they were focused on me for some reason, I would either need
to know that I could easily defend against what they're saying
or I wouldn't engage. Those are like the two options, right?
But I think they're funny. I don't think they're terrible people.
She's just like, "Oh, these other people are terrible." But she's
conflating you with them, which is whatever, but it's it's weird
cuz I've very explicitly got different ways. >> I mean,
she's also conflating me with being here. And I'm like,
it's odd because she doesn't apply that principle to Erodite,
right? She doesn't like Destiny.
Um, and presumably if she doesn't and thinks he's a bad person
because of whatever reasons she has,
but she can excuse Erodite, but if I'm here, somehow that is
worse. And I'm just like, uh,
>> Natalie says, "This is literally a panel on Tom's character
or something." Well, it started off with a private conversation
on stream between Erdite and Tom and then it turned into this.
Um, which is fine. Like, that's fine, you know. So, here we are.
>> That's actually a good point, Ralph. Uh, it's so lucky
for me that she just gave me five hours of free content to do
with her whole stream here. That's very lucky. Thank you.
Thank you, Britney >> Yeah, I called Tom weird.
>> The biggest crime of all. >> The biggest crime
of all
to be a rhetoric coach. I coach people. You don't think you misled
people about your qualifications and your job titles when realistically
you were basically assigned to teach new Pizza Hut employees
how to upsell combos?
>> Not new Pizza Hut employees and not >> Oh, it
was Domino's. Sorry.
first off. >> Is this something recent? Sorry. >> Okay.
That's That's me being a piece of [__] Okay. But
it's funny, so I'm allowed to do it
anyway. >> The rhetoric coach stuff. Is this something
that you promoted? >> Just cuz I have no conduct for any
of this. So, what Jay, are you talking about something that he's
promoted like since starting streaming and stuff? Like, is it
a service or what's the Okay, so since he started streaming,
he probably uses a stream to promote the service as well as like
a rhetoric coach. Um, and >> him saying he had experience
as a rhetoric coach. >> Oh, he misled people on his >> Okay.
People misleading you on purpose and then people not knowing
what they're doing, kind of figuring it out, misspeaking, using
different words. Totally different. JTO misleads people on purpose
for views and clicks, but he wouldn't see himself that way even
though that's absolutely what he's doing. misleading this whole
>> What's she referring to? >> Like to see some implication
cuz again
Aerodite had mentioned this a couple times as well that like
I was doing this with a financial incentive. It's like no when
I started doing this I had literally zero financial incentive.
There was no financial incentive there. It was just funny. It's
literally always just been funny >> around Tom. So we think
he knows something we don't know. But every time he's proven
wrong, he goes, "Okay, but what about this?" And then every time
he's proven wrong, he's like, "What about this?" And every time
he's proven wrong, it's like, well, what about this? He doesn't
have anything. So, he misleads the conversation, right? Derails
it, doubles down,
right? So, again, like he's saying Tom misleads people. Okay?
All people on some spectrum have misspoken, misled, confused,
spoken incorrectly.
All of it. All of we've all made mistakes. There's a difference
between being a person who consistently has a pattern of misleading
people, which JTO exhibits, and a person like Tom who like tends
to fall into a very normie bubble of like, you know, casual lying
or lying for like protecting your like person. >> I feel
like, and somebody can correct me if I'm wrong here, I feel like
I'm pretty clear when I'm like being uh like a piece of and and
like memeing on stuff. I think I was very clear with the Tomfest
thing. I don't think very many people in this specific community.
Now, there's an argument for harm in adjacent communities where
they don't hear the whole thing. But in this specific community,
I don't think anybody actually thought Tom was a second,
right? Before before the whole blowup, >> dude, there was
a time where before the whole blowup, um I even leaned into the
joke like, "Yeah, Tom's over." And then you like my joke and
then explained how you weren't being serious. >> Oh, okay.
Yeah. I I But I just I don't understand. I like I literally don't.
It's lying about somebody is not a meme. Uh
have you seen how funny it's been this whole time? I'm sorry
to tell you sometimes it can be funny. I'm sorry. Yeah, in my
bubble you can lie about people and it can be funny. Okay. >> Personality
or privacy or parts about yourself like it's very normal, right?
Like Tom falls into a >> you just have to say that you're
lying. Okay. You just have to say that you're >> Very like
normal pattern of human behavior to me. Jtock is the one who
actually stands out and projects that onto other people so people
don't think he's the one perpetrating the the issue, but he is
the misleading character. So Jto is that category of person who
is the misleader, but his misleading is to convince you other
people are the misleaders, but he's actually the one exhibiting
the pattern >> to do certain things and be like uh his
professional qualifications, the titles he's held in order to
make himself seem >> This is just not Yeah, this just isn't
true. I've always been very clear. I don't have qualifications.
I don't have a degree. I would never call myself a linguist because
I don't have a degree. I literally had this conversation with
Kyla on stream and we were talking about the differences in how
she was kind of uh getting in trouble for like degrees and like
that and I talked about the fact that like yes, I don't have
a degree and I've never claimed to be any sort of authority but
I have a job where I bring it up and because it sounds super
official, people start putting some sort of like idea that I'm
>> that's very normal. Everyone does that. They think this
is going to come up later in the conversation where people will
hear a label and think it's much more important. You're someone's
friend. Oh, you're someone's boyfriend. Oh, you're some
I didn't notice that. Good one. one's partner. Oh, you're someone's
lover. They put a lot of responsibility on those words which
in other bubbles they don't. So that's going to come up later
with Tom where people like labels mean a lot of assuming this
this part of the internet is so bad at just assuming. They're
making an ass out of them and you them and me whatever however
the saying goes because they are >> I was going to like
really try hard to put this in Britney's terms. The reason I
called Thomas Fest is because I was chatting in Spicy quite a
bit right and in that bubble. Okay. in that bubble and community
of people. Uh I was called a fest for some fairly innocuous comments
about DK's girlfriend where I I like was like as a meme leaning
into oh uh why does like DK's such a skitso? Why does he have
this girl as his girlfriend? She's like way too cute for him.
I said that and I was called afest. You know what? That was funny.
That was very funny. And so that was the context in which I was
calling Thomas was I'd heard about stuff there and I was just
saying the same thing in like DGG logs. Oh, he's a second best.
That's like how this whole thing started. But under Britney's
like worldview, that's totally fine. No.
And like, so to be clear, I'm not blaming Spicy for that. I thought
it was funny when they called me a second fest, and now I think
it's funny when I call Tomfest, but it's not serious. It's not
like the the level of evidence you need to make that accusation
is not very high in that community. And that's why every time
I've talked to him about it, I can say we could use a different
term. I'm describing behaviors. Describing behaviors I think
are wrong or or possibly harmful.
>> so assuming they never get real clarification because
they're just too dumb. I'm telling you, this space is just filled
with the dumbest people I've ever seen in my life. And I mean
that in the nicest way possible. >> Fargo Lefty, I actually
went out of my way multiple times to say it was a meme. It was
not meant to be serious. Tom is no no threat to women. That was
my consistent position for like weeks or months.
All right. Cherry just said, "Why are you looping on this?" I
intentionally I intentionally like cucked her joke about >> Nobody
cares. >> Uh Chad is asking me about
Chat's literally engaging with me, Kelly. Why are you literally
yell at me? You yell at me for not engaging with chat.
>> Yes, it's because we've already like gone over like
whether he's really or not like about 100 times. It's like >> I
just don't think you have the information you have. You are obviously
unread. Like I do not believe any of you have any life experience,
right? There's no way. By the way you talk, you tell me you have
no life experience. I don't believe any of you. Mine is Tom and
Kyla and the people I like like Wick and everybody else, but
everybody else in this life. >> I don't think I'm talking
about you, but I might be talking about you. Okay, that's another
thing in this space. People hear me say >> I don't think
Tom's life experience would be beneficial to anybody
>> like being a criminal, getting locked up and doing drugs.
All right, pass on that life experience. Fargo lefty, if Tom
had actually raped somebody, if we had Tom on video violently
raping somebody and I called him like, would it be weird for
me to call him a pass after seeing that
>> Cuz that is what happened. Over time, new evidence came
to light that made the joke suddenly seem like it might be a
I hope you understand. >> They think, "Oh, she's talking
about me. I'm probably not talking about you, but I could be
talking about you."
Okay, I might be talking about you, but I'm probably not talking
but I could be.
>> I know what I'm talking about. But even if you go like
I have it even on the I have a bunch of clips of it. I have a
on the like the doc about gender where literally at the beginning
it says like I'm not
getting tired the job that makes things
always expended. >> But you definitely brought up multiple
times on stream that you were a rhetoric coach and not went on
to clarify. >> Okay, you actually Hold on. Hold on. Hold
on. I actually, okay, even if he brought it up 10 times in his
like years of streaming, I don't care. This is a non-issue for
me. Most bubbles have made up jobs. You know, most of the controversies
that are happening in the modern world aren't >> literally
every every criticism of Tom that we lay out, she's literally
just like bubbles, bro. It's actually the response to everything
she has or everything she hears. It's just bubbles, okay? Literally,
like lying is okay in your in that bubble. Lying is okay in that
bubble. Um, misleading people on your credentials is okay in
that bubble. Um, you don't have to be accurate as a streamer
at all. It's like, okay, what what is the point? aren't real.
Like they're they're not real until now. Like example, in a lot
of religious bubbles, lots of religious pastors or community
members or counselors are counselors, but they're not medical
counselors. Even
>> Zach, I don't keep flip-flopping at all. >> Isn't
that in your bubble? >> Did you really need to stop just
to fight? Zach,
popped a bubble for me. I always thought this is a bubble. I
thought therapy meant you had to have some sort of >> But
Kelly, you cannot. You cannot respond to chat at all while we're
not responding to chat. Okay, I won't and you can't. >> It
doesn't need to call yourself a >> So if rhetoric coach
is a BS title, every job is anyways, guys. It's a construct.
He can call himself a rhetoric coach and make up a job title.
You're allowed to do that. You can call yourself a coach and
say, "Oh yeah, I'm a t coach. I look at t and tell you if they're
good or bad." You're allowed to do that. This is America. Red,
white, and blue, baby. You can do whatever you want, baby. Okay?
So again, >> this is America to a Canadian and a British
creating jobs. So we have a title put on something and you're
figuring out how to make a job. Dog walker. You think dog walker
was a job before it was a job? Don't be dumb with me right now.
I will spank the out of you, chat. Do not be dumb with me right
now. Do you think jobs aren't things we made up? Jobs are literally
things we make up. Okay? And unless somebody is abusing their
title in order to
not pick up a job and putting a title on >> literally just
saying nothing matters and you can do whatever you want. >> I
hear you. I just want to actually hear. So the issue with that
I'm trying to figure out is is it reasonable to conclude that
your audience would have thought that you had certain levels
of education that you leaned into it for some level of authority
that you maybe shouldn't have? Like these are going to be like
the main things obviously that matter. So, my question is emperor
at the time. Um,
>> Uh, sorry. Tree wants to hop on for a
>> Hey.
Oh my god. Has she been watching?
I was thinking about that earlier. >> She did say she was
like, "Did you just say you feel sorry for Tom?" I want to hop
on real quick. Um,
>> I was thinking about the her and Britney thing because
I feel like Britney is acting real dominant, real top to her
chat ever since Tree called her a sub.
Uh, Tree, if you're still watching, I just gave you permissions
to join this
She just wants This is better than just watching a video anyway.
So if Tree wants to join, I'm down to take a quick break. Talk
to Tree.
>> Annie is so American coded. Don't say things like that.
Has Tree seen any of the previous
Did she say anything or she just said she's coming on? I think
she would have watched some of my content and your your stuff
like our stuff with Tom. >> Oh, yeah. No, I meant like
the Oh, so tell me whilst we're waiting, what is the part where
Erdog are really mad at you? Cuz you said it's before where this
started cuz I haven't watched that.
oh, we pulled that up right now. Are her Twitch bods behind a
payw wall? >> I mean, you don't have to get the bod. You
could just tell me maybe. So, >> well, okay. But you're
trusting me to recall it perfectly. So, what happened
um she was asking me why she was trying to pin me down on like,
"Oh, do you think it's a meme or is it serious?"
And I my brain was mush. So, I I was like explaining how I thought
at different times. And she's like, "Well, it seems like you're
going back and forth." It was like, "No, no, no. It was a meme."
And even the times where I said it wasn't, like I got a clip
of Tom me and I like paused and I was like, "You know what? Tom's
a [__] fest again. This guy like I think that's very
clearly a joke, but maybe it's not. I don't know. I'm I'm pretty
sure it's a joke. I feel like I was always joking while also
but but here's the thing. I was joking >> about this pest
thing because it bothered him. But when I originally brought
it up with him, there were some behaviors that I was like, "Hey,
this is kind of weird."
>> Yeah. For someone that wouldn't like that label, he
sure did do a lot of uh weird festy things afterwards. >> Sure.
And like I don't know, for some reason in my head that can exist
as a as a state that's fine and I can say it's a joke because
I could like I'm trying to think they're like things where like
reality overlaps with your joke and you leave something out and
imply something.
>> anyway, we can talk about it after. What's up Tree?
How's it going?
>> So Jess, you said you were you feeling sorry for Tom.
how I just tuned into the stream and I came in with just when
you were saying that >> I think I was saying that I don't
know I legitimately don't know if he can control how he lies
sometimes
like there are times where he's been lying and it's like completely
there's no reason there's no benefit um if he was like Mchavelian
if he was like trying to lie to get out of stuff it wouldn't
even make sense it's like everybody's like it's totally fine
to just tell us what we all know is true and he's like no no
that's not true right and I I don't know. I legitimately am not
sure that he
>> can tell.
>> So anyway, I feel I feel bad for him being brought in
here on that one. >> Or is it possible that he can tell
and he knows that this method works? because I I believe people
do what works.
And he noticed that it it gets it gives him that pass where he
doesn't have to have accountability
because he's really good at constantly lying. He's a lying. He
like he'll badger you with his lies. And I'm speaking from experience.
But the thing about it is is I'm such a [__] that
I will not let you badger me. I don't care how many times we
you repeat the lie. I'm going to keep showing everyone that you're
lying and that you're doing this to escape accountability. And
but the biggest problem I have with Tom the fool is that he hates
admitting when he's wrong. And that's a narcissistic trait that
I think anybody can control and um he's much aware of it. What
do you think about that argument?
>> Um and I just have to see a lot more evidence of it,
I guess. But like I feel like I feel like there have been a couple
situations and I'd have to see where he's lying. But like I feel
like there have been situations where he has no incentive to
lie. It actually hurts him to lie in like every sense and he
still lies. Like it seems compulsive I guess is the word. >> Maybe
he likes being treated like a
He just gets like the scapegoat. He acts like an idiot and then
everyone's like a poor little victim addict. He's just being
an idiot. Actually,
Kelly has a point there because the fact that he keeps lying.
Look at what you're doing. You having you're having sympathy
for him. You're feeling sorry for him. And there's possibly it's
possibly if people are thinking the same thing like a he's a
you can't help but lie. Let's you know, let's not be so hard
on him and make him responsible for the the lies that come out
of his mouth.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I think it's kind of up because there are
plenty of like addicts and people that have been through trauma
and whatever that aren't like insane compulsive liars. Like I
don't know how bad he really is now. Like I don't particularly
care if he's like embellishing a bunch of stories from his past
to make himself sound cooler. It's like pretty indifferent to
me. It's like if someone's lying a bunch, but those lies don't
really hurt anyone. I don't know how much I really care. But
I don't like the implication that that you know like addicts
always have these types of behaviors and therefore it's excusable.
It's just kind of weird things to be >> Agreed. Agreed.
And those of us who have um shortcomings, we seek help
for those shortcomings. Um is he not aware that he is doing this
or does he not care? Because a lot of us who want to be better
people, we seek professional help or we seek the help of good
people around us to say, "Hey, I have a problem. Hey, this is
going on with me. Um, I need your assistance." You know what
I'm saying? You don't have to do that on a stream, but if you
want to be a better person, you will seek uh other people that
can assist you in being a better person. But if you like to be
a piece of which he does, he is not going to have accountability.
He's going to constantly say being a piece of [__]
because it works for him. >> Yeah. I mean, if you've got
people like Britney, they're just excusing the unhinged things
he says because we almost got him to a point where he was like
acknowledging at least somewhat that some of that stuff was weird.
But now, like she's saying, "Oh, this is normal." Like she he's
just going to backtrack now. It's like, "Oh, I've got people
to like excuse all my insane behavior and all the weird he said."
I was just like, "Brilliant." like he she genuinely thinks like
she's helping this guy by doing this. I don't get it. But
>> yeah, there you go, Cherry. I was going to say, why
is she inserting herself into that?
>> I have no clue.
>> It's like support group building.
I mean, I I I don't know. I just I think people were trying to
help him. And you might be right like some of it might just be
he notices like he's just evolved into this >> wasn't she
helping him? Was it like like I actually listened to that live
stream. Okay. And talk about a ride or die friend.
You know what I'm saying? Like she was there holding him accountable.
He kept going around it. She was like, "You told me to watch
out for optics." This is what Zonia said. She said, "Look, you
said optics means a lot." And so when I'm showing you that this
is not this is basically uh an optic cancer, you don't care.
You move you uh you uh deflect or move the goalpost. So he has
and that's just one person I know u cuz I actually listened to
that stream on Za end and I was like the way he kept fighting
against someone
um that was on his team for a while but really was sincere and
cuz she kept saying over and over again I am saying this because
I care about you. I love you as a friend and I want you to be
a better person. He didn't give a [__]
>> I'll be right back. my >> Yeah, that was weird.
>> But I think also Britney I don't know criticizes Za
as well. I feel like at some point
>> Oh, I don't Yeah, I don't know if it's I swear I listen
to some I don't know. She just seems to think like everyone else
is insane and she's the only I don't
>> At this point I'm just like all right.
She said some insane things about me and the only thing I did
was say, "Oh, this guy's a weirdo.
That was it. That's cool.
Spiraling. I'm like, he is a weirdo.
Am I not allowed to say that about people now?
>> How mean I am? I'm like, right. Jesus. >> So,
she's she's okay with the harassment or the advantage of someone
that's in the industry. I don't think you consider yourself in
I don't know. I'm I'm just asking. Do you consider yourself in
the sex industry? >> Um, I'm kind of like adjacent with
it. Like if this makes sense because I don't mind. So like if
people call me a sex worker, I don't bother to argue with it
cuz at the end of the day I use Only Fans as a platform. And
so sort of like arguing against it feels like a waste of time.
And also I have no I have no problem. But also,
>> this proves that Britney's full of because she's always
talking about positive and, you know, we need to be on the side
of women and those who and not um uh vilify any woman that's
in the industry, blah blah blah. But yet still, she's taking
Tom's side, you know what I'm saying? And not holding him >> Yeah.
I don't think she saw it as harassment at all. I think she saw
it as jokes and her argument is like I do what I do and so I'm
supposed to just yeah take it I guess >> when obviously
my argument would be if it's in the like if it's in it's circumstantial
right so in c certain places
it's fine and if I consent to it it's fine if people want to
be to some
>> but if there is no consent and it's in a really inappropriate
setting then I'm going to be like This is weird and somebody's
kickstream
is an inappropriate setting for people to be that weird in their
chat. It's not it's not my only fans.
It's not like a normal place to be like that. Additionally, you
would be considered socially awkward if you bumped into a star
in the street and started like talking about how you like jack
off to her. It's just like have some social skills. I don't know.
>> Hey Miss, you always wanted my just
I don't know. Don't make people feel weird and uncomfortable,
bro. I don't know what to say. >> Kelly, you're right.
She um she doesn't agree with Za or support Za >> or sass
with Frra, it seems, anymore. She thinks that they are both bad
friends for having done it publicly and
>> opportunistic or whatever. >> I don't think she
agrees with anyone by the end of this. So, it's like,
yep, she goes through like a whole like period of calling people
Uh, I think she even caused Tom by the end of it. So, I was like,
"All right, then just everyone else is the problem, but uh, you
are the moral arbiter of all of this and correct and just and
okay, cool." Sounds like Britney is a little unhappy
cuz if you're just pointing fingers at everybody else and you're
not pointing them back at yourself like you to me your life is
so and this is my opinion nobody else's opinion here but it seems
like your Britney if you're listening this sounds like your life
is so that you want to sit up here and deflect and distract yourself
by making everybody else the villain
and making everybody else bad and criticizing every else everybody
else bad. But what the have you been doing with yourself?
>> Show me somebody. Show me somebody. She has what? Really?
>> She She has been saying people are bad a >> Oh,
okay. I thought she took it. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, when when are we going to get some self
critiquing on her end, you know?
>> Yeah. Doubt. Extra doubt. >> Listen, she's a level
five, so she already knew what all of her flaws were and she's
already fixed all of them because she's a level five. Um, I didn't
get that memo, but thanks for updating me there, JS. I appreciate
that. >> Yeah, she can also fly.
>> Yeah, I
it's I like hesitate. I can understand what she's saying, but
like obviously when you excuse everything with bubble, like everything
Britney says, she's just like when I like somebody, it's a part
of their bubble. When I dislike somebody, it's like a toxic behavior.
Yeah, she should be able to apply the whole bubbles thing to
you
>> just as much as she's doing it to him.
>> Okay, that's all I have to say. I'll just sit here and
watch. >> Sorry, I'm uh I'm also arguing in my chat cuz
Kelly wanted me to stop getting one guy on stream. So now I'm
just getting one guy in chat. So sorry about that. I don't even
watch the chat because it's you can't listen to Well, maybe that's
just me. >> No, I'm the same way. I'm just bad at listening
sometimes if I'm watching the
>> I need to listen to what everyone is saying in the Discord.
I can't watch the chat at all. I do this with everybody I'm talking
to. And so I want I don't ever want to um mis
uh understand someone. I don't want to I want to make sure I
understand people's arguments and what they're saying perfectly.
So, I just like right now I'm looking at Kelly in her pretty
and pink and her pink uh headphones. It's a big distraction,
but I'm listen I'm looking at her. Yeah. Thumbs up. Gotcha.
And I'm listen I'm looking at her but listening to everybody
else.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I'm the same way that like um sometimes
when I'm watching a video, I'll be watching chat and I'll miss
something that said in the video and then everybody in chat will
clown me because I missed what was said in the video that like
everyone heard, but I missed it because I was reading chat. >> Yeah,
I can't multitask very well
>> Yeah, I I do read chat just so I can take people's jokes
like faster than others can read it.
All right,
>> let me see. I've I've offered Discord. No, no, no. I've
offered Discord or ban to a bunch of people. None of them are
taking it.
>> Shocking that none of these people have enough of a
spine to come in and defend any of their opinions. Incredible.
>> Coach, do you remember how like did he bring it up as
just like a past experience? Did he bring it up as like no trust?
>> It doesn't matter. It doesn't matter. He's allowed to
do this. He's allowed to coach people. He's allowed to make a
thing out of it. He can even sell a course. If you have a problem
with that model of jobs, cool. Everyone's got a problem with
some model of everything. I This is a
>> nonissue. It is a non-issue to create a job and to make
money off that job. As long as you are not maliciously hurting
your clients, as long as you are not like lying to them. As long
as you It doesn't matter to me. I don't care. This is a non-issue.
I know what's what. Like, okay. >> He would use it as an
argument defeater sometimes when there was like a sale and people
were arguing about definitions or something like that. He'd be
like, "Guys, I was a rhetoric coach. I understand. This is how
language works." And then try to proceed from there. >> Yeah.
But like, so who cares? Who cares? What is he impersonating?
What? So,
>> literally gigachad. Who cares about lying? It's all
fine. Okay. His b his bubble is that of a liar. So, obviously
he's going to lie. Guys, what are we what are we even talking
about? >> So, she's okay with someone being a
>> Uh, basically, yeah, she's Well, she's excused all of
his lies because she's like, "Oh, sometimes people have trauma
and like obviously addicts lie in like different ways." She's
She's literally wheeled out like a hundred different excuses
for why it's okay for him to
>> Yeah. Excuse my ignorance. What trauma?
>> Uh like childhood trauma growing up in a religious household
where like if you tell the truth about certain things like maybe
things or something, you're going to be like hit or punished
in some way. >> She's like, "Oh, so you know who? I was
tortured growing up. Am I not a liar? WHAT THE HELL?"
>> IT'S like a little much.
>> are you serious?
>> I mean, her argument is everyone is a liar, so why do
we care? Basically,
>> yeah, that's another part of her argument. She's saying
that I lied about Tom, so obviously Tom lying is not a big deal,
I guess.
>> When most of the things come out your mouth is a lie,
how does that make you a decent person? How does that make you
an
>> Well, she doesn't seem to differentiate between someone
who lies and someone who lies significantly more than average.
There's just everyone's a liar. There is no difference to her.
So, yay.
>> Yay. That's pretty much it. I don't know. Like,
>> makes perfect sense if you're >> frustrating to
watch. It's frustrating to watch. Okay. It is frustrating to
watch. Also, why won't any of these people join the Discord?
If they if they actually think they've got me on something, why
wouldn't they join the Discord and make fun of me? >> Who?
What names? >> Uh, Jacob and then another guy was named
Zach, but Zach explicitly was like, "I'm not going to join the
Discord. I'm just going to make a different YouTube account."
So, Gigach, I guess. >> I shouldn't have done that. Like,
that was stupid. There's other times where I did it where people
like there's a specific debate that I'm thinking of where people
kept like, >> "Yeah, Natalie says if he was claiming to
have degrees or something, that'd be different." Yeah. If he
was claiming to be like certified or gone to college or if he
says like oh he's a master's degree or yeah like a PhD Kayla
said that would be different if he was if oh my god I keep blowing
up my own mic. If he said if he was appealing to authority by
saying he had like an educated background, that'd be so different.
>> Pushing me on like you you haven't read Chomsky, you
haven't read this person, you don't know anything about this.
And we were arguing over how we come to definitions. And so I
kept saying like guys, I know what I'm talking >> by the
way. I disagree with Tom on like rhetoric and and terminology.
The way we come to terminology is cultural. I think it is so
specific to the bubble, right? So like in my opinion, >> like
Tom and I would disagree on how rhetoric is used because he's
we're talking about different shades of blue, right? Bing says
it's called leaving up the resume, which by the way you're coached
to do often. We should just skip every time she starts talking
about
>> I promise it's like
I don't know what it means. She said >> is that why she
has those different colors of blues
>> up on the screen. >> Different shades of blue
for different types of liars.
>> And no one understands that Tom is just a different
shade of blue. They don't get it.
Yo, this is
extra.
You know, I I got to pat myself on the back. I remember when
everybody loved Britney
and everybody was like, "Oh, Tree. Oh, Tree, you're a domina.
You should and she's a submissive. You guys should do some content
together." I was like, "Nope." I said, "Nope. Why not? Why not?"
Nope. I said, "Yeah, y'all can like her. That's fine. But, you
know, something I'm not I'm not I'm not pulling towards her and
she's not there's something about her I'm not gravitating to."
And ta, I was right.
Yeah. I mean, I mean, there's always a decent chance that anyone
in this community is going to go psychotic at any point in time,
so I don't know. Nothing surprises me anymore.
What's up, Rally?
>> Yo, who >> we talking about? >> Britney
Simon did a whole stream on my stream with Aerodite.
>> She said is trash.
>> And insane. >> Sounds like a good uh opportunity
to debate. Yeah.
>> Uh, no. Cuz she also said she blocked me on everything
and anybody who interacts with me is toxic and loves drama.
>> Oh, well, Britney Simon likes me, I think. So, that's
going to be an interesting conflict. I guess
>> I guess toxic.
>> I think she she just straight up doesn't understand
a lot of stuff about me. She also she's like saying I I'm made
this happen and that I was like ready to crucify Tom when I went
on impromptu. I didn't know that this was going to happen. Like
my lack of evidence is because I had no idea I was ever going
to talk about this again. I had moved past Tom. I didn't >> Yeah,
I'm shocked that this is up again. I mean, I was like, does is
Tom hurting for content? But apparently this was not his idea.
>> Well, so I'm saying I'm saying I heard this. I don't
know for sure cuz somebody was saying that like Erodite was planning
to go down this road and Tom didn't want to. I've heard this
from like three different people now. And so I should make it
very clear. It's it's
>> if Tom wanted to go over this or not.
>> Okay. I I would need to ask Ardite explicitly like,
"Hey, was this your idea to go over this or was this um Tom's
idea to go over this?" Because I do think like it feels very
unfortunate that he's bringing it up again
or he's hurting for content and
and views cuz this is drama. People like this. and uh
he's probably looking at his analytics and was like, "Yo, let
me let's let's start this up again cuz I need to get those views
again." You know, that's a possibility. I could be wrong. I'm
open to be wrong. Unlike Tom.
>> Yeah. I mean, I think it'd be interesting. And I don't
So, when if Aridite brought this up, I don't think she had any
real idea like just how Tom interacts with this stuff specifically.
Like, I think I think if Ardite brought it up, I doubt it was
to like farm views from Tom. I really doubt that. I like completely
doubt that actually.
>> Uh not from Aerodite. No.
>> Well, Nick in chat says that Tom wanted to talk about
making the space better for women. That's something that uh
>> has been talking about.
>> Uh I don't know why she want to talk to him about it.
>> She can make it better like ejecting him into space.
Like what? What? Why? Why would you speak a palm about it? >> Like
why?
>> I just
>> also I don't think >> I don't think Nyx really
likes Aerodite. Okay. So Nick, >> I respect your opinion
a lot, but um probably on Aerodite I'd look for somebody who's
a little less biased.
>> Just saying. >> Was she Was she on Toms?
>> I didn't see that. I didn't see that yesterday. Was
she on his side with like >> Um, she was not really on
a side. I got in an argument with her over something like uh
unrelated basically and so she was arguing with me on something
unrelated, but otherwise I think she was trying to act as a moderator.
>> Yeah. Yep.
>> It was more so to try to get them to engage with me,
but I think overall in g maybe not each and every single time
I've said >> sorry was I I feel like I started talking
there to answer a question and I'm not sure that I answered the
question. was I asked a question there. I'm like actually lost
out. >> Yeah. I wanted to ask something quickly. So the
the next person said um making Tom wanted to talk about making
the space better for women. Like was he asking for advice
or was he trying to make plan? Like what's the context of this?
Like if he's the one bringing it >> maybe he's trying to
rehab.
>> It's so obvious the things he needs to do. Like stop
being a weirdo. I don't think it was like a 10step point for
>> So, he thinks that he can help.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I think it has to do with Arodite's mission.
I don't know why he thinks he can help, but >> he's [__]
>> is the one who's like on a mission to make the space
better for women. >> And Yeah. Yeah. Of course. But
he thinks he has any input.
>> I don't know if it's her space or just like this entire
debate space. I'm not sure. Well, every day space should our
I mean I'm I'm being biased here, but if you're a woman and you're
you're in the position she's in, wouldn't her space be a safe
space for women?
>> Um I don't think it's about safe spaces, right? It was
I think it's sort of um about changing how the community behaves
in some aspects.
>> Okay. Uh cuz there is some like
type of behaviors you get and it's just like if it's a very male-dominated
uh arena like just women become uncomfortable due to the strange
behavior of the men. But it's also like uh I don't know like
the stupid thing you just read where it's just like this is why
I hate women because one woman has been weird and done something
stupid and it's it's not like the egregious type of misogyny
stuff or anything.
>> Yeah, I've I have no idea what
their goals were or I probably should look into that. I should
probably ask some people just for like, hey, how did this start?
What was going on here? That guy. >> It started because
of the canvasing stuff because some men were weird. That's what
the reds were. >> Tom's end. I mean on Tom's end. Sorry.
>> He probably just needs something to make him look better.
I don't know.
>> a big long clarification, but I think in general, I've
been very honest with my audience that I am not any sort of authority
on these things. >> Okay. Um, and so would you agree that
he's also done like the qualifications? Like has he done both
these things or has he really >> I don't really catch a
lot of qualifications. It might have been more of a point before
I came around the community. uh maybe talked about more then,
but since I was part of the community, I didn't catch a lot of
that. >> In the last year is all I care about because people's
content changes so much. My content changes all the time. I want
to know if there's anything Tom has done in the last 12 months
that people have issues with that have nothing to do with their
own personal values.
Cuz if they don't, then they need to shut the [__]
up. I'm not going to shut the up because this was trying to s
for goddamn Lauren D herpes and reference to the law where they
didn't he wanted to her and sit up here and take her side against
her when I was right about the goddamn law. You know, we the
the lawyers agreed with me. The the lawyers agreed with me. Destiny
agreed with me. It is not illegal for the biological mother to
leave her biological children with the biological father. That
is not against the law. And this [__] sit up here
and try to tell me. I don't know what the [__] I
>> did. Did you know that she's like ejected herself out
of the orbit?
>> Huh? What? >> You Oh, you didn't know?
She doesn't know. That's a great bit of news. She She said on
the end of that guy's stream
>> that she has like removed herself now and like she's
not friends with Destiny or anyone. Well, she might still be
friends with Pixie. I'm not sure. >> Oh, happy days. Oh,
happy days. Oh, happy days. >> I don't know if she's leaked
why. Yeah, but like Destiny said it's cuz she got embarrassed
over something that she can't talk about. It was very she would
said she talked about it >> in the chat. He put like she's
embarrassed over something.
>> Oh, I didn't know he brought that. >> Did you
see that? >> No.
Wait, where did I
I I smell
your shell for you JS. Like, how come you're not up on this type
of drama? This is the drama I'm here for. >> Wait, I am
up on this kind of drama. I just I didn't >> uh I listen
I
>> Kelly just informed me about some drama and you didn't
even know about it. >> Wait, no, no, no. I Oh, sorry. The
Destiny message I didn't know about. Everything else I knew about
I covered >> in your Discord and you don't know. >> Well,
yeah, it's in my Discord. I don't know. Yeah, I didn't see >> it.
We also talked about it on his
>> So Destiny put in your Discord for reasons that are
embarrassing for her and stupid for her in brackets, but for
some reason she feels the need to make her issues everyone else's
problem and decides to be public about it in the dumbest ways
possible. And that was at um Exona Killer saying, "Drop the warranty.
Why is she tripping?"
So there you go.
Wait, he brought this
>> all right. It wasn't >> all do the same >> two
days ago. I got you. >> who asked him about that? >> But
two days ago >> exa killer. >> Yeah, Destiny came
into my Discord
and basically said somebody said drop the Laurent. Hold on. I
have to actually Can I get to this message?
>> Yes. Hold on. Uh
it is tripping and then Kelly
got it. It's like I'm living in like Groundhog Day. Oh completely
ignore. >> Now I'm the person who's actually paying attention.
Belly, did you hear what Kelly said? >> I'm not going to
lie to you. I was zoned >> Yeah. And you literally asked
what did Kelly say? So I was about to repeat it. >> You
know what? I will repeat it again. >> Okay. Kelly will
repeat it again. >> The second time you >> I'm getting
a drink. I'll be right back. >> Go ahead, girl. Do >> All right.
So exoner killer says drop the laee. Why she trooping? Destiny
responds for reasons that are embarrassing brackets for her and
stupid brackets for her. But for some reason she feels the need
to make her issues everyone else's problem and decides to be
public about it in the dumbest ways
All right. Did you listen this time? >> Man, it sounds
even better to think. >> Honestly, I thought it was uh
more interesting how you said tripping. Uh >> tripping.
Yeah, >> that's how I imagine Exona killer speaks. Just
like that. >> No G at the end of tripping. So, it's >> I
feel like there's not much information to be derived from that
message from Destiny. But all right. >> Uh I mean, I could
guess. Uh I feel like you could guess as well. Surely you know
enough information. >> It's crazy. She is cray cray.
>> But then that's that's Steven's eml, right? He loves
attracting all types of women, especially the crazy kind. Yeah.
>> Well, no, I'm crazy. I admit it. But my my crazy is
manageable and I'm aware of it. I have self-awareness of my crazy.
>> But my crazy don't >> being crazy. >> Yeah.
I My crazy girl, you cool. My crazy doesn't with other people.
You see what I'm saying? That I care for and that I like. If
I like you, you know what I'm saying? My crazy don't [__]
with you. I [__] with you, but I don't [__]
with you. You know what I'm saying? >> Oh, look. I just
I just did the thing that I didn't want to do. Look, I dragged
a window onto this screen.
I just did it. I hate display capture. I'm never doing this again.
Okay. >> Yeah. Don't do display capture from that. That's
how you get the wash >> Yeah, exactly.
But well, that would never happen to me precisely cuz I literally
only put streaming related stuff on this computer. There is >> Oh,
of course your lollies on the other
Listen, if I had anything unsavory, it would be on my personal,
not on.
>> But you notice how there haven't been any issues since
you've been using window capture, not app capture.
>> I mean, monitor, not window. >> You misspoke.
But >> yes, but I corrected it before you had the chance
to stupid.
>> I don't know what was happening with app capture there.
I have no idea, but I'll fix it. >> You say that every
stream and there's >> I do not. I do not. Entire streams
where I have no technical difficulties. >> Either something
to do with the image or something to do with the sound. And it's
very annoying. Every single time stream. >> Yes, there
have been many entirely smooth streams. >> I don't believe
it.
>> Is the one telling lies now? >> I'm going to start
making Wolf Gang make like uh weirder caricatures of you guys
that I can put up on screen when you're being annoying.
>> Weirder. Brilliant. I don't know exactly what it'll
look like yet. I think I'll Kelly will be in blackface. Okay.
And then she'll be in blackface with all the other black characters
who are here. It'll be very embarrassing for you.
>> I don't know why you're racist, Kelly.
>> I mean, if you want me to turn up even less than I already
am turning up, by all means, feel the need to do that.
>> Well, you wanted me to come up with something on the
spot and I didn't have
>> Okay, this is the clip of Lauren and Alex and the thing
about Destiny.
some people trying to do some >> I think I think Destiny
would probably be fine with keeping these things private,
but Lauren keeps making like tidbits of it public. So I got to
imagine that's like frustrating him to a large degree. It probably
means >> well in private I would imagine that it also means
she's probably saying more than she's saying in public. But >> this
is like the least surprising thing on the planet.
>> Whenever anyone like goes out of their way to like be
like, "Oh, I'm so loyal and like aggressively fight." I'm like,
she'll be gone in 6 months. I could just [__] put
on the timer. >> I don't know if Tree knows this, but I
offered a bet, an open bet to anybody, $250, that Lauren de Laguna
be kicked out of the orbit before Farra was. And I offered the
same bet to Lauren. I said, Lauren, if you can control yourself.
Here's the bet. You can take it. $250 bucks. And she did not
take it. >> She did not take it. She didn't.
>> That goes crazy.
THAT IS REALLY CRAZY.
>> YEAH. SO, I just feel completely vindicated. Okay.
>> Here's a clip. Here's a clip. >> You try though.
>> Yeah. There's always people doing [__] up.
I actually cut a bunch of people out of my life. No more Destiny.
No more >> No more Destiny. >> No. Gone completely.
>> What happened with Destiny?
Um,
>> if you want, you can tell me offline. >> Yeah,
it's fine. I'll just I'll tell you later. But yeah, no, he's
gone. >> I was just talking to him last night. He was on
my my debate panel.
>> Interesting. I mean, like you
>> always been great to me, but I'm curious what uh what
your story is. >> Yeah, I've seen what I've needed to see
and I am done. So, >> what does that mean? Fake posting.
>> This is actually way worse than I thought it was.
Uh, didn't she basically herself mean by >> I would be
>> Yeah, I would. Sorry. That is actually um way more up
than I thought it was. >> Uh, that's the kind of thing
that gets Destiny to come out and go, "Here's exactly what happened."
>> I told you he already said something on stream about
this. It's pretty >> Oh, has he? >> Yeah, it's uh
>> same day as those messages in your chat, whatever morning
stream that is. Does someone have the clip of that for me? The
clip from Destiny stream where he mentions this? >> Yeah.
Can you guys get the clip real quick because I have to leave
in about five minutes to prepare for my show?
>> Or JS, you can have a segment of that with all the receipts
and everything
um either later on in your show or
>> Yeah, I've Well, I've done a couple things on it already.
I just I like I like farming drama when people are like strong
and I dislike farming drama as much when people are like having
major bad moments in their life cuz I just don't like piling
on person. >> She's a bad person. She's a bad person. She's
not
>> I Why is it that the women are like the hardcore
[__] you don't I'm not no mercy and the men are like
a come on. He's so hard on her. Like, let's just
>> give her a moment to regroup and woo woo woo when she
needs a hug. >> Hey, it's not just her. I did it with Tom,
too. Okay.
>> Uh, JCO is Canadian, so that might BE PART OF THE THERE
IT IS.
>> Comes out in the end. >> Thank you, Cherry. That's
all I need to know. That makes all the sense in the >> Damn
it. >> Calling you soft, >> dude. Do I You guys suck.
How How did I get a bunch of DJers as fans? And none of these
DJers are the ones who will link.
How did I not get any of the DJers who link? >> Not a single.
>> Why would you ever get the useful ones? Like, why are
this myself? You guys suck so badly. >> Why? They're all
watching Destiny, bro. What the [__] >> Did
you uh stream? >> Why would they be here? Did you see Straighter
Raid's clip on whatever? >> Oh, whatever podcast. >> Yeah,
we could pull that up too and talk about it. >> That [__]
is crazy.
>> It seemed a little wild. I don't really know for sure.
>> No, you're getting all the good stuff when I have to
go in a couple of
>> Well, I'm trying to find it, but unfortunately, nobody
in my chat or my Discord wanted to find the clip for me. Although
if you get these clips
>> Yeah. Apologize to Tom. >> Hold on. >> Well,
just come back and we'll talk about it all over again.
>> Thank you for I can't come back late. Well, I don't
know how late you guys are going to be tonight. So, don't hold
off on the good content because of me. I'll just tune in
um and because they'll tell me when to tune in and I'll listen
to it. But um
There's nothing like being here. But I I I I rather you all talk
about it, you
>> um even if I'm here or not. So
>> I listen cuz I'm not worthless cuz I'm not worthless
like all of my chatters. Okay, I found the clip before any OF
THEM DID. >> OKAY, GREAT. GREAT. GREAT. >> YOU GUYS
SUCK.
>> This is great.
>> It's not even going to be interesting, but I'll play.
I'm >> I'm listening to the law and allegations. Listen.
without
without it's just dumb. There's
I can't like I mean I could I guess but
there's just like dumb personal
that I think most people would agree is a little embarrassing
for her and when she has like a personal problem she decides
to make it everybody's problem and it's just really dumb. Like
it's very very super stupid and that's it. That's uh yeah I don't
know. It's just
Okay. Like if all like if any drama related to this ever leaked,
it would easily be the most boring dumb [__] in the
entirety of the DJing universe. >> It's just stupid.
>> this tells us personal
>> saying just so extra she turned a mountain from a molehill.
So that is what I'm assuming. Yeah, she just threw up fit and
then just Well, I guess because nobody cared enough, she just
>> Strange. Is she still friends with
>> I think they're roommates, right? >> They were
roommates. Yeah. I don't know if they'd not be friends. >> Hold
on. I got to keep playing this. There's more here. >> We
keep keep watching.
>> I thought you were done with dumb personal. I am.
>> Yeah, it's him and
have this dysfunctional relationship. And I'm not saying he her.
I hope he didn't. But um >> wait, what happened? What did
he say? >> It's it's
uh he said somebody said, "Are you dumb?" I thought she was dumb
with uh personal. And he said, "Yeah, I am." And JS says, "Copium."
>> Oh, I see.
I mean, there'll always be something
Cuz these people are insane.
>> Yeah, they are
>> Oh, there's another one.
hold on. I need to do
you see Anna Casparian iCloud leak.
>> You what mate?
>> The official cloud with you.
>> Oh [__] My mic is muted.
>> Wait, wait. >> Is who being trolled? Destiny.
>> Uh, Destiny about uh the Anna. >> Oh, I don't
know. iCloud. Yeah, I don't know exactly what that means. That's
a little crazy. >> Sorry. Here's I think this is another
>> I got to go. But >> this is another clip. You
got You got 90 >> Oh, another one. Okay, go ahead. No,
I do. I do. I do. I do. I do. Yeah. >> Okay. Chad is We'll
see if he reads it.
Lauren said that Farha went behind her back and told people not
to collab with her. Lauren also said that Molina messaged Pixie
because Farha said that Lauren was trying to hook up with you
behind Molina's back and supposed Molina told Pixie to not move
in with Lauren. That's all that Lauren leaked a while >> I'm
lost.
>> Okay,
Lauren
names and got immediately confused.
>> Lauren said that Far was talking about her. Far talks
to Molina about her and then Molina continued that talking after
Farra poisoned the well. >> I think Molina told Pix not
to move in with her or something. >> Yeah, we're not going
to we're not jumping into this cuz this is all this is so stupid.
Okay, the issue is that Molina was insane and Molina was playing
all sorts of unbelievably
games with any person in my friend group. So
most of the bad stuff you would hear about Molina is probably
true. I think all of those things are probably true because Molina
has an unhinged need to control every single friend that I had,
okay, in the past. So, the Molina is insane. Um,
Lauren, when she doesn't like somebody will start to emotionally
override everything that ever happened and will just make up
in regards to people she doesn't like. So, if Lauren says anything,
she always
>> exactly what she does.
>> I don't think she should be making >> Yeah, you
can tell from the way that she insults people. It just she used
to be like a tree fan and then she just like switched on her
because of one thing. >> Yeah. Like with the where she
did the hunter as well. It was just like insane.
>> Oh, the hunter stuff. Wait, tree. You saw the hunter
stuff, right? >> Yeah, I know. I know all about the hunter
stuff. Yeah, >> you saw that she texted him day of,
>> In the same time stamp series that came with like the
are you okay message and
I I got everything. I told Stephen, I said that is a clout shark.
I said she wants There's nothing unique about her. Like everybody
on this panel here, there's something unique about every last
one of us. There's nothing unique about her. Nobody gives a about
the whole I passed the bar in two states. What else you got?
She's dumb as you know what I'm saying? So it's like she's trying
to become relevant by getting in on the action. What a very insensitive
thing to do. the day that he that day that the that situation
happened with his girlfriend's ex, like you want to like get
into the DMs and like, hey, like like if this was your friend,
you would want to see how he's doing emotionally. This was a
very traumatic thing and and and say what you want about the
whole farming of it that's down there blah blah blah. It's still
traumatic, right? And so instead of you checking on how he's
doing, you want to like get in on the interview. You want to
use the fact that you loaned him money. You know what I'm saying?
Even though he paid your back, you want to use that as a conditional
reason why he should do what you want. That's the evil
>> I Yeah, I don't know if I'd say evil. Just something
is weird there. >> Entitled
womanship. I'll try to get if if Huh. If you >> Okay, Lauren's
evil. Lauren's evil. I want to get through this clip. So you
can go tree, we got to get through it.
I would I don't I wouldn't trust anything she would say out of
hand. >> Um and then Far does her own and she also does
goofy dumb. Everybody's just like everybody's like playing some
weird reputation control saving in the background where everybody
hears people talking about them. So then they go and talk [__]
about everyone else and it's just this unhinged
stupid game of everything. I don't know. Um I think it's all
none of this drama is that interesting. There's nothing big at
stake here. It's just people's feelings getting hurt and dumb
residual from games was playing. >> Nothing here is that
interesting. There's nothing interesting here. It's all super
boring and super silly. So, >> it's not necessarily good
or bad. It's just more direct.
>> Who was he responding to? Who made Who said that inside
of the chat? >> Someone in the chat. >> The same
guy who asked him in Discord. Actually, he's one of my chatters.
>> Oh, cool. >> Wait, how the
where is he getting? Was this like public information? I didn't
hear about
>> how did he get this intel? >> I'm gonna let you
guys continue talking about it. I I gotta dip out. >> All right.
Thanks for coming on, Tree. >> Bye, everybody. Thank you
so much for holding. Bye. >> See you, >> bro. It's
for somebody who loves drama. I don't follow this [__]
enough. This was public info. >> Uh, what was public info?
The Far Lauren blow up.
the whatever the the confusing thing was at the start. >> Oh
yeah, that was public info. She dropped that in my Discord.
>> Who did Lauren? >> Lauren. Yeah, she like leaked
all of that in my Discord.
>> Like the Far stuff. Yeah. Also,
uh there is some stuff in there where Molina had the right to
be upset at like
And I don't know if I could really I don't know like what am
I allowed to say at this point cuz Lauren is like out of >> Am
I allowed to speak now? I don't know. I don't want to piss off.
So I'm just going to play safe. >> Oh should have even
said you know >> I wasn't even speaking to you. I'm using
>> even said you know anything.
>> Called you a [__]
>> Not good. >> Listen. If I if I mean that she's
going to leave so I can't be I just have to be
I think everyone was probably insane in this situation, but
>> I don't know. It's not just Molina being like, you know,
>> you keep this up. >> And Kellister of House Jean
will strike you down just to be careful. How are you? Okay. >> Just
cuz I'm I'm letting her talk [__] So now I actually
am a >> I wasn't talking [__] >> It's
over.
>> What was I looking for? Oh, yeah.
>> I had this album. Uh, well, Frugals made this album.
Thank you, Frugals. And this was just all the all the
doesn't like somebody in this group. That's Farra, the one that
tried to ruin all my relationships behind my back before ever
speaking to me. So, I know what happened here. So, Lauren is
going to say that that Far probably was poisoned against Lauren
a little bit. Destiny was willing to give Farity and say, "Hey,
Molina poisoned Far's brain against you or something." And Lauren
doesn't believe that. Lauren thinks far brought the whole thing
up and Lauren probably wanted Destiny to like 86 Far from the
orbit and I'm willing to bet she pushed that super hard until
the point where she was like it if you're going to choose this
person over me I'm going to go and then she walked away
and I would bet reasonable sum of money that I would be correct
here.
>> Wait, who? >> Maybe it was something like related.
This was
when was this? 14 days ago. It was made
two weeks ago. >> Bro, I'm I'm so late.
>> Like, holy. That's like a almost a month ago in drama
time. >> This guy's been helping out Super Earth a whole
lot. He's been taking down bots,
>> I was I'm trying to grind before that new war or that
new battle pass comes out. You feel me? >> New battle bond.
Yeah. Damn.
Yeah. So, all this stuff happened. Lauren like leaked all of
this. >> She also seemed to claim in uh she seemed to claim
in in my Discord that she'd Destiny, but people were like, "Oh,
that's just her humor." So, and she hasn't like confirmed it.
It was a weird thing to leak to be honest, but
>> to be honest. >> Well, I just Yeah, I think all
of this is weird to talk about publicly.
>> I mean, I'd have to read it. I I don't know what the
whole point she's making. >> Kelly patiently waiting for
the day she can speak.
>> Wait, Kelly, what do you What happened? Did you say
something dramatic? Why? Why you can't talk? What's happened
while I was gone? >> All these people like to talk behind
the scenes. Kelly probably knows some stuff. >> Oh, so
Kelly. Ah, >> I've learned this stuff since like last >> Oo,
Kelly, you just expose yourself as like a a point a crack on
the wall. Okay. If anybody wants to get their destiny, they know
who to go after now. The Keelstar of House Jean. >> No,
it's not. It's just like a It's just a bit more context to it.
Jesus Christ. >> Okay, littlest.
You don't need to message me to say don't say anything when I'm
sitting here saying I'm not going to say anything. Patiently
wait.
>> LIKE, WHY WOULD I say I'm patiently waiting if I'm gonna
just spur now? >> yeah. the [__] producers,
the producers behind the camera hold up beside like, "Stop talking
about this." And she's like, "Stop talking about this. Talk about
what? What are we >> What are we talking?"
>> Uh, yeah.
Anyway, this was the message I was referring to. So, >> I
think Lauren's going to make a full
>> I think she's going to recover. >> I'm sure. I'm
sure that could happen. >> The giga chads. That's so funny.
>> Giga Chad, so that's funny. So, I don't know. I feel
like this could go either way. That this could be a sarcastic
comment or a truthful comment.
>> Yeah. I mean, I don't know. >> Dude, Jimmo is
going off behind you. >> Oh, can you hear? Can you hear
the poochie? My bad, bro.
>> I just I couldn't figure out. Somebody had dogs going
and then it was just like this beastial roar in the background.
>> Over. That's me actually. >> It's better than
hearing pom pom.
>> Pom pom. Quit. Pom pom. Stop. I feel so bad. I feel
so bad about them. >> Ouch. Pom pom.
>> Oh god.
>> Okay, where were we? How sad is this? >> Okay,
I think this is um Rhino sent me this clip. I think this is Aerodite
saying like, "Sorry for bringing any of this up."
>> Thank you for having me. Have a good one. Bye. >> Wait
a minute.
>> All right. Well, sorry that that moved away from a ideological
conversation, but yeah. Um, I do need though somebody that I
could go over the things. I don't want to leak DMs. Try my best
not to leak DMs. But yes, there are other claims about other
relationships that I would like to show people and say, "Hey,
can you just like confirm that this happened cuz there's other
implications for a ton of other people to where if I black out
so much that I'm like it's just a worthless statement at that
point. So even just leaking things was isn't useful, but at least
yes, getting people to just look at it and say, "Oh, wow. Okay,
this did happen." That's that's good. And yeah,
>> trying to see what kind of
>> these are neon tetras.
>> Anyway, thank you for having me.
>> They're some kind of tetra, but I think I think they're
neon tetras. >> [__] How did you clock the
fish like that? Are you a fish guy? >> [__]
sorry that moved away from me. Why are we looking at the fish?
>> Um, I do need though somebody >> that I could
go over the things. I don't want to leak DMs. Try my best not
to leak DMs, but yes, there are other claims. Yes, about other
relationships
to show people and say, "Hey, what is >> Oh, this was saying
that apparently somebody was asking like, "Oh, who brought this
up? Tomite."
I think Tom was under the impression that the conversation wouldn't
be about that drama last night.
But I got into it. Or at least that's what it seems. That's what
people are saying. Like there's evidence that that was what it
was about. >> I think I'm going to end up falling asleep
long before we got to any of the that Britney was saying. Uh
but >> Well, wait. We already went through a bunch of stuff,
but Britney talks about this for like three more hours.
So unless we get timestamps from people, there's like no way.
>> Yeah. Unless we get timestamps from people, we're not
going to get to any of the good. I mean, it would have been nearer
to the end, right? Because I
I watched maybe like the
two/ird in question mark. I don't know.
>> But it's Yeah, I don't know. I'm getting pretty tired
anyway. >> I have no idea what part you watched that. So,
I I literally
I can't say. I mean, I could skip forward like an hour and a
half or
Get to like some other interesting part of the conversation.
Look around. >> Yeah. I mean, >> this is why I tell
you my work is better than all your works because it is absolutely
bubbles and value
>> So, Tom, I watch the stream live. Tom comes on the next
day and he goes, "I'm not apologizing for anything." Which is
not to say that he's not apologizing for things he's already
apologized for. Which is not to say that he's not apologizing
for offending Kelly Jean so much as apologizing for the action.
All these things are nuance, but let's see. >> So, there
was like 10 15 different things I was fighting against at this
point. So,
>> I don't know. Like, literally, I feel like Tom could
come out and say like, "Yeah, I think like four women." And Britney
would just be like, "Yeah, obviously he did that." Like, you
guys just don't understand Tom.
Like, she's ready to defend literally anything he says or does
for no discernable reason.
>> Um, I'm going to see if I can find
some >> I Well, I skipped through, but you have to tell
me. You have to give me some indication of where we're going.
>> Break up hard. I said 2/3 in roughly when I started
listening. So, you're not even halfway yet. Two >> Well,
sorry. Sorry. 2/3 into the You don't know when it was in the
stream
>> like this is 2/3. >> This would be about 2/3.
>> You wouldn't have started listening 2/3 in cuz that's
like here
and they're like they're essentially done. It's like over at
that point
>> to the point before they stop. Find the point point
where they stop.
>> And then I can work back from there.
and nothing big. >> Yeah, he's a small time criminal, guys.
Small time, but bigger time than like someone who steals food,
but he's a small time criminal. He's not like that big a
few people.
>> Okay, so are we going forward or back?
>> Um,
let's find the point where it finishes and then I can figure
out by looking at it.
>> Wait, where what finishes?
>> Where the the topic of conversation
>> Okay. Somewhere around
>> I like the edge of that square.
>> Like um there was some sort of confusion
>> Did you listen to me at all?
>> You said the edge of that square.
>> Yeah. That's not where you put it. Like the other way
to the left towards where it says human's going to human. >> Wait,
I did that precisely.
>> I'm staring at it right now and you're >> No,
it was over here. It was over here. This is right where it was.
>> Oh, you're a [__] >> The edge of this
square.
>> This is where we were.
>> No, a little bit beyond this. >> And it was before
this. You were
>> Tom is in recovery for years now. He has a very appropriate
relationship with his past. And here's J.
>> He's sharing the stories. The fact that he knows it
was wrong. The fact that he starts off with the sentence, I'm
a red flag. He's literally taking >> Just look for a time
stamp. I don't think we're going to have a transcript for this.
And I think if I refresh the video,
it's probably going to go members only. So yeah.
>> I can't refresh the video, guys. Okay.
>> Accountability with Andy hasn't repeated the pattern.
There's no repeating of this pattern in any of his current life.
And then she would text me and be like, >> that's untrue.
Tom absolutely misrepresents and lies about things whenever he
can in his current life as a >> Their drugs are pull up."
>> Aaron says, "Very annoying. The expectation ever cease
for each piece of your life story is so stupid." It's so stupid.
It's so inappropriate. If you don't believe him, don't engage
with him. It's just so inappropriate. >> No. If you listen,
if you think me doubting some of the stories or some of the things
he says about events that have just happened recently that involve
me, you think that me doubting those things means I can't engage
with them, then don't engage with me. I'm going to continue to
engage with them all I want. That's my bubble.
Obnoxiously forcing my way into other people's bubbles,
>> bubble breaks and like uniforms and break in, take all
the drugs and uh and leave like we were police and um like that.
So yeah, we're always like >> I just want to be clear.
We believe that they pulled up in SUVs and in SWAT uniforms and
tried to bring in somebody's house. >> SWAT uniforms, but
as close as we can get in like black clothing and everything.
Yeah. >> It's like JC has never left his bedroom. How hard
would that be? I could do that. How hard is it to pretend SWAT?
I feel like that's really easy. My brother's grab some camo black.
Grab some black boots. Show up in an >> It's really easy.
You show up in an SUV. You just got like two or three riot shields,
a couple ARs, and it's so easy to look like. >> Everybody's
got an SUV. Show up to your friends. It's easy as Why is he acting
like Jay talks? Like, is this even literally a 15-year-old could
do it? They do it. WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT? >> DO YOU
want to go back? >> Yo, this is crazy, bro.
>> Where's a 15year-old going to get a SUV?
>> Yeah. Not only like the SUV, but then like what you're
like, is it really? It's so easy. >> Is it that cheap to
get like what? Fake Riot gear. Like if you go to Amazon, how
much are you spending for the sake of like and like are you guys
reusing this? How many outfits are we getting for how many people?
And we're getting fake guns, too. Like, okay, cool. Okay. >> I
Yeah, I This is
like I [__] it. >> I don't know. Like, what
do we even say when somebody's like, "You don't go outside. You
don't even understand. 15year-olds like fake uh SWATs all the
time." Like fake uh what would you call it? Not riding uh not
ride engagement.
They fake like raiding all the time. I just don't understand.
It has to be confusing SWAT with like just I don't know police
officers with like uh >> that doesn't even
>> Who are who are the 15year-olds doing >> I understand.
I'm just trying to think of how this makes sense in her mind,
right? And it has to be like the only way like she's seen like
uh cops or some [__] like that. Like that it's the
only way that it makes sense. That is an outrageous thing to
say.
>> Sorry, I had to send a message there. you were breaking
into. >> Uh, yes. And this that the part that I'm talking
about there. Yes, I did. It was another drug dealing. Um, but
yeah, like this entire part because you were reminding the context.
We're talking about relationships. We're talking about the fact
that I keep dating like really horrible women who keep cheating
on me and treat me horribly. And then I realize, oh, I'm the
[__] problem. I'm like a piece of [__]
that nobody that I would want to date would be willing to date
me. And so then I go down a blow like problems with >> Colleen
says my husband was robbed that way when he was young. It's super
common. Literally, it's like it's just How old is JTO? Is he
like 12? Maybe Jaw just doesn't leave his house. Literally, everyone
in my chat's like, "Yeah bro, how hard is this?" Like literally
airsoft guns. It's like very easy. Again, I just feel like it's
the difference between like adults who have like seen it or understood
it or just watch a documentary on like it's not that hard. Like
just get a laring community to do it with you. It's like Yeah.
Is it because Jay-Z doesn't leave his bedroom? Is that the problem?
What is happening here? >> Lar use like foam weapons. What's
she talking about? >> Am I out of touch crime? You'd get
so
>> Is this actually that common? Am I that crazy out of
Cuz I know that I am out of touch, but like that much where it's
like a common occurrence where like people are coming up to your
house with like the the whole like Oceans 11 gear at the end
and like Yeah, we're the SWAT. I That can't be right. That can't
be right. >> I l Yeah, I literally have no
It is what it is, dude. You know what? Human's going to human
>> or he's a pathological liger and he's accusing Tom of
doing everything he's doing to like pretend he's not the one
doing it. That's a good tactic. Ooh, that's a good gaslighting
manipulative tactic. Ooh, that's interesting >> with myself
and why no woman that I would want to date would ever want to
date me. Like that's this is literally me just talking about
why the people that I want to date don't want to date me. This
isn't self glorification in any
like we were the police and um crap like that. And so yeah, we
were always like trying to get over on one another as well. And
so it just became normal to always lie to one another, to always
try >> uh $5 super chat from Kendrick Lamar. She knows
dealers have real guns, right? Yeah. I don't like I and you would
have to be at least a little bit convincing, no to not get shot
at by the by the cops. And also, apparently these people knew
it was your girlfriend because you said it was your ex or whatever
that they met. So, wouldn't they recognize you? Wouldn't they
know you?
You showing up as SWAT with like helmets on.
>> Britney has to be confused. I truly mean this. Like,
there's no way she'd make a statement like that. She has to be
confusing with something else. She probably means just regular
cop impersonation cuz there's no way I think that's in No, she's
got to be confused.
>> Yeah, I feel like a regular cop impersonation
could make more sense for why she would think it would be. >> Yeah,
I've I literally
I'm lost. But it is again humans going to human. Okay, you guys
are saying he's privileged. Is >> He might be. Maiden says
I seriously uh think Jtock might be emotionally stunted developmentally.
He might be, which is not uncommon for the space. To be fair,
he actually might be. >> I actually do think that's a possibility,
right? And so to be fair to him, to meet him where he's at, >> it
happens. I think a lot of people that are stunted end up on the
internet. I do. I think cuz you can't make it in like regular
life. You make your life here, which is why I think it's really
important that a lot of us do have lives off the internet. >> Hold
on. Okay. She I think she would agree and she would go, "That's
what happened to me." I think she'd say that. Okay. I think she'd
say, "That's what happened to me." So, I was about to go like,
wait, I actually have a real career. I have like training, a
degree, a profession. Okay. I don't know. I I did succeed in
real life. Okay. I did. >> And I'm chronically online because
of my job, but I obviously have a whole life outside of it, right?
I have friends and family and things I do, but I just like I
separate them very clearly. So, I I always say I'm chronically
online, but I don't mean it the way the internet says it. Like
I don't I'm not literally like my you know what I mean? But hold
on. Okay, I'm connected. So, is is Jaw just like is he stunted?
Is he like a chronically online little rat? Like, what is he
doing? You know what I mean? JESUS, WHY DOES SHE HATE YOU so
much? >> I go rat. >> I don't know. I I >> I
think I would understand like if she if she had Okay, so I think
in a lot of people's minds who care about this um going this
hard on Tom because in their minds you absolutely chose to go
on that stream. That was a choice that you made in their minds.
And to stay on top of Tom because of stuff that has been like
dragged out for way too long is genuinely at this point for them
probably looking like you are an active harasser. And to them,
all the vitriol comes out the moment that comes out, right? Uh
if somebody who was harassing I guess Kelly or irrelevant or
anybody else in here, my opinion of them would probably be similar
to the way that she thinks of you. That's probably what it is.
It's just the the same way that you were like, "Hey, people in
DG, the moment they think they're right, they don't give a about
like holding back any opinions or any thoughts, the moment that
she perceives you as a harasser, right, there's no need to hold
back because you're the scum of the earth." Uh, it's that easy.
I think I think she just is biased towards Tom.
Uh, yeah, maybe.
Uh, I called her. Somebody says Jaw called her out on Wick stream
and she hasn't forgotten. Well, I've called her out a couple
times actually and I think she just doesn't like me now.
She reads one of my where I call you and and evil and just agrees.
Got him. >> I think he might be there might be some defect
or something. >> Another and eventually you were just like
streaming webs. >> Well, I think actually there would have
to be a mental defect for him to even be reacting this way, right?
Like something's wrong with him, right? >> That weren't
even connected to something in hopes that they would be connected
to something way later down the line. That would help you. And
so yeah, you just ended up lying for for no reason. >> So
question is anyone who's like, does anyone listen to So, I'm
trying to listen to this perspective like does any of this flag
me as being deceptive or as being glorifying for example because
I obviously have a bias that I don't think it is. Are you guys
watching it for cues that would suggest truthfulness and non-
glorification because the main things you two did is pause it
to point out just two things that might confirm your bias which
I don't think is a fair way to engage with Tom especially such
a serious thing and especially bringing up such a very serious
vulnerable history which is addiction history to use against
him. >> Like I said I didn't know that this was in context
to addiction and I still even in watching back further I still
didn't see the uh >> BB says Jto is either redundant redundant
or evil that has to be it. Well, it could be a lot of things,
but I do think it's something good. >> It's It's >> good
one, BB poison. You >> Oh my
>> It is >> mental health. Like, you can't just be
the normal grounded people aren't like this. That's what I mean
when I say like I'm sensing. >> That's what I'm saying.
Like, ooh, like I'm sensing, right? Like, you can't be a normally
adjusted person and treat people the way JTO does. You can't
be a normally adjusted person and chronically cheat on people.
You can't be a normally adjusted person and like be >> cuz
of course who's top of mind. >> Who's top of mind?
I I swear I half of the people who hate me hate me because of
one association. It's so weird.
>> people up just for the fun of it. You can't be a normally
adjusted. Like again, when we're looking for sort of more healthy
than unhealthy, right? Healthier people are much more grounded
and much more kind to people because they don't often feel like
a need to be defensive and a need to be like like a need to be
like, you know what I'm saying? But Jtock is like something is
is seriously wrong with him. Whether it's intentional or not
to me, everyone's dysfunctional on a spectrum. On a spectrum,
it's just like I'm closer to healthy than unhealthy. And you
can tell because of the way I treat people and the way that relationships
happen. JTO is willing to make false accusations with no receipts
and when pushed into a corner just makes up a new lie to distract
from the original accusation. That's not normal, dude. Not let
me rephrase. Not normal. That's not healthy. Okay, I'll make
the same. That's not healthy. So, what is wrong with him? If
he's, you know, developmentally challenged, well, now we have
a reason. we can be more lenient, right? If he's not challenged,
that means he's doing it on purpose, which means he's like the
evilst person. He's >> I'm challenged in some way. I need
to find a way to deal with that. >> You can't just say,
"Oh, this person has some mental illness or an addiction, and
that absolves them of any responsibility for their behavior."
You can't say that. >> So tired. >> It's literally
not how that works. >> And evil meaning furthest from joy.
Not evil meaning that we create in the >> I don't know.
>> She's gone on about how evil you are. Can you imagine
you as like the lead in a movie? It'd be so boring.
>> Kelly for a good
>> Stop calling me boring, Kelly. Just go to sleep. >> I
wouldn't even myself in the movie. I would just leave. You'd
be like, you're really unconvincing.
>> You know why? Cuz movies aren't real life, Kelly. Cuz
in real life, you just stay here continuing to call me boring.
>> The movie would actually be me existing for 30 seconds
and then three hours of run time of Kelly calling me boring.
No, I would just >> That would be the movie. No, no, >> that
would be nothing cuz I had already
>> from joy. He's so lacking of joy, he can only spend
his time destroying other people's reputations because he's so
like without joy. That's what I mean within his own consciousness.
Right. So, a person
>> what reputation? >> We are destroying people's
reputations. It's just
>> Yeah. I don't I don't know. >> The guy that ruined
himself, by the way.
I've said it like a bunch of times. I don't think that him pulling
up the Instagram was like evil. He like he turned it he like
continued to snowball it into worse and worse things. Like actually
pulling up the Instagram I was just like ha not beating this
best
And then he turned that into like all of the weird chat messages
he sent. And then he turned that into coming in and doubling
down on those chat messages and refusing to apologize or acknowledge
he did anything wrong. And then he turned it into like the Wickstream
and all the stuff with Zona and Sassifras where he refused to
admit that he did anything wrong to his friends and they all
turned on him and said like, "Hey, this is really unhealthy for
you." And so he lost all of his like closest friends. I don't
know. Like he literally just made he did this all himself. Like
I I literally am like the guy knocking over the tiny domino,
but it falls short of like the next domino and then Tom knocks
over the next domino and all the preceding dominoes. H. >> Uh,
yeah, Kelly. I Well, actually, Kelly did read the logs, but I
call them in chat first. Okay, so too bad. Me. I know that Kylo
>> goes back to me. Thank you. >> Uh-huh. Kylo went
ahead and then she mentioned how he shouldn't have said any of
that to Kelly and that was like a
>> Did Britney say Did Britney say anything about Kelly's
part in this? Because it seems kind of like weird. >> She
does. She blames Kelly a lot. Wait, she
Yeah, she blamed Kelly a lot >> for what? Calling it feeling
like it was creepy. Is that what the
>> Yeah, basically just take it. Yeah,
you do Instagram. So, too bad,
>> Pepa. I don't know. >> I don't know where that
is precisely here, but we'll get to that. >> I don't lie
about people. It's a very wonderful thing I think I'm great about.
I don't lie about people. I do not lie about people. Okay, I'll
lie about myself in the past. In the past, I do not lie about
people. And JTO cannot say that. He lies about people all of
the time, including myself. And so again, when I look at him,
he lied about me,
by the way. >> How did I lie about Britney? >> I
don't
insane accusations about me. She doesn't know me at all.
>> So, I don't know about that one, Chief. If you're making
>> if you're making really big like statements about somebody
you don't know without anything to back it up. Is that really
much different to lying?
>> You're just saying things.
>> What is that noise?
>> But is it a bar?
>> Uh, no. I just hit two bottles together. >> Uh,
gotcha.
>> I actually like maybe of minor diverency. I never lie
about people. So I can literally say that now. >> He can't
say that. And that's what makes me look. I'm like, you're willing
to lie about people. You're automatically suspicious to me. >> How'
you lie? >> Willing to say I lie. Tom is already >> So
they're saying that the like me calling him af. That's like a
major lie.
>> wait, how is that a lie? If anything, at most that would
be a misunderstanding,
>> Or like I just have a different definition of what I
think of as best.
>> Yeah. Which at most would make it a misunderstanding.
like a
>> like a lie. >> Yeah, I think so. I just um Yeah,
I I I agree with you. But yeah, I I don't feel like I've ever
lied about Tom. I feel like most of the stuff I'm bringing up
on this stream, by the way, the air >> You did call him
a
>> Oh, sorry. I actually I actually 100% did do that. I
I 100% did do that. That was kind of funny. Um $5 super chat
from Emory and he becomes a Oh, he gifted a membership. I'd never
trust a person who's paid to be a fan's friend for any duration
of time.
Well, guess what, Emry? You just donated $5, so that means we're
friends now. Good luck. >> Mhm. Friends.
>> You'll never trust yourself again. Wait, no, you don't
trust me. Okay, I get it. Um, what was I saying? Oh, but I I
don't know. I think I think it was just funny. It was like at
some point after a little bit after the Instagram stuff,
I think I said something like, "You know what? I do think he's
af
I was like and you know what else I've some people are saying
I've heard this but I haven't confirmed it yet but some people
are saying he's probably a
sorry but I think when you say with that when you say it that
way I think it's obvious it's not true but maybe I'm
>> kilo $5
but yeah >> well
I say that kind of >> yeah you guys did say don't do And
I was like, "No, you guys. It's funny." >> But it's like
I think it's incredibly obvious that's not as serious. But maybe
when I'm like laughing and saying it that way, it's not clear.
>> You're saying don't say it because people will say that,
"Oh, I'm making things up about him." But I don't really care
if people are going to read it that way and say it that way.
If people wanted to actually go and say I'm calling him a I just
had that argument in the moment. It's fine.
>> Mhm.
Mhm. Mhm.
Mhm. Yeah. Yeah. >> Admitted when he's lied and why he
did it, which to be fair makes sense. Lots of people lie. Why
is he lying? Why is Jtock lying? But JTO, if asked would not
say he's lying. He would say, "Oh, I misspoke. Oh, I misunderstood.
Oh, he is literally doing exactly what he's accusing Tom of doing."
>> That had anything to do with addiction? I didn't know
this conversation had to do with addiction.
>> What I'm talking about, what is Dave talking about?
This is what I'm saying. What the is Dave in this conversation?
What do you mean this conversation? You didn't know this conversation
has to do with addiction. Tom's whole past has to do with addiction.
>> Drug dealing. Uh, he talked about how he was a massive
giant red flag because he was a guy selling drugs. So, I'm not
really understanding what you missed.
>> Uh, at the same time, he also apparently Oh, there was
something with credit cards. Oh, he got caught and sent to prison
because his girlfriend was using a credit card that he stolen,
right? >> So, apparently he had a whole bunch of like schemes
for taking credit cards and not getting caught using them using
them credit cards as well. He also was a
broke into people's houses. I'm willing to send Kyla the proof,
which is great. See, he has people he trusts, which I think is
good. And again, don't send it to Jtock because he obviously
>> this dude stole like tens of thousands of dollars from
people like by all of the stories he's told about the thefts
he's done.
>> I just I don't believe it. But you know,
he apparently was able to steal debit cards from people and not
get caught using them.
>> But I don't know how he got the pins for these people
like for these debit cards. I I really don't.
>> In some places you don't have to have the pen. Well,
if you use like the chip,
>> Contactless. Is that >> what you're talking about?
Or are you talking about like there are places where you just
don't need a PIN on most debit cards?
>> In countries of technology, we have
>> Well, hold on. Like, how many years ago? I just said
contactless. >> Oh, it would have been before >> Yeah,
that would have been before tap.
>> Oh, how long ago was it? >> I believe they're
saying like 15 or 18 years ago. No. >> Oh, boy. >> Yeah.
Oh, okay.
>> ain't no way tap was a thing back then. >> There
are ways to bypass the PIN, like using it as a credit card. Oh,
possibly.
>> Doesn't care about whether you're right or not.
>> You should know the details before you talk about it.
Okay. Um, Ralph,
I'm just saying what I've heard. So, I watched some of one of
Queenman's streams and I believe debit cards was said there.
I believe debit cards was said by Tom. That's why I'm saying
it was weird that he said debit cards. So maybe he misspoke or
maybe I'm mis I could be misremembering. Okay, I'll say it right
now. I could be misremembering,
but I do believe like that was what struck me as so weird was
why is he saying debit cards when credit cards are clearly what
he should be using if he doesn't want to get caught
anyway? Get their jewelry
>> I like all of these stories seem crazy to me. >> That's
fair. I just feel like you are super not aware of like what this
industry is because I think part of what you're describing is
like a holistic how is it possible that he's like a junkie who's
also doing like high cap burglary of jewelry and also doing credit
card scams like is that the threat
for any of these things
>> he's consistently stealing high ticket items from people's
houses he's stealing credit cards and debit cards from people
and getting a bunch of money out of their accounts he is uh robbing
ripping off other drug dealers with elaborate schemes all while
working at Subway when he's like 19 years and addicted to pills.
Like like I just I don't understand. It just I'm going to say
again, it's just strains credility. I don't believe all of these
stories are true. They seem like somebody who's making things
up to sound interesting.
>> But was he dealing drugs? He was also dealing drugs
at this time.
>> Did all these crimes. He got caught for none of them.
Well, >> he got for some. That's what I'm saying. Did you
hear what he just said out loud? How sheltered is this boy? He
just said, "So he did all these crimes and never got caught for
any of them.
Oh, to be clear, I'm pretty sure Tom went to prison for stealing
his parents' credit card.
>> I'm pretty sure that's the fraud he went to prison for.
>> Is that maybe incorrect, but I believe that is the fraud
that he actually got put in prison for. >> What information
do you have to lead to that conclusion? >> Uh I So, again,
this is like one-sided, but I've seen like uh one document
that seems to to claim this.
He also I mean he's been clear that he did steal from his parents
too.
>> I like I believe he stole a credit card from them. I
maybe I'm misinterpreting or conflating two things, >> but
I'm pretty sure he did steal a credit card from his parents and
I could have sworn that was one of the things he was actually
criminally charged with.
Um I would trust Kyla's background with this cuz I know that
she worked with a lot of these people. But where did Britney
grow up where she has all this like authority on like people
that are committing crime? And I don't understand that part.
Um
is did she grow up like super poor in like the hood and stuff?
Like I don't I don't understand. >> Uh she's been outside
and she watches
>> If JTO ever did one of those two things, he would understand.
here I'm hitting play again.
>> What What is JTO even saying?
What is that even?
You know what I mean? What does that even mean?
What? Most people do a bunch of crimes and never got caught for
it. You guys ever speeded and not get caught for it? You ever
smoke marijuana when you're not supposed to not get caught for
it? What?
>> But am I understanding your business? Like I don't really
>> I just I am very dubious that somebody who's committing
these kinds of crimes at this level in such a short period of
time and literally only got caught for like one >> All
right, we get it. You're dubious
like his um his arrest record or something. I would >> Yeah.
Is he playing dumb or is he sheltered? Yes, Maddox. That's what
I want to know. Is he literally playing dumb or is he that [__]
sheltered? What kind of question is that? >> That would
go a long way to believing. >> I will say of my clients
that are chronologically involved, most all of them to credit
card fraud. Most of them obviously 11 women do prostitution.
Kidnapping is also if you're gang affiliated. The triad is typically
kidnapping, um, assault, and drug trafficking. He's done a lot
of drug trafficking. So, credit card theft and drug trafficking
are decently common. The only thing that I'm not sure about with
the cat with a girl is does he mean that he's like breaking into
jewelry stores or like what is he breaking into pawn shops? >> Breaking
into houses. So, again, breaking into houses is Tom isn't fully
listening to what Kyla said. I think she just said something
that wasn't >> Oh, Michael Walsh. What did you ask me?
>> Uh, I can't see what you ask me. Just ask it again.
>> Decently typical addiction behavior when they're also
criminologically involved. It's not all addicts. To be clear,
there's a lot of addicts that don't do crime at the same time.
But when you do crime and you have this addiction element and
you're selling drugs, this lit you I wouldn't be surprised. I'm
actually talking to you agent. Do you have multiple assault charges?
You must. Do you not >> assault charges? No, I don't have
any. I don't have any.
>> Okay. Did you assault people though? >> Like I
was in fights and like regular. It's just like it was like like
junk on >> Yeah. Like parties get in fights like Yeah.
Yeah. And so lots of people who drink go to parties and get into
fights. >> Well, you hear that junky and junky crime versus
lots of people get drunk and get into fights. >> He I don't
believe he acknowledged junky on junky crime. I think he said
I went to parties and got in fights.
Listen, I
I don't understand the charitability. I just don't >> Yeah.
Do you know that's assault, dumbass? Do you know it is assault
to get into a drunk fight with someone at a bar? You dumb. Yes,
someone can absolutely get you arrested for assault. They just
often don't. But they can. Yes, those are all assaultike charges
waiting to be pended. They just don't happen because most people
know the context is a little different. Lots of violence occurs,
lots of assault occurs. Do you know if you spit on someone that
is a form of arrestable assault? In Washington state when I lived
there we had lawyers
>> That's clearly not what Aerodite is saying. She's saying
violent assault and that addicts have a pattern of having violent
assaults.
>> Wait, Tom, can you tell me what you went to prison?
>> The spitting thing is just bizarre. >> Don't answer
him. Don't give this man >> No, it's it's a little complicated.
So, I was locked up for burglaries. I got out for two weeks.
Then I was locked up again for uh debit card theft and debit
card fraud. And then uh and then I also had a probation violation
from >> there it is. Debit card theft, debit card fraud,
just in case people were all mad in chat that I said debit >> the
burglaries before that and a probation violation from a weed
charge as well. >> Yeah, Tom is like a little criminal.
He's like a light criminal, but he's still a criminal. He still
has a record. He's still have to deal with that for the rest
of his life. >> Uh there might even.
Um but that I think that was the fifth time I've been locked
up. And so I had all of those things stacked on top of each other
with 10 years probation. And so I had to uh so that's that that
was all of the things that I was in trouble for because it's
it's a bunch of violations and the the charge of debit card theft
and debit card fraud.
>> Okay. So you you weren't caught on trafficking ever?
>> On trafficking? No. >> Like drug trafficking?
No. >> What were you selling? >> Uh other stuff mostly
uh Oxycontton.
>> What were you moving? >> Uh nothing big. >> Like
you were selling? >> Yeah. He's a small time criminal,
guys. Small time but bigger time than like someone who steals
food. But he's a small time criminal. I don't know many small-time
criminals who uh who rip off stash houses, but uh whatever. >> He's
not like that big of a criminal, but like in this space to people
who never leave their room, it's like whoa. But to somebody like
me who has like cousins in prison, it's like ah yeah, like he
did the small baby crime, not the like big crime. And he's definitely
not crime. You know what I mean? >> Probably time. Were
you like a you were a junkie dealer, right? You were like So
that's what he says. >> Yeah, he's a junkie dealer. It's
not the same thing as being like, you know, cartel in Mexico
>> successfully dealing drugs. I was not successful dealing
drugs ever cuz I was >> Yeah, exactly. He wasn't successfully
dealing drugs. Nobody knows what category Tom is in. Tom is a
very specific category of criminal and >> that's why I'm
asking.
>> Yeah, he's an unserious criminal. He's like he's like
he's a victim to his own addiction where he became a criminal
to >> Okay. He's I believe he's an unserious criminal.
If that was how he presented it, I would understand that. But
instead, he presented as if he was making elaborate ruses to
dress up his SWAT, pull up in SUVs, and rip off other drug dealers
that involved like his girlfriend moving in clandestinely after
saying she broke up with him. I I literally I just don't get
it. Tom definitely lying, broke probation with fraud, and somehow
only served 13 months in jail or in all. Yeah. I don't I >> keep
it going. >> It's very strange. Okay. It's very It's very
strange. I feel like >> Yeah. I'd like to see more. >> We're
selling really well. And then there's other parts where we literally
have nothing and we're robbing everybody to try to get more money
to sell again to support our habits. And so yeah, it's kind of
always back and forth. >> Yeah. So I am definitely sus
that you lie by omission as far as like when current drama is
going on and you don't want certain details know like soft hat
over them. I am not convinced that you are like a chronic pathological
lip about your past. >> Yeah, everyone lies by omission
even me. Absolutely. I lie by omission. uh especially to the
point >> I actually try and do I try and be very very careful
about not lying by omission unless it's like necessary to keep
like somebody else's secret like I don't have permission to say
something. Um I think lying by omission is one of the best ways
that you can go about breaking somebody's trust
um while also trying to protect your own like ego. I think it's
cringe and corny and childish behavior. Yeah, 100%. I think it's
also the easiest one to get away with because you assume that
they aren't going to have any way to check, right? >> Yeah.
And and even if you do get caught, it's like, well, you didn't
ask that. And you you're 100% trying to do that. Just that way
you can >> like do that. Oh, well, you didn't like ask
directly. You didn't do that. I didn't make like a specific statement
about it. I just didn't speak.
>> I think it's just as deceptive.
>> Yeah. Precisely. >> Like these people, they don't
Oh. Oh. there. I'm not I'm not giving you anything. So, if you
mean like we leave details out or like we I don't know what that
means actually. I don't know what Kyla is saying. Everyone does
that. There's no one in the space who doesn't do that because
why wouldn't you do that? You're talking to on the internet.
Again, I don't know why everyone thinks this is a safe space
to tell your business to the internet when we know that's not
true. >> Uh Pacan, thanks for the YouTube membership, dude.
>> Like, I don't know why everyone acts like everyone's
closer than they are or like everyone knows things. Like again,
I'm not friends with Tom off the internet. I only know him from
the internet. Okay. And I like Tom. But again, like even when
I make new YouTube friends, I always tell them, "I like you.
I don't want you to know anything about my life, you know? I
don't want you to know anything about my husband or my family.
Like, I'm willing to tell certain people certain things. I'm
willing to get closer to certain people, but I'm not getting
closer to like, >> no way, bro. Like, not not right away.
You know what I mean? Kayla uh says Kayla says I think she means
purposely misleads. Is that what she means?
Okay. Well, I guess that's different. I don't do that.
Purposefully misleads.
I'm not sure what that means.
Maybe.
I mean, he definitely has admitted he's lied, >> which
I think is Yeah, that's better than other people to lie. I never
lie. Like, bro, just say you lied.
>> Not to not to cuz I think everybody's already even in
this stream, like I feel like everybody's kind of on the same
page about Tom, but has there been any condemnation from Britney
in the part of Tom? Like, in her has she mentioned anything that
Tom's done? No. Like, not. I believe she thinks everything he
did was a joke and funny or like like nothing was serious and
there's absolutely no reason to have any level of condemnation
for any one of his acts as far as I understand it.
She could she could clear that up if she thinks that's untrue,
but I do believe she basically thinks Tom has zero uh fault here.
There is nothing he's done that's been wrong. Maybe he's done
some things that were stupid, but I don't think anything he's
done has been wrong.
>> Anyway, I have to Sorry, I came back to >> No,
that's fine. That's fine. That's >> Okay, I'll be right
back again. >> Comparing it to the biggest kind of >> She
just she starts yapping a lot. >> I don't I don't think
it's his. I only don't think it is his because I feel like he's
already admitted to so many different lies. Why wouldn't you
admit to that one? But also, maybe it is his. I just don't think
it matters. >> The only reason I think maybe it isn't is
I don't know why he'd lie at this point. Um and I don't like
that he like lies on a mission to avoid certain responsibilities,
but I don't think that that is in line with any of like the junky
history stuff. Okay. I think um all of the there's just so many
I it strains fragility again um that there would be this huge
pattern of all these things influencers saying, "Hey, this guy
um he misrepresented his qualifications to me." I'm positive
we can find that by the way, the misrepresenting of the being
a linguist >> yeah, I'd be curious to see that. >> But
like, okay, so if we start seeing, >> but even if you do
that, every business has an unhappy customer.
Every business has a group of unhappy customers.
I don't know what you're saying. That's not even proof of anything.
So, every business has a some un unhappy customer.
So,
>> and connecting the dots on these and basically proving
that he's lying. Are you going to start flipping on a bunch of
the things you've said? >> Uh, I might slip on I mean,
I don't know if I what I think about the rhetoric coach stuff.
I just don't have receipts on it. Either way, I'm not saying
all allegations are dismissed. Um, it's totally possible that
he lies about. It's not obvious to me that he's lying about the
junky past. He might be lying about like understanding, for example,
that his relationship with this person is turned into a nut.
I would like some padding. That's super possible. I'm saying
specifically the addiction stuff does not strike me as a lie
in any way. And I think you guys >> Okay, I'm gonna skip
through the addiction stuff because I think for the rest of that
conversation, we're not getting to Kelly stuff. So, I'm gonna
try to get to whatever Kelly was mentioned in. So, that she wants
to go after that, she can. >> Kelly was mentioned. >> Well,
we get back to the
um the weird >> Oh, I see. I see.
>> So, you made two. >> Here we go.
>> Hello, YouTube.
>> Oh, go [__] the sexually harassing them.
Stop it, Shadow B. I assume you're being sarcastic. Obviously,
it's totally Oh. Oh. Hm. Who else has a pattern of burning friendships
and bridges and chronically admits to lying and cheating all
the time and yet is not held to the same standard as Tom? Who
doesn't have >> Did you just skip forward or back?
>> Are you in back? >> Yeah. Yeah. I think that's
hilarious that I zoomed right in on that exact point where she's
talking about the person constantly in her head. >> People
who are unhinged being so inappropriate with him. Hm. It feels
a little bit like once again people will tell you who they are
and you're not listening and you're going after people that are
literally the least of your problems. Again with peace and love
none of this matters. You can all be exactly who you want to
be. It's just interesting interesting that Tom gets you know
on trial. H okay block them all Tom. They don't deserve you.
So the reason why I assume that you are like my sister is because
you leaned on it and tell you questions. Um you're never friends
with Tom in the first place. >> Sure. By the way I do like
a bald man. So just FYI Middle Eastern. I do love a bald man
with J.
No, I don't think it's reasonable that anyone has any of these
thoughts if you are in any way a person who's had relationships
and knows that things go wrong. Okay, Hunter says, "By can you
at least acknowledge that you're missing the point of his lies
being brought up?" What lies? >> Which ones? The ones we've
already gone over. Nice try, Hunter. Fired. I'm trying to like
ban
that of having, you know, those sort of things on your stream
or like the cuming stuff that everybody says is like um, you
know, super degenerate. I don't think so. And so, yeah, that's
like that's the stuff that I'm trying to talk about. And yes,
I was trying to avoid that conversation.
>> I I think it's fair. The issue is I think you have to
avoid the primary conversation or the cuming stuff. >> No
jumping on the lation conversation. You try this type of conversation.
>> Yeah, I didn't want to have this conversation either.
But no, to be honest, probably serious if I was like
you understand.
>> There's another thing I missed last night. Erdite did
say it was her who wanted to go over all this. I guess >> relationship
with the truth on certain thing and therefore that for him I
cast a whole bunch of other stuff cuz I can kind of understand
that. >> I can understand that there are a bunch of things
that I because I talk about my life. I talk about my experiences.
I talk about all the things from my past and most people can
go slightly like if people start calling you. >> So the
thing is is Britney's got that sped up so I can go slower but
I'm only out 1.5. >> There's nothing there's nothing going
to start to sound worse and worse over and over and over. So
whether regardless of what it is, if there's somebody like Queen
where no matter what I say, he's going to claim it's a lie and
then blow it up. And I either don't want to don't want to share
personal information or just don't have any way to prove it.
Then I'm just >> The reason that I'm saying this about
just like um and this just like you might think I'm just like
glazing. I don't really care. This is just I hope I feel like
I'm pretty hard as well. Um just like in a relationship as well.
The reason why I'm saying this about just like I don't give a
[__] about things ever. He's just like a dumb British.
Don't care. Just like it's really interesting to me. I agree
with him. >> Stupid Kyla. Stupid.
>> Block him. He stupid. Bad opinion. >> Bad opinion.
You have a habit. >> Oh, hey. Quan just raided us. Actually,
Queman and their viewers just joined. Say hello. Hey, Queman.
Hold on. You just got a shout out here. >> I want to check
it out. I'm going to go back and we'll check it out.
>> The digger
in a relationship with the reason why I'm saying this about I
don't give a [__] about Queen ever. He's just like
a dumb British. Don't care. Just like interesting to me in my
opinion of >> Stupid Kyla. Stupid. Block him. He stupid.
Bad opinion.
>> Bad opinion. You have a habit >> of clinging.
>> Bad opinion.
Bad opinion.
>> She's She's basically saying me and Destiny are the
same and Kylo likes both of us. To be clear, I'm not sure that
Kylo's ever like super liked me. Okay. I She might like aspects
of the content occasionally, but I do not think she actually
likes me. So, it's weird that Britney's implying that Kylo thinks
of me and Destiny the same way. >> No. Read my mind, Kyla.
You know what I'm thinking. You know what I'm thinking. You have
a pattern. What's your pattern? What's your pattern? You know
what I'm thinking, girl. Read my >> Oh, this is so weird.
>> Not this one, too. No, >> it is very weird. >> It's
like she thinks she she thinks she's being subtle and not just
saying like, "You trusted Destiny and he's a liar and a cheater
and now you're trusting this person who's a liar again." Okay.
>> Yeah. It's just weird that she's saying that when like
Kylo is still good friends in Destiny as well. Just like uh what
does this mean? What the
>> to figure out where how to understand him because he
seems like somebody who was definitely engag is bad faith in
like classic drama. But other times I see like him actively actively
actively absolutely searching for stuff that he thinks matters
in this moment trying to be good faith. I think >> I literally
said this last night was talking to Elder Dra where he was saying
uh JCK is literally queen and I was like no he's not. I was like
JJ is way more honest and like totally different than queen.
So yeah I I agree with this. >> Right. I do think in this
case just like I'm not super happy with the like
>> the goal post shifting that has occurred. Um I think
>> it makes me not know what sometimes to be. I don't know
what about when you rehash stories to me either. Um but that's
a problem. Do you have any last thoughts on anything? Just like
I don't >> Why are they No. >> Yeah. Substantial
doubt. Obviously that happened. Yeah. Very obviously that would
have happened. >> I'm calling it right now. >> Oh
sorry I should read the message here. Why doesn't she like me?
Uh listen Queen. Apparently you're just a British.
Also that Yeah, you're right. I think there's something about
your profile, Clemen. Like if you were to your side profile,
there's something about it that just it sticks out. Okay. It's
distinctive. You could say
>> that's why she doesn't like me. >> Cuz I'm just
a British as well. >> Oh, also possible. >> I don't
know why else she's sping about me. I wasn't even involved in
this conversation at all.
>> He's got the charis that people like, but he's such
a little liar. He gonna [__] you up, girl, just like
everybody else. Given the opportunity, he's going to you over
watch for patterns.
so I want
to Tom's comments and basically his defenses of them. Uh Really,
you uh you have your mic real close in your headset, just so
you know. >> You breathe.
>> My bad. >> We can hear you breathing. Um I believe
with the She wants my He said that was a self-deprecating comment.
>> Could you explain that >> Yeah. Tom, did you explain
the the basically this?
>> Yeah. That like it was obvious that she >> Americans
don't know what self-deprecating mean. >> Except for that
it's obviously like saying like obviously she doesn't want it.
Obviously she >> Oh, is that a nose joke? Yeah. Yeah. The
joke is that Queen is wait no that is actually true. But people
hate him because he's the joke. >> Like what is the other
possible implication that I'm I'm coming out with information?
I'm leaking information that she's obsessed with me and actually
want or like what is the other what is the other narrative? >> Yeah,
we already settled this. Why would we bring it up again? being
>> that you're trying to get to her in a way because she's
shown disgust for you. >> Trying to get to her in a way
by >> Yeah, you're trying to like direct her. >> Like
when you say get to her, you mean? >> I know. I would I
probably wouldn't needle somebody by explicitly saying you're
begging for my colleague, right? That's probably not a way to
uh Oh, so you think that he was sorry, I just want to try. Do
you think he was trying to hit on Kelly Gene with that? Like
>> he was trying to be disgusting to her because she already
explained that she was repulsed and so he was just leaning into
that but not in way. I think he was just trying to as much as
he could in a sex way. >> Yeah. To upset her using sexual
>> No, it's not even the same category. It's literally
not even the same category. It was meant to be
disgust. >> No, it's not in a way like not for gratification.
It was a joke for not
>> It was It was literally to denigrate another person.
It was to like make another person grossed out. That's literally
what it was for. Wasn't to make himself seem worse. It was just
to gross somebody else out. >> The troll comment with as
the topic, but not in a way. >> It was like in my eyes
like obviously
>> Androider asks, "Is Queman even?" I mean, there's not
much else that explains that side profile. >> It's not
he's not making a joke.
He's not like, "Hello,
like sitting up there talking about you just pulling up their
Instagram and just saying like they uh they were engaging in
cultural appropriation that I'm creepy and I'm weird, that yeah,
like that was the idea is that yes, this is like uh it's obvious
this is not the case, that she's not actually obsessed with me
or my
>> Okay. I I don't understand what you say all the time
there because I believe the the comparison you made before was
you're like, "This is the same as telling somebody to suck my
dick."
Yes, I was saying in a sense of like the fact that it's obviously
not serious. And so because it's not serious, like it doesn't
have the same implication as if it was serious and you were actually
telling somebody to suck your dick, then that would be like >> No.
Hunter says regardless of it being gratification or not, it's
still No, it's not. It actually changes the context. It literally
changes the >> Wait, I just don't understand why she thinks
I I thought Tom was getting gratification out of it. I don't
think he was. I think he was just trying to make somebody feel
grossed out by continuing to throw
at them. I think that's was his entire goal. I don't understand
what's confusing there. >> First of
all, >> you're not gonna say anything intelligent. Just
get back to >> these are very different things.
>> Okay. Is a word too when you're talking.
Stop it. Shadow B. I assume you're being >> Obviously,
it's totally like not right. That's not what's happening. I assume
>> Let me hear that. >> Chat, oh, it involves a joke,
but not all.
Never mind.
>> Right. So these are very different things. Okay.
These are very different
Okay. Yeah. Is a word too. When you're telling someone to go
[__] themselves, you're harassing them. Stop it.
Shadow B. I assume you're being sarcastic. Obviously, it's totally
like not right. That's not what's happening. I assume Shadow
B. >> Wait. Telling somebody to go themselves is not inserting
yourself in that situation. It's not like
>> I surely she understands.
Why is she speaking? Like it was only like one comment and it
wasn't like five and they were all like weird like I'm going
to put up on my stream and she's an eth and she deserves to be
objectified. There was like five different comments >> and
then he rolled into the VC and was like uh if you don't like
me having your on my screen DMCA me then.
>> Be real with you. If I had done it, it would have been
within my values. Now if I done it and it wasn't within my values,
then I would have apologized. And that's what Tom used to decide.
Was it within his values to make that kind of a joke or is it
not within his values? If it's not within his values, then he
shouldn't have made the joke. But if it's within his values,
then he should have made the joke. But then he has to make sure
he's following to and he has to make sure he keeps his job and
he has to make sure a lot of things, you know what I mean? So,
a lot of this >> Yeah. Oh, Britney's so close. She's so
dangerously close to understanding
that he violated everybody else's bubble and that's the reason
he lost a whole bunch of viewers is that everybody else thinks
he's a weird freak now for doing this and continuing to double
down.
I I realized I'm not going to try to absolve myself of all responsibility
here, but I really had very little to do with his whole falloff.
Like he was getting viewers while he was talking about this and
we were fighting and it was all like fine. But his like refusal
to admit any fault, to admit any of his lies and his continuous
double doubling down was what drove his viewers away. I'd stopped
covering him by the time he started shedding viewers majorly.
>> Goes into actually shedding viewers from >> uh
pretty significantly. Yeah. >> Oh, damn. Really? That's
interesting. >> The problem. >> Yeah, I think so.
>> Or is it the fact that the audience didn't this audience
didn't take it well and now they're like twisting on it, twisting
it to make you look worse than you were because they know that
it's going to make you look bad because so everyone is so bad
faith. I'm just saying in a different group, in a different bubble,
they would have understand Tom's point. >> You had sexual
harassment. Like if you >> What was the point? Rick says
like what was the point? He just made a lot of weird like creepy
messages. There was no point.
>> the point was to troll or be rude back because I basically
said he was a weirdo. Like that was just a knee-jerk
>> Like there's no What point was being
>> I literally don't know. >> I don't understand
how anyone can have such a powerful opinion other than like,
"Hey, you made her uncomfortable. Just apologize and move on."
Like that's not it's not even a big deal. Like Kelly's probably
not going to like him. Like from the very beginning that was
I think the solution. That was it. Just say, "Oh, made her uncomfortable.
Keep cuming whatever, however you want. Just apologize and don't
do it again to Kelly." Like just do that. >> Just move
on, brother. >> He didn't even have to apologize or move
on. He just had to like stop bring it up and stop being a weirdo.
Or literally, he could have just like stayed there and kept being
a weirdo and never engaged. It's the weird thing where he It's
like the jumping back and forth between him being comfortable
with like being kind of afo
on his stream and then him being like, "You guys can't call me
this." It's like, if you're going to pull up like an Asian girl's
picture and sit there staring at it for 20 seconds without commenting,
and then like have your chat saying like, "Oh, damn. She got
me having yellow fever." And like, if that's the community you're
going to foster, then people are going to call you a weird like
a degenerate. Like, you are doing weird [__] on your
stream.
But you can't be upset that people feel that way.
>> I don't know any like decent streamers that like bring
up girls Instagrams if they're not like 17 like year old streamers
or like people like Aiden Ross or whatever. Like I don't know
anyone with a brain. Like Destiny doesn't just bring up random
Instagram girls on his like stream cuz he's not a idiot either.
>> I was like, >> "Yeah, this guy wants to be a kick
streamer. Just be a kick streamer." Like that's what I feel like
he wants to do. He wants to be on that. >> It was just
weird. >> Yeah. Also, his like weird that like
the best was when he came in, he was like, "Uh, Kelly Jean, can
you give me a normative reason why I can't pull your Instagram
up at on screen and like look at all your your pictures? Can
you give me a normative reason why I shouldn't do >> I
don't want you to." >> Like, oh,
>> I'm going to debate you.
It's like debating. >> I'm going to debate you out of your
ability to consent to things. It's like, oh, cool. >> To
be fair to him, he was probably looking for a normative reason
for that because he was he probably felt like you guys were saying
it was immoral to do this act. So, why is it immoral was probably
why he was >> I don't even
Nobody was saying it was immoral for him to do. >> I said
weird. >> I said, hold on. That's
be clear with what I just said because it sounds like every person
in this chat intentionally just misheard me because I said he
felt
>> like he was being called. >> I misheard you.
>> I don't care about Tom's stupid feelings that are based
on absolute dulu things. Like who cares? >> Mind you, I
do not know cuz I've had a very similar situation happen recently
where I made somebody feel unhappy with me. Uh not like creeped
out but unhappy. They were angry with me. Uh because I crossed
the personal boundary for them >> about that right now.
>> Oh, sure. No worries.
>> Wait, what?
What was happening?
>> No, shut up. I'm not pulling anybody in. I'm sorry,
Seven. I'm It's cool that you're here. I'm literally We already
can't get through this VOD with this many people. >> Wait,
we can't finish our story. >> Oh, no. >> I was supposed
to leave like an hour ago. For the love of God, let's >> Yeah.
No. Yeah. Yeah. Let's just continue. We'll get to the the part
about Kelly and then she can go. >> If you're not actually
telling somebody >> Renick says with peace and liberties,
a reason why Tom gets an infin infinite share ability. Um because
the evidence points to his favor.
>> A lot of evidence. >> It just points to his favor,
right? So like I know you're being weird in chat and you're trying
to catch me cuz I can tell by the way you type cuz I know patterns.
But he literally the evidence points on his favor. >> She's
got you Rhox weirdo. >> Do not know how to read the situation.
You are not giving the right evidence. There is absolutely no
receipts. All the evidence just says things just like all the
evidence points in his favor. Doesn't supply the evidence either.
And it's just like, okay, >> well, yeah, there really like
some of the cases where I'm like, I don't believe that story.
There really is no evidence either way. Maybe he did roll up
in like riot gear with airsoft guns and pretend to be SWAT. Okay.
But I I don't believe it. I feel like I would need I don't know.
I There's probably not evidence that I could see on that front
that would actually convince me it happened. Like, sorry, not
reasonable evidence that I could be given. It's It's so out of
the norm for what I'd expect that I might not be able to have
my mind changed on that,
>> but it Yeah, >> obviously the only people >> there's
no evidence that it happened either. He just says it happened.
>> Who are trying to bring up her seats are getting shot
down. So, you better bring up a better receipt. Okay. Hunter
says the point is that in the context Kelly expressing her discomfort
of him gooning over he wasn't gooning over her. So, you're wrong
there. So, now see >> is this Hunter Avalon? Who Who is
this >> Why is she? >> No, I'm pretty sure that's
I'm pretty sure that's my chatter.
>> Oh, okay. um
what's his name? Infinite Hunter in Discord. I think >> that
she's begging him for it constantly. None of that is true. He
wasn't gooning over her on stream. I saw the stream. It was a
17-second clip. He wasn't gooning over her. And even if he was,
he's allowed to. And if she doesn't like it from him, they don't
have to be friends. If he wants to do >> Do you like this?
>> We were never friends. We never We're friends. We never
will be friends. This has nothing to do with being friends. It's
like just stop. He Well, the funny thing is is like I actually
agree with Britney on all of these things, but then all all he
had to do was not come in and make those weird comments. That's
all he had to do. Like just the Instagram thing that blows over
in 2 seconds. Nobody's actually upset. I'm sorry. Like as much
as Kelly is like >> weirded out, him just pulling up the
Instagram thing. If he just minimizes that clip and walks away,
literally nothing comes out of this at all.
So, I don't know. >> Maintain a friendship with her. He
can change his behavior, but like he wasn't gooning over her
on stream. Think that's what happened.
>> The chat because you're too goddamn damn too goddamn
dumb to have the conversation. He was not in any way gooning
over her on stream. That 17-second clip that she made a big deal
out of and then took back when I was on that and then decided
it wasn't big deal. I said he was a weirdo. Weirdo. >> No
[__] >> Consider it sexual. >> No messages.
>> Destroyed, Kelly. No, [__] You got destroyed.
destroyed
>> uh that I was trying to keep you defend myself against
what she's a public eth thought. She exists for objectification.
Was that a serious statement or an unserious state? >> No,
it was obviously a joke.
>> Where's the fact that it's partially true that >> Wait,
pause this. Pause the pause. This is one of the most I'm trying
to dial back on the R word. I apologize. Um th this is incredibly
stupid. The idea that this is a joke. Yeah, sure. It's a joke.
But it's a joke when, if correct me if I'm wrong, he was upset
at Kelly, was he not at the time? >> Yeah, sure. It's just
an insult, isn't >> Oh, it's so it's insult. >> It's
an insult. So, he meant to degrade her. And the thing that he
went for is that she's like a thought. >> That is a that's
a not an appropriate thing to be going after unless he's like
on some red pill and then I would just say he's on some immoral
whatever [__] you know? I'd fight that on the grounds.
So, either he's like, "Oh, yay, progressive, whatever." Who's
just throwing at somebody who
uh in a way that we I would hope all disagree with because he
got mad
or he's just some red pill guy. Like, what's those are your
>> Okay, there is there's hold on. There is a middle ground
and I'll present this because I presented it last time and everybody
wants to say I'm not good faith. His argument is that when somebody
does work, you should be able to they are objectifying themselves
in a way that makes them money. That is their job. So when he
objectifies somebody who does work over their sex work, that's
a net good because you're supporting their work and their ability
to do that work. And so when he says that, so I agree with you.
I 100% think he'd said it to degrade her. But his argument is
going to be, "Oh, no, no, no. I said it because because obviously
her content is that of like somebody who sells pictures of their
body. So that that makes it okay to make that comment because
the p the purpose of those pictures is
>> Okay. So then so then I would put >> to minimize
me, right? And if you say things like that then you can disregard
my arguments or feelings on the matter completely. So then I
would put him in that second group where he has like a redpilled
look at this where she's because he feels like she's objectifying
herself that means he can objectify her. Like I don't think that's
even if I were to agree that she's objectifying herself. I don't
think that gives me the right to objectify somebody else or >> And
he he also made a stronger statement. He said I am an eth that
exists for objectification. So that is like my sole purpose in
life. So I think and again >> that's why it was an insult
>> for infinite charitability. He's saying as an online
influencer that is your like primary job your content online
exists for >> people do other things online like just because
you exist in one facet online doesn't mean that is your entirety
of your online presence. It's just >> yeah. So then that's
again where I would bring it back to the binary because it is
a binary. I would have an issue with the moral implications of
his worldview period fundamentally. So the joke is made from
a position of or from a place where I think he has an immoral
worldview to be able to make like his perspective is not good
that he's >> Yeah, I mean I agree >> doing that.
So like it's it's either he's making a he's being a weird progressive
or he has like a really worldview overall. And I mean it seems
>> I I I you know keep it above 50. I don't know what his
politics are. >> Uh yeah, he's not a progressive but he
does have like I would say progressive views on work and he would
like I think he actually believes he's like worked this out logically
in his head. He believes this is like a good but it's like yeah
there are obviously like this assumes that everybody who does
work or uh even things adjacent to sex work is completely comfortable
with that work and enjoys it and wants to be like lauded for
it. But I would imagine at least if if Lav and maybe even Kelly
are any indication, there are probably a lot of people who do
work or adjacent work like um modeling of some kind who aren't
necessarily comfortable. >> Okay, I don't agree with this.
You you said this uh it's not I don't have an issue with it.
It's
the right time and right place and consent. The other problem,
if someone were to message me something on my Only Fans and then
I decide I want to respond to it, like this is an appropriate
place to be
deviant, I suppose. But on your kick stream as a part of watching
um like me be on like a political debate of some kind whilst
having that up on your stream and then bringing up my Instagram
and what have you. It's not an appropriate setting
>> and I did not consent, which is really >> This
reminded me of another one of the lies. He was like, "Oh, we
had a chatter who didn't know who Kelly was and they wanted us
to pull up Kelly's Instagram." That was what he said when he
came in. >> Wait, do you have a clip of him saying
>> Yeah. Well, I can go find it. I don't I literally don't
I when I talking about these things, I can go find it in the
stream, but >> Yeah. Yeah. I'm not trying to I'm not trying
to find tricky because I I know he said that. It's just that
would probably be a good thing like if it ever gets brought up
again for him just like straight up to show he was straight up
>> Yeah, maybe we have to. But so he said that but just
so it's clear. Um that same chatter who was a mod of his also
got him to bring up Kelly's Instagram like a week and a half
or two weeks earlier. So
>> it wasn't even that that guy didn't know who he was
or who Kelly was rather. That's literally had nothing to do with
it. They were just in my opinion bring it up to to degrade Kelly.
I think that was the entire point. I That's >> I I got
like 10 minutes before online
means she doesn't want to be objectified. Obviously, it's a two-layer
joke. All jokes have a sense of humor and a sense of truth. >> So,
obviously, he's being a joke hyperbolically
being bigger than the joke. But obviously, it's true that Kelly
Jean has no right to tell people not to objectify her online
in the way that she's being objectified, literally has explicit
content online. >> Because I am a human being. >> Wait,
wait, wait, wait. Can we can we pause this?
>> Does Britney Simon agree
>> with object? It is it is you are objectifying yourself
doing this thing.
>> There's there's no way Britney Simon agrees with this
tag.
>> Does she knowledge is one of the people in the camp
where I believe that they think objectification is a good
>> uh bruh. Okay. I might have to talk with her because
I think she'd have a conversation with me cuz that's just that's
not at all what objectification is. But okay. >> Objectification
is intrinsically bad.
>> Oo, that'd be interesting. I'd like to talk to you about
that.
>> It's
definitionally dehumanizing.
I think I've heard Kyla give her take about objectification
in some feminist literature where her idea of it is it is separate
from the dehumanizing aspect that that is you can objectify
and do it in a a wanted way without dehumanizing or
I don't know something else. >> We have a word for that.
It's called
>> Yeah, I know. I somebody and that's not
Somebody is not dehumanizing
>> because the subject is still on the >> Yes, it
is. I'm somebody because as people we are the nature we have
like characteristics
humans are like pretty intrinsically right like we'll want to
>> have desire.
Yeah, maybe you're right. Maybe you're right. I'm not going to,
you know, delay this any further. My bad. >> No worries.
>> Just so you know, they talk about it on the Wick panel
yesterday. >> Oh, cool. I might have to review that, too.
I did kind of want to watch it. So, >> choose how the world
reacts to you. You can only have your own feelings about it.
And then Tom can decide to adhere to those feelings or not. >> I
cannot control if you objectify me. I can only control if I block
you from my stream or if I end my friendship with you. I cannot
control if you objectify
>> It doesn't make any sense.
>> I don't need to control people. I just like reserved
the right to call them little freaky weirdos if they do it in
a weird way. >> And then he got mad. He got mad and engaged
himself. Right. In Britney's worldview, Tom's up, hasn't he?
Shouldn't he just block us and move on? Shouldn't he just end
the friendship and move on? >> Wait, hold on. In her worldview
though, to be fair, it's that you guys um are making public statements
about him that is potentially reputation ruining,
>> Okay. But but she's saying they're lies in my bubble.
Fest isn't reputation
>> Wait, that's not true.
>> Well, listen. I can't make anything anything in my bubble,
really. It's my >> Oh, I see. >> You're doing a thing.
I got you.
>> So, it's that's But that's the point I'm making. And
I literally I we could talk about it after, but I'll uh I'll
just hit play. We got to continue. I I have some other points
to make, though. >> Have your cake and eat it, too, people.
That was a serious statement that was made fairly hyperbolically.
>> All right, verdict. >> Right. Hyperbolically serious.
It's a >> No, no, you said it was clearly a joke, Britney.
You dumb. She was like, "Oh, no. That's clearly a joke. It's
clearly unserious." And then he says, "Serious." And she just
moves forward. >> Very specific. This is a very specific
point Tom is trying to make and it is
>> It's not harassment. It's public content. Serious statement
or unserious >> Serious statement. >> Okay. I will
keep Kelly on my screen every stream. Serious statement or unserious
state? >> Unserious statement. So, you made two unserious
statements apparently and two serious statements. But you defended
the I will keep Kelly on my screen comment >> it's a perfectly
fine comeback
obviously
because again it's that whole like don't tell me how to live
my life when you're obviously being a little [__]
about it. Kelly is one of the most bad faith [__]
in the sphere. She literally all the time. >> She just
says things about me.
>> What goalposts have I moved? I said he was a freaky
little weirdo before and I still think he's a freaky little weirdo
and that's all I said. >> How to live my life. >> when
you're obviously being a little [__] about it. Kelly
is one of the most bad faith [__] in the sphere.
She literally smears people all the time. She moves gold post.
>> Her and J
basically the same person. >> Uh she's going to It's all
comes down to the Anna thing. By the way, >> I smeared
her cuz I said her tattoos are
>> Look, I'm sorry. They are. But she's still a very attractive
young woman,
>> Okay. All right. >> I refuse to let the >> There's
lots of people with bad tattoos. I would like actually >> No,
no, no.
>> Shut up. I can >> looping. Okay. >> No,
I'm not going to. I was just going to say that I would approximate
like 50% of all people that have tattoos are bad.
>> Shut the when I get to them. And no, I will not talk
to you. Thank you for
>> And it's because you are so bad faith.
>> It is so [__] bad faith. This whole conversation
has been hours of me
bad faith to say someone's a weirdo.
>> I think >> I think she just hasn't watched the
content you were in, Kelly. But
>> I literally think she just hasn't watched the content
you're in at all. >> Not hang out with people. >> But
she's been told about this before. >> That [__]
around. Kelly, >> I literally went in and have a conversation
with her.
>> Move on. >> She talking to you, Kelly. >> Yeah.
Well, maybe if you could pause it when I speak sometimes,
>> cuz you never do. >> All right. >> On that
panel that I was on literally said she wasn't even that bothered.
I don't even need that apology. I don't even want these things.
Then stop opening your mouth.
>> No, stop these bad faith people. Stop trying to build
a bridge with people
>> uh I don't know >> that are waiting for their
opportunity to [__] blow it up. >> At least
one place if not two. You said DMC Amy if you want me to take
them off. >> Yeah, I may have. Like as I said
about knocks it down to three serious comments and one unserious
one. I believe the other one was serious, too. And you were just
trying to gross her route trying to get in her head because you
were pissing off. I think you were >> Hunter. Unless you're
a YouTuber and especially if you're a YouTuber, I don't want
to engage with you. I'm a YouTuber in this sphere. I engage with
these people. I've made contact with these >> Get destroyed,
Hunter. Get destroyed. >> I've watched hours of these streams.
Do not come at me and be like, "Oh, you're missing context."
You're missing context.
I am the streamer. You are the peeon. Get it together. You're
the person who doesn't know my work. You are new to >> Jesus
Christ. >> Who is she talking to? >> She's talking
to Hunter Young.
>> He's in YouTube chat right now.
>> My chat. I don't know who the you are, but you can go
watch my pen stream covering this book. And I'm not going to
stand here and have you in my comment section like, "Oh, you're
missing context. Your mom is missing the context." I asked her
last night when I was with her. You absolutely do not know what
I know and you're absolutely wrong and my own chat can call you
out right now. You're being outrageous. Sit down. >> Just
Maddie came in and you decided, "Yeah, she doesn't like objectification.
I'm going to objectify as hard as >> By the way, none of
my audience is a peon. All my audiences are kings and queens
and they just hunters the peon. Everybody else is on the >> Oh,
big news. Big big time sad news. Kira Toriyama, the creator of
Dragon Ball, dead at 68.
Holy. No shot.
>> Dra Dragon Ball Z or just Dragon Ball >> Literally
all of it.
>> I didn't know there was >> except for Super. But
>> no, except for GT. >> Remember that point when
I said I was going to be here for 10 more minutes. >> He
He did Super.
>> Oh, sorry. Wrong. >> You can wait for Dragon Ball
>> the same level just
peon.
>> Okay. Yeah. Okay. Just to be clear, Wolf Gang didn't
understand the difference between Toriyama not being involved
with GT and not being involved with Super because he was involved
with he's an assistant writer on Super Arguments that you're
reading are arguments about whether or not it's right or wrong
to pull up somebody's Instagram. So those are like obviously
yes put in a very hyperbolic manner, but there are obviously
arguments about yes whether >> even the unserious ones
you know when just like seriously had a criticism of you and
called you sex but obviously he was being like hyperbolic. >> I
feel like you were doing a more extreme version of that even
with the unserious comments. So when you said that she's an eth
that's all she's good for. Obviously, you don't actually think
Kelly is only good for that. But also to some degree, you do
think she is an eth thought. You do think she should just be
fine with the fact that like you do feel these things as well,
right? That's my understanding. Even the unserious >> I
mean, both things are true.
She's not just an eth thought, but worse than an eth thought,
she's just a crybaby
>> who moves the goalpost and makes it about her. >> Have
I cried about anything?
Uh, >> is it crying to say, "Tom, you're a
>> What does that mean?
so unattractive. Still have like a genuine criticism barked where
point was not that that's like her value as a human. I was saying
that that's her value as like a content creator. That that's
why she's on streams. That that's why like she would be talking.
>> Mikey with the super chat says booze in the chat for
Hunter.
>> Hunter, don't come into this space, bro. If you don't
get it, you won't survive >> To destiny or that's why she
would be in this sphere as somebody that would be pulled up consistently
is because yes, like that's her value as a content creator. That's
how she got her clout. That's Yeah.
>> Hunter got blocked and you'll be next. Everybody get
ready. This is my safe space on the internet. >> Get that
ass banned. >> Okay.
All the evidence points in Tom's favor.
If you can show me some goddamn evidence that doesn't, I'm here
with you. But right now, that's not what's happening. And I'm
not friends with Tom.
But I've been in this space long enough to know you guys are
right now. Okay.
Don't [__] with me.
I'm better at my job than you'll ever >> Oh, are you supposed
to be scared,
okay. So, that was also you did a number on her because that
was like the first time she'd ever camped up on my stream
and this was the outcome. >> Messed up. >> Um, so
she doesn't do that. She doesn't promote her on my stream. She
doesn't talk about it. She essentially uh from all indications
seems kind of grossed out that she does it in some way. Like
I think she really likes the sexual element is something she
>> Okay. Well, I thought it was >> you weirdo sending
me weird Destiny related essays on my Only Fans again. Just don't
do that.
>> Kelly, you should charge for those messages. Okay, you
should charge for those messages.
>> Monetize the skitsos. Kelly, you have to monetize the
skits. I I have free messages cuz I I'm pretty inactive and I
don't want to charge people for like subscriptions and messages.
So that just means they send me essays.
>> So wait, is it free to message you or do you have to
sub and then they can message you? >> It's free for both.
I just have a free
>> So yeah, I only put out content when I'm like not feeling
like dog. So it's been pretty rare.
So yeah, it's being annoying. So that's why I don't promote
>> No, I don't think it's worthwhile. Also, >> you
literally just put in your description, hey, I will I you can
feel free to pay to message me, but I respond infrequently right
now because of
>> No, I just I don't feel like
people will can shouldn't be angry. I feel like for my only fans,
I prefer to be for people that actually like me. Uh, as in they
like my cosplayer or whatever, not random Destiny fans who just
want to scream at me.
I'm good. It's fine.
>> Uh, except because it's how you make money, right? And
it's how you get to do something you're passionate about.
>> Yeah. So, again, she was just debating. She was debating
counterpoints. She was debating a bunch of people. Literally,
like in the Destiny community, she doesn't cam up. She just debates,
right? >> She doesn't really debate on his stuff. And she
even admitted in that she was just insulting him that she was
just like going out. >> He's going to he's going to make
the point that oh you weren't debating you were insulting Connor
or >> he was insulting me.
I don't I don't understand how she insults are unhinged. >> I
don't see how that that doesn't add a moment anyway. Insulted
her, right? >> Okay, that's fine. I'm saying that >> she
counterpoint insinuated that she [__] Destiny. That
was the only reason she was on stream. >> Okay, I'm not
I'm not saying that it's bad for her to insult people. I don't
know why you're justifying it right now. That's not >> bad
for bad for me.
Ignores the fact that that was him insulting me.
>> She's just arguing insulting them.
>> Okay. I'm not >> See, CC see how Jaw confuses
people and then he's like, "How do you not get it, bro? How do
you not get it, bro?"
>> J, that is true. You do confuse me all the time. You're
white and you say the and it confuses me. >> It's It's
a mystery. Yeah. >> She's just debating and I'm saying
like from my perspective, the last >> So, that was her
content. That's like her content was was arguing with people,
having arguments >> that she's on there just debating,
but the last two things that I saw at first her arguing with
counterpoints just ripping into him and
>> sound
to Britney.
>> Hello. Like, where did I insult counterpoints anywhere
close to anything you said to me initially as he came in? >> Uh,
no. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. You don't get to get away
with this now just cuz Tom's unhinged. >> Okay. Where where
did I insult him? Do you do like a thousand little cuts, Kelly,
and then somebody eventually >> That's pathetic.
>> He insulted me first very soon after entering the the
voice chat. >> He probably did. Yeah, he probably did.
>> Yeah, he definitely did. That's why I didn't bother
engaging with him properly cuz he
saying this >> in terms of like getting in people's head
and making them upset. You're like a like a Golden Gloves boxer
who is picked off. >> Do you remember why he was? Because
you don't seem to remember that he was picked off as he arrived
in the chat just because I said he was boring. But you were just
saying the video was >> But what kind of psycho takes that
>> Uh I don't know. Somebody who didn't get the whole context
and probably got a message from Shatter. >> So somebody
stupid. Brilliant. Thanks. >> Sure. He probably came in
hot. Yeah.
>> [__] [__]
>> Simon kung fu. Let's go.
Let's go. Appreciate you guys. Thank >> Holding him over
and over. The thing I just saw maybe a couple days or a week
before was her ripping into Hannah and uh and like same thing
like making a bunch of sexual like a dirty >> No, Matthew.
I'm not going to engage in your weird Tom has power over his
audience debate.
No, I'm not engaging with this. I don't believe in this. I don't
believe bigger content creators can have No, I don't believe
this. Matthew, I will ban you too cuz you're like weird. You're
in a weird bubble. I don't like it. No, this is like when smaller
YouTube creators like Keeles goes after bigger content creators
and then she's like, "I can't believe these bigger content creators
are retaliating against me. I'm a small content creator." No.
If you're an adult on the internet engaging with anybody on the
internet, you're on your own. Girl the [__] up. Okay,
girl. The >> Who is she talking to? >> No one is
coming to save you. >> This is so weird for her to say
of all people, but I guess maybe it just had her pegged the wrong
way. I guess that's so strange. >> I just I still again
don't understand why she even like why is she even engaging with
any of this then
>> your goddamn self. Okay, if you're a grownup on the
internet, figure it the out. And at the same time, if you as
an individual find yourself to be more compromised, I give you
my sympathy and I will treat you thusly.
But you better be careful if you're saying Tom has power over
his audience. Like, bro.
Okay, relax. Okay,
>> Britney, what is your thought about John emulating certain
personality traits of a certain streamer? I have no idea what
you're talking about and I don't care. >> Everyone in the
space, you know, finds someone they like and trying to copies
their style. Everyone has a relationship with posting content.
All I know is that Jtock has no like
he has obviously some sort of intent in being here.
>> He can make that decision to be here, but it's obviously
bad faith. Whatever it is, it's bad faith.
>> Bad faith. >> Like a garbage
tattoos over and over her Instagram and insulted her. Like this
is the >> That never happened. That literally never happened.
>> Okay, maybe it didn't happen. that this is the um this
is >> going to say it >> from what I Yes, that's
what I read on the Reddit post about that. So, but anyways, yes,
>> why look into it though if you're going to make that
allegation on the stream? >> I I'm taking that JTO has
no place to tell Tom you better look into it if you're going
to make that allegation on the stream when JTO literally made
hours of allegations.
That's what I'm saying.
That's what I'm saying. JT will >> You know what? That's
actually kind of fair. I was I was shooting from the hip because
I wasn't prepared for the stream, right? So that that is actually
kind of fair that I probably don't have any right to actually
be angry that he's saying things. >> Literally do this
to Tom for >> But you know what? He didn't point it out.
So I still get the W in the panel last night >> for hours
and then if Tom makes one mistake, J's like, um, you better have
some evidence before you say this on stream.
Where's your evidence, JTO? Where's your evidence?
>> This has nothing to do with Hold on. Just be clear.
We have to do have to let Tom respond, but like I mean, yeah,
we do have to let Tom respond. So, like, let's just make sure
Tom can >> stop being bad faith. Yeah, I'll try to stop
being bad f
just be direct. Just just answer just >> That's what people
always used to say to me. You know, now you get that honor.
>> There you go. >> Where people just they don't
have anything else to say, but they're angry, so they're just
going to call you bad faith without actually explaining it in
any way at all. >> They are mad. Yes. It's like I don't
think you're telling giving a accurate feeling response. Uh something
is weird. Something is off. Uh
are you telling
>> You're bad faith now. >> Uh for some reason my
mic level is like way below everyone else's. Are you guys noticing
that I'm quiet on the stream by the way compared to like the
Discord?
>> Hold on. Is that a little better? It's not really a
lot better. I'll try to fix it. I'll see if anybody says it.
>> I think everybody's >> It's fine. Okay, >> just
try to be direct. >> Okay, that yes, the the like the debate
idea is like, yes, this is my this is my impression of her is
that she's just insulting people and making fun of people and
this is how she engages with other people and she justified these
things on Destiny stream. So like yes, my way of engaging with
her. See, at the time in my head seemed like it was like just
a a way that she engages that it would be okay. Obviously, I
was wrong, but that's yeah, my in my head at the time didn't
seem all that outrageous. >> Okay, so she engages by pulling
up people's Instagrams or focusing on their
>> Yeah. Well, is he? >> No, he means being mean.
He says I'm engaging in
there. It's really unfortunate this one instance of going after
somebody's appearance, Kelly, because now everybody will just
be like, "Oh, the Anna thing her Instagram." >> Yeah. And
it's not even really their
>> Why Why is she lunging at Okay, obviously being uh being
mean in a way is very different. We all know this, >> Sure.
And so this is going back to how we started. This is like this
is how I would analogize it. So it's only different in a sense
but not always different in terms of category
right so yes it's all a joke all jokes are blue what kind of
jokes are they well okay so the joke is meant to be me
>> if you have to go lower to engage
I I went I I'm rewinding so we can get all the >> Yeah,
I can't get >> So, okay. So, Kelly Jean has a very mean
way of joking, criticizing, getting into fights with people,
and then plays victim every time. That's Kelly Jean's
>> literally when >> destroyed, absolutely crushed
>> So then Tom when engaging with Kellyan
>> I don't know >> down to Kelly Jean level.
>> This is crazy. as if Tom keeps up with like the Kelly
arguments that she's clearly indicating to. And Britney's never
going to bring those up, by the way. Like I'm sure there are
even examples where she could maybe build the case. Like me and
Kelly have had issues before, right? And maybe she could be like
they were kind of rude and mean and but she's not going to bring
those up. She's not going to bring any of them up. She has a
general Oh my god, this is so
Oh, Kelly, you're getting real dirty, dude. She does not care.
>> No, I'm not. cuz like she's been going on and on about
how like just didn't bring any evidence to anything, but she
never brings any evidence to her claims that she's burging here.
She just says a lot of things about me and she did it last time
when she was saying that I am a liar but never really substantiated
that. And when I came on and just said, "Yeah, I'm just ill a
lot and I don't want to promote my Only Fans and this stuff's
weird and whatever." She was like, "Oh, okay. I get you because
you're ill all the time, blah, blah, blah." just immediately
forgets it.
>> barely on you on Wick's panel. >> Yeah, barely
anything because there really wasn't anything to respond to because
she was just being psychotic. I don't know. >> She got
destroyed on Wix's panel and sat there like rolling her eyes
and making faces instead of making any arguments. >> and
now she's acting like you owe her
>> Engaging with Kelly Jean goes down to Kelly Jean level,
which is why I'm saying don't engage with Kelly Gene. Block her.
Block Jtock. Block everybody that forces you to go down to a
lower level to engage with them. Block them all. Right? That's
my recommendation. If you have to go lower to engage, block.
Because if you go higher and they can't engage with you, which
they can't, they're useless. Okay. >> I can also make up
like a
>> correct me if I'm wrong, but hasn't Kelly gone after
women? And I can put myself at like a level 5,000 if I want to
because it's as meaningless as the stupid that she says as well,
right?
>> Who listens to that? It's just why >> mentally
mentally ill people probably >> actual deranged weirdos
>> Oh, and and Wreck is not mentally ill. >> Dude,
I've heard Kelly go after people for everything.
I don't want to hear her talk. Okay, >> more unsubstantiated
random. She's just >> talk about how Tom was unfair, >> [__]
What?
>> Tom makes a joke that coincides with the context of
the situation, which is in relation to him being allegedly aest.
So, he goes after Kelly with a >> Kelly didn't say that.
Kelly never said
>> Kelly did never say that.
>> He's a weirdo.
>> Yeah, I made sure that Tom knew that when he came in,
I'm pretty sure. I'm going to have to uh I have to re Now why
did they bring this back up? Now I have to review Tom content
and get timestamps. Why?
>> Okay. Okay. Can we do that when I leave? >> I
hate these people.
Obviously meaning to be a meme on the fact that people think
he's a but isn't any more than a person who's just into people,
right? So he jumps into it hardcore, makes the obvious joke that
any person could see that isn't bad faith and then makes the
joke. Where's the joke? The joke itself is obviously meant to
be a joke. >> You stupid
on the fact >> Americans when they try to gaslight you
that something is a joke and it's just criminally unfunny. >> And
I feel like she's clearly going against something that she is
agreeing with and Tom kind of agrees with. Now mind you, you
can say that they don't and they're just trying to look for an
excuse. But if you really think that it's healthy to be like
a towards people, you should probably teach people that like
just engage with the people that you're to in a in a respectful
way like it's in it's yeah it's insane for you to devalue the
idea of like yeah we think it's completely healthy for people
to be and we adore the idea of these people because they're beautiful
etc. But when those people, whoever it is, Kelly or whomever,
ask you to stop. Just be respectful. But instead, you're going
to do this thing where it's like, well, he's not really any more
of a than the regular.
Let the guy be a Just teach him to be respectful of boundaries.
That's all you need to do. That's all you need to do. I love
being a If anybody tells me like, "Hey, it's weird that you're
looking at me this way." Stop. You just say, "I'm sorry." And
you move on with your life. And you don't give it to them. It's
It's so easy. It's insane. Is it Is it easy, Wolf Gand?
Just apologize and move on. >> When he's not. So he's like,
I'm going to lean into it hard. Funny, >> maybe inappropriate
to you. I don't give a personally. I'm pretty neutral, right?
I'm pretty neutral. >> Literally, nobody has ever laughed
at Tom ever in his life. Aside from when his parents sent him
to jail would want >> I just I just clicked the video.
Hold on. Where were we, guys?
>> H I just clicked the I just clicked the
Now I need to pull up the the timestamps over here. Hold on.
I think I should have a relatively close time stamp. Just give
me a second. >> They should have a like go back button
where like if you click randomly, it should be able to go back
to where you were couple seconds ago. >> Oh,
we were somewhere around our relevance head. So if I pull this
up, it's like somewhere around right here. >> Which is
in relation to him being
funny. Maybe inappropriate to you. I don't give a personally.
I'm pretty neutral, right? I'm pretty neutral. So, her new channel,
I saw that, too. >> Cool. Be offended. You and my mom can
go to church together. Okay. If Tom regrets doing it, cool. He
can regret it.
>> Okay. We all can of opinion, but everyone's acting like
there's a black and white, end all be all that 100% wrong or
right. Girl, where do you live?
>> this is all subjective. Girl, girl, the [__]
up. >> Something like suck my dick. I'm fine. >> It's
all subjective. It's all subjective, but she doesn't respect
our subject. Like, >> it's fine. >> Doesn't Yeah.
What? >> I can just sit in my bubble and say this guy's
a weird sex freak. Like, I can just sit here and say that. And
why is she engaging? Why is Why is Tom engaging with that is
fine. >> A saying that you're saying, but it's obviously
so ironic that you're not actually the person. >> You would
never say I would never say Tom is sucking my all the time. That's
not how you make that that insult. >> Yeah, it is. Sure
it is. Why not? Who the [__] is Jtock? He doesn't
even know what drugs are. Who's JTO? He hasn't even left his
mom's basement.
>> Don't even know what to say. That is obviously ironic
based on what it is that she's saying on stream about behind
that. Obviously, I think >> Well, you just said it's like
the suck my dick thing. >> Correct. The irony of it. The
fact that it's not actually a real statement. You're not actually
telling them to suck your dick. And then in this case, I'm not
actually telling her to that that I'm not actually saying that
she was obsessed with me or that she was uh that she wanted my
dick.
>> And I think that was obvious. >> I don't neither
of us is arguing that you actually mean this. It's about what
you're trying to do with the comment. And you've argued that
it's like self-deprecating. And now you're saying because she
was mean, it was okay for you to be mean back. So now
it's everything. It's all of the things. He's self-deprecating
because he's calling himself a pest. You idiot. And then he's
also going after Kelly because it's mean. It's both. It's self-deprecating
because he's leaning into the pest, which is a self-deprecating
joke. >> Not self-deprecating jokes. >> If you
say stupid. These aren't self-deprecating jokes. You stupid and
you stupid. You're getting a light. >> Sure. If you lean
into the pest thing, why are you upset when people call you a
sex pest? >> This is literally the Darius problem. You
can't send the messages he does to people and then get upset
when people are like, "Yeah, you're you're weird with women."
Okay, if they say that like he a woman or woman or something
women, if they say that he ripped a woman or something, then
he can get mad. But if it's just like, "Hey, you're like super
weird. You might be a best around women." I don't think he can
really challenge that because he leans into it so hard
>> because he's like, "Yeah, I'm a pest." And then he's
being mean and going down to Kelly's level to hit her with a
joke that Kelly herself would make about somebody else, but in
a different way. In Kelly's own way. >> I wrote it literally.
Never in my own way. What does that mean? So that means it's
absolutely nothing like what he would say.
That's such a pointless thing to say. Kelly would make this joke,
but she wouldn't actually make this joke. She would make an entirely
different kind of joke. Yeah. No,
>> what a worthless statement. >> Not just that one
comment. There's a number of comments that we're talking about.
That comment is uh is obviously like, yes, very hyperbolic. I'm
not justifying it, not saying this is why it's okay. I'm explaining
my my frame of mind as I'm saying,
>> okay, Ivy, like >> like we've already been over
the idea that I shouldn't say these things and I've already said
this. So, is there like another point? Only if Tom doesn't want
to say these things and only if it break Listen, the only person
who can tell me how to talk on stream is
After that, I'll take it into consideration, but no guarantees.
>> So, going over this outside of that? >> Yeah.
No, I I just wanted to get those. >> Shadow says, "Imagine
having to explain a joke like this, bro. It's like even the in
my audience get it. How do these people not get it?"
>> Not that's a joke, too, cuz people with autism get a
lot of jokes. You guys are
>> Several motivation out of the way. you're saying there
for different comments. Nobody believes that this is ironic.
I think >> I I believe that everybody who watches this
will understand that she did this specifically because she's
mean because you think it's okay to in this way because of how
grossed out she was by it. Um probably because of her proximity
to me would be my assumption. >> What do you mean? Sorry,
I I fed you into that >> because of the text comments I've
made because I I pointed this out originally. >> For the
record, Kayla in chat,
neither Kelly nor JCO are acting like ones, right?
This is they're not playing a
right. Like it's it's if you want to joke about them being one
behavior, I'm into the joke. But if you want a real answer, like
none of them are displaying activities of ones. They just seem
like twos to me. Uh like narcissisticy twos, like traumatized
twos, you know, made it to level two. >> They could I don't
have enough information to think about. >> Who's the narcissist
and who's the
>> Both of you. >> Who have I been traumatized by
here? >> I don't know. She knows. I'm definitely the narcissist,
but >> you guys are probably at least a three.
>> Okay. All right. To begin with, because Tom came in
and did all this, I assume mostly because he was angry at me,
which just made it weirder that he was directing it at Kelly.
>> Yeah. I mean, I have a hard time um I have a hard time
the comments obviously. >> weird weird take weird take
weird take. >> So weird not to them, >> but that's
how they feel. >> Okay, you're kidding. Kayla, just checking
girl. I just didn't want to I wanted to give a serious answer
cuz it's serious. Okay. I love that Kyla is saying this about
herself because I personally like don't agree. But maybe it's
cuz I also grew up with like brothers and boys and like I've
been called a boy my whole life. I mean I am a man. >> That's
weird. >> Didn't have like a similar situation. >> Seriously
saying that I I >> You guys all talked at the same time.
What's up? >> Uh I said your mom has sweet cheeks and I
love being inside him.
>> Get faster pausing. Jesus. >> Also, I'm eating.
I'm trying to finish this stupid food anyway.
>> Trying to finish the food.
>> go [__] yourself.
>> I'm literally sick. I've been sick the past two days.
Today
I started streaming >> I started streaming
two and a half hours early for Kelly G. four doctor's appointments
in
>> me the entire stream.
>> I'm such a good friend all the time. >> I want
to make a joke about Kelly being abusive, but considering >> considering
what we're watching this
>> I didn't do anything to deserve this >> both the
butt of the joke. That's the
>> Um I think like the nature of it gets inherently when
you had pulled her up on screen to kind of like all out with
the kum time. She said she was uncomfortable and then um god
now I need to pull up the order of these messages. Uh, I know
it's right here. Um, yeah, Kelly is begging for my I understand
that you're joking about it. You don't actually think that she's
begging for your dick, but it also it's hard to get away with
that section when the entire premise of what she's upset about
is about her Instagram, which is in and of itself.
>> Oh, so it is a Instagram. So maybe she should take it
the down. Ardite is sheltered. I mean, Kyla is sheltered. That's
the whole point. >> I feel like we're just watching a bunch
of sheltered people who have never engaged in different kinds
of humor. And that's a bubble. Bubbles. Like we
>> this [__] did BDSM and hung out with shoe
and head one time and think that's that makes her well traveled
or some [__] I don't get it.
>> Like I don't understand where she's coming from that
she thinks she's got all these experience experiences.
>> I I just don't understand. She's literally been a YouTuber
for her entire adult life.
She grew up in the hood, dude. She I
I don't believe very much about this
I don't know. >> We do shelter. You >> know what
I do believe about this person and I've believed this since day
one is that she explicitly packages therapy like an equivalent
to psychotherapy with work so she can harvest and farm the most
mentally ill people online, the most lonely people online. Those
are the people she targets.
>> Uh yeah. No, I I started coming up with that way before
Mr. Girl did that guy. Okay. I I called that on this B from day
one. You sell You sell watching anime episodes and pictures of
your to the loneliest dudes online and then go, "Oh, I I wouldn't
possibly I couldn't possibly exploit them. I set perfect boundaries."
If you set perfect boundaries, why did you have to get a restraining
order against a stalker?
I don't know. Like, I I just I don't >> I don't think that
correlates.
>> Okay. Well, listen. I was going to say it was one of
her customers, but now I actually don't remember. And I don't
want to make that accusation with you here cuz I know you're
going to call me on it. >> You're goddamn right it will.
>> Yeah. So I had I had to weaken that accusation in the
middle of making >> the end.
>> You're talking about relationship boundary for her partner
to not engage with somebody,
>> but he still ended up and that girl stalked them. >> Okay.
Oh, then I misunderstood that and never mind on that part. But
I still believe the whole >> I'm so tired. Please press
play. >> And I love Kyla, but obviously like >> press
play. She's not. >> No. Like, this is what I'm saying.
This is a bubble and it's fine to be in this bubble. There's
not wrong. You know what I mean? But it's not also true. So,
again, like it's only Tom has to decide if he wants to keep engaging
and adhering to these people's behaviors or if he just wants
to do his own thing. Like, I'm really lucky. Obviously, I've
built my whole platform on my own. Like, I don't have to rely
on a community to stay afloat. I think sometimes people in this
space feel like they need to maintain these relationships to
stay afloat. And maybe they do, but I don't obviously. And I
recommend going that >> It's better to be independent and
do your own thing than like rely on those communities. And same
with like Papa does the same thing. Like a lot of us do the same
thing. It's better to have an independent platform that invites
people on when appropriate. But seriously, like
this
Yeah. Like if your business is writing on the fact that other
people have to approve your jokes. Mm-
>> Yeah. Sure.
Maybe just make them jokes in the first >> She's in the
middle of >> Tara says, "I have a couple of friends who
cannot do sexual jokes." I know some people do. Some people do
struggle with it. It is a real struggle for people. >> Americans
just call anything a joke. Like I don't understand like what
about these like weirdass statements that are just kind of creepy
andor insults give joke vibes. Like how
>> uh I don't know. Well, sorry. I do know. I understand
it. I think saying there's like absurdest humor where you say
absurd things and it's funny like 100%. >> Yeah, but there's
nothing super absurd about any of that. Like I know what absurd
absurdest humor is or observational humor as well. But it's none
it's none of these things. It's just an insult. >> Well,
it's subjective I would say, but I don't I don't see any reason
to >> Nobody would be like, "Oh, yeah, like take Tom's
jokes and give them to a standup comedian and get boobed out
the venue." Like that's not what is. All right, we good to go.
Can we hit play? >> Thank you, sis. >> I think so.
>> I can't adhere to there. I always say like, "Oh, I definitely
recommend you don't watch my stream or like watch my stuff."
You know what I mean?
Um, so yeah. Mantis says, "This whole thing was initially about
the Instagram. So pathetic. That's why I got on JTO's stream
to call them out. You too, Mantis. You don't have to listen to
me, but stop talking to Jtock. He's useless and he's just going
to [__] with you, bro. He's going to use everything
against you. Don't. You too, girl.
>> I I wonder so much if she would feel any sort of way
if people I mean she probably I'm hoping that she would be consistent
if people especially big creators are telling her to stay like
people to stay away from Britney Simon cuz she's insane. Uh and
she makes these crazy reads about people. I wonder if she would
have anything to say about that or she'd say like, "Oh, it's
all fair. Yeah, people can tell other creators to stay away from
me. Uh I don't I don't know. I hope [__] this I She
could also listen, this could all just be a like three head play
to
be like, "Oh, I'm just gonna make stuff up about this person
because I think he made stuff up about Tom."
But realistically, I'm sitting here and it's like, "You want
to come on and talk about any of this? I'm willing to, but she
won't
ever."
>> Okay, hold on. Just a heads up. Tom sent me a DM.
>> Oh, this is um >> I'm pulling it up on my phone
on stream cuz [__] you [__] Okay. Confirm.
>> Apparently Tom sends his entire criminal record to her.
>> Okay. Okay. So Tom sent me his criminal record and proof
of that criminal record. I'm not gonna, you know, obviously show
or anything. Looks real, looks right. Everything is correct.
Um everything is what he said it was so far on probation. Definitely
did these crimes. Everything JTO is saying like this never happened.
He doesn't believe like Tom did these crimes. I mean it's all
here. I see burglary. Uh I see the confinement. I see probation
time. I see uh I see the credit card stuff. I see the fraud and
>> uh some document that's on our phone. Got email from
Tom. >> I see the probation possibilities. Okay, I see
all of it. So, I don't know why J kept saying like um it's not
real. >> I don't I don't necessarily think that he didn't
do any crimes. I think the crimes are just far lesser than what
he's like trumped them up to be.
>> I don't believe he ever did these things. I'm looking
at a record. I mean, you can believe it or not believe it. I
mean, I know I'm just saying Tom stream. I could be lying. Uh
but it looks like everything Tom said is on this. I don't want
to say anything else, you know, in case. But looks real, looks
good. I've got an, you know, a name, an address. Obviously, I
don't want to dox anybody. So, I don't obviously that's not going
to be JTO to believe it. But I know one more person who's seen
it. So Jtock saying like Tom is lying about this. Like I Okay,
I Tom is the one giving the evidence. Tom has receipts that hold
up. >> Tom is the one with the evidence. JC brings fake
receipts. They get demolished. He claims they're still real.
With peace and love. >> I literally didn't bring any receipts
cuz I didn't even know I was going to be arguing with Tom last
night. No receipts
>> Okay. With peace and love. I've seen enough. I'm content
in that regard. Okay. I don't think Tom is lying. I have no reason
to think he's lying about his criminal record. JTO just hasn't
left his mom. >> There is no peace and there is no >> trouble.
It's what it is. You know what I mean? >> Debating somebody
on stream and that's kind of what I'm engaging with and not really
like thinking about the bigger picture of all this. Got >> sure.
Um, another lie that I was Tom got permission from everybody
who's on list and then he didn't know what the list was about.
Didn't know what the purpose of the list was realized. He knows
what the list is and why getting permission from everybody on
list. What do you need permission for people on the list for
if he didn't know what the list was? >> I So, from what
I understand, there was one list. There was one person who said
that they uh that I never talked to them about the list and then
they DM'd me and talked to me about it and then said that they
were going back onto your screen to clarify that there was some
implicit uh uh like consent there from that she not to go back
on because those names have been leaked out. So they're that
even that conversation that I'm aware of >> really so that
that didn't happen at bare minimum you're saying that before
you put this person on a list you said ask them put you on a
list. >> No operate consent operate like after >> yeah
I'm going to continue to meet on
>> Sorry that's too fast.
Turn this back down a little bit. >> I'm going to continue
to make a joke out of it. I want to make sure that yeah those
people are okay with it especially as more people started making
a joke out of it. Yeah. I want to make sure that the other people
who were included were okay with it and those other people were
joking about it and naming on it and posting and >> Thomas
welcome to memberships. Welcome. >> That was me getting
like some sort of >> fairly also on the list and didn't
get asked two people. >> I hate this. I hate this whole
conversation. What a brain dead
>> I I have spoken to about those sorts of things. So >> weren't
the other people like famous people though? Yeah, there was like
Pamela Anderson, Aar. >> Okay, I might have mistook it,
but I thought the joke was that actually nobody on the list had
given had been talked to because there
obviously you didn't reach out to Person.
>> Yeah. So, there were people who were my friends that
were on the list. The one person that wasn't my friend was and
so >> what's the list
>> No, it was literally nothing. So, it was like um there
was some sort of confusion where uh seven had posted a joke and
that like she had posted a joke on Twitter. I mistook it. I misunderstood
it. I got offended. She came to me, hey, it's just a joke. Like,
my bad. So, I was like, "Oh, okay." So I uh I pulled up a I typed
up a list with a bunch of different names on it. Pulled it. >> I
would say seven did come and say that he basically lied and misrepresented
this again in her opinion. So on >> the screen real quick
and then as I show it on screen I erase seven's name and say
well I guess
on stream so there wasn't like an actual thing to it. I was drunk
at the time. It didn't actually like it was just kind of a [__]
thing that I thought was funny and yeah but then other people
started posting >> I was drunk. There was a list. >> Oh
wait
[__] literally obviously. >> Okay. Okay. I
just like I feel like it's not being close and I need to understand
what the list is for. Is the list. Even if it's a meme, I get
you a joke. Is the joke that this is a list of women that you
want to [__] It's a joke. It's not like totally a
joke. >> I feel like
I I want Tom to explain to me the list in private almost
>> because I can't tell. There seems to be Okay, I'm going
to project something onto Tom that might be incorrect. There's
a ner my nerd divergent brain really wants to be explicit with
categorization because was it a list of people you wanted to
or was it a list of people you thought were hot or was it a list
of people for something else or was it a list because sometimes
the way Tom is answering I can't tell if it's actually is what
people are thinking it is or if it's something different that
like they can't say or if it's something it feels like you know
>> you have a list of women's names inside of a file or
something.
>> Oh yeah, I think it gets Oh, I might not have it pulled
up. Oh, it would have been on my stream. So yeah, he just the
joke is he has this um the list of women who he's going to have
sex with and there's another joke like an adjacent joke that
it was his rap list that these are the women he's going to rape.
>> if he was smart he could just say it's a list of hot
women and leave it at that. But he could literally just panic.
>> Yeah, he could literally just say it's a list of women
he wants to it's fine.
>> It's just a weird lying. >> No, stick with the
list. No one's going to take that seriously and it could be kind
of funny. Yeah, it's
my
>> it's just it's just all weird that he has to lie about
it and say like no no I don't the list doesn't mean >> feels
like a lie. See it feels like there's almost like not like he
can't just say it because he almost wants to say something else
but if he says what it is it might sound worse than what they
think it is or better than what it is. Like what is it? Is it
just a list of people you would want to? Because like honestly,
>> yeah. Isn't that just saying like, oh yeah, if the opportunity
came up for sure, which
>> it's weird to make a list of it. >> But also,
if it's a group of your friends, I don't know. I [__]
my friends, so I don't know. Like in the past, obviously I'm
married, but in my past, like obviously the people I've been
with were people that I considered friends. So I think your friends
are the like unless they're your friends are like siblings, which
I have three of my inner circle are like my siblings. I don't
[__] them, but all my other friends that don't feel
my like my >> Good to know. >> You know what I mean?
So, I can't tell if it's like a like a neutral like we made a
list. Like also, don't you just make I can't tell. Something
feels weird. I refuse. Something feels
>> weird. I don't know. I just um it feels something,
you know. >> You know, it sounds something, >> Alex
says that's like teenage diary list material. Yeah. Something
something,
>> You know, uh Paul, that's not funny. And if you say
it again, I'm going to delete you just cuz like I understand
edgy jokes, but I don't like that joke. Um >> substantial
doubt asks, "Didn't Cherry say Britney like 10 people total?"
I have no idea.
>> I don't know. >> She doesn't like edgy jokes,
but the stuff that he said to me wasn't edgy.
>> I'm not going to talk about things that I know Britney
does not like me talking >> Oh, fair enough. >> You
just did in a way.
>> Referencing a previous fight that we've had that we
squashed and we got past and so I have not done any of those
things
>> Oh, no. That's fair. That seems fair. >> Oh my
god. Two on stream as a joke. Um
I don't know. >> Tom is like if a parasocial viewer became
a streamer. You don't have to look at Tom. Just look at me. >> Oh
maybe maybe like a list of people you want to bring up on stream
to look at. Louis says, "Look, if you have friends, we all know
who we are attracted to and why that would why would that be
weird?" Yeah, I think like the list makes it weird, but like
I don't know if it makes it that weird. I don't know. It doesn't
seem that weird. It doesn't make it that weird, but it is >> implication,
but also there's like a ton of people that I'm friends with on
the list. That's obviously like >> I literally like I don't
think the list is even a bad thing. You can just say I was drunk
and apparently it seemed like while I was drunk a funny idea
to make a list of women I found attractive or that I you could
even say that I wanted to. You could say all of that. It literally
it doesn't matter. It doesn't matter. It's just the weird lying
and saying that it means nothing that >> So just like your
concern is is it that he pulled >> Yeah. Why are they being
weird about that? Like yeah, but but like also it's not a real
list, you know? on stream that only made the joke or does he
know? >> It was No, my concern is when when it was brought
up on Wick, he said one permission from everybody who was on
the list to be on it. And he also said that he didn't know what
the list was.
>> Yes, that's still the case that what's funny about it
is that there isn't like an actual meaning to the list that it's
not an actual list of things that it's or people. >> So
why would you why would you lean into the meme that we both know
about with the anyone Destiny's ever [__] for
>> Wait, none of Wait, hold on. How does >> What
does that mean? What is that from? That mean anyone Destiny's
ever women that Destiny was that a list of women that I'm saying
on that? Hold on. I'm saying on that list was the words anyone
Destiny's ever before. Where did those words come from? >> Oh,
that's from another meme. Yes, that's from another meme. >> What's
the list meme on that meme?
>> What's the list meme on that meme? Is that what you
said? >> Yes. Every girl who has ever talked to >> So,
when you put those words on there, what is that referring to?
>> That like that they have sex with all of Destiny's exes
or girls that he's had sex with. >> Why? Okay. But you
you're not aware of the meme this comes from? >> The picture
of me holding a a list that says anybody that Destiny's ever.
>> Yeah, exactly. >> Okay. That's where you pulled
it from, right? That's the meme. >> Yeah. I don't I don't
I don't know if >> Can someone in the Discord link me that
meme, please, so I can put it on screen. Thank you. >> Was
at the added at the time. I think that was something that was
added way later. But yeah, this is a meme that like carried on
for a while, so I'm not I don't remember exactly. >> And
also, >> I don't get it. Well, I'm missing something. What?
Are you guys getting
Mantis says, "It's not that complicated. It was just females
on a list to leave it open to interpretation. Maybe it's to signal
to these chicks are hot or just some chicks like it's not malicious."
Yeah, but like why was it written? Is this meme court, Zim? Like
why was it written? Right.
>> Like why was there a list? I'm so confused on the list.
I don't get it.
>> Was it just a list of like
is it just a list of people he like I just something doesn't
see someone's lying.
Something's not I'm lost. I'm too lost. So, someone's lying.
It's either >> I mean, she's right. Someone is lying, but
it has to be Tom. Like, what? You don't make a list for no reason.
You don't expend that energy for literally no purpose. He could
literally just say, "It's a joke." I was playing into the meme
that I want to like all these women. So, I made a list because
I >> "Yeah, substantial data. I know I put it on screen,
but this is my VOD. This is >> That's not actually possible
to just do things. You have to have a reason to do
Uh yeah. Well, >> I don't have the but I put other ones
in the side chat.
>> Wait, you put what in the side chat?
>> Different photo memes. I can't find the rapist one.
>> Somebody get me the rapist one. That's what I want is
the rapist one. >> I don't trust JTO cuz he's making an
insinuation that Tom must have everyone Destiny. That's not that
hard. If Destiny [__] everybody, right? Then everybody
in the arena is somebody Destiny [__] Like it's if
Destiny everybody, okay, whether they're progressive or conservative,
it doesn't matter. That means anyone you will be some if you're
in the same sphere. But obviously Destiny hasn't literally everybody
obviously. So like I don't like JT stock insinuating that Tom
wants to [__] everybody that Destiny
cuz then that's insinuating that Destiny like that's such a weird
thing. So I don't trust that. But then I don't trust how Tom
is answering either and I want to know what he's trying to say
>> blabbering on about. He says, "Hearing Britney explain
simple social situations like this makes me really makes it really
seem like these people are all in this space for real." Oh, they're
all definitely nerd. >> I can't follow her very well. [__]
They're obviously also trying to find no one's having these like
these conversations don't happen like this in
>> Manta says it was at the end of the stream. He was drinking
and it was in a cheeky mood. So, he's around to delete seven
from the list and then he then it then he ended stream.
>> So, is he drunk on stream making the
>> Cuz then that makes total social context sense. So he's
like, "Guys, hey guys, I'm going to make a list of all the
And then he's like doing >> Yeah. Yeah. That is fine. Literally
nobody cares about that. It's that he's saying he has no idea
what the list is >> The list and then you know what I mean.
>> Is that the Is that how the list came about? How did
the list happen? Was he on stream drunk then made the list as
a joke? Because then all of that makes sense. Why the is this
confusing?
because he's not admitting that he made the list. >> This
is chronically online. Literally,
>> Yes, he was drinking. This is so dumb. Why isn't he
saying that? Tom used to say, "Hey, I was drunk. I thought it
was funny to make the list. Maybe I shouldn't have made a list."
But yes, if he did it on stream especially, then why are we all
confused? What is happening? Who's lying to me? Is somebody lying
to me? It could not. This is a nothing burger if it's what you're
saying it is. >> It sounds like he never even made a list.
It was in the context of that >> Well, this is the part
where really I don't know how you feel about this, but this is
the part where I'm like, this is I thought this was p pathological
lying, but it turns out it's compulsive lying where it's like
he's lying for no discernable gain. And literally everybody involved
is like please like we actually don't think it's bad if you did
this. Please just tell the truth. And he's like, we all can see
what was happening. We all see the pattern. We all see what he
was going for. And we're like, "Just tell the truth. This is
weird that you won't admit it." And he's like, "No, the list
didn't mean anything." It was like a list of names for no reason.
Like, why? Stop.
>> Why? Just stop. >> He's going for it. >> He
just needs someone to like stand there with a water bottle and
like spray him every time he does it and then he'll
>> Are you me right now? You're saying drunk Tom got on
stream and made a dumb list and everyone's blowing it out of
Yeah. Did he type it up on stream? Did he type it up on stream?
Cuz then what the [__] is the problem?
He said that he does say it. What the This is a nothing burger.
Oh my god,
bro. What?
>> Uh, just to be clear, go back to the previous stuff.
We already me that many people repeating, right? >> Okay.
So, you when you said you didn't know what the list was, you
were lying cuz you do know what the list is in reference to.
>> It's not being referenced to anything. That's the point
is that it doesn't actually like it's not actually a list of
girls that I would have sex with. Most of them are like just
friends that I've just hyped up real quick just cuz I thought
it was funny, but it wasn't actually like a list of anything.
It wasn't actually referencing a thing.
Okay. So, the reason that's not trans surely she's going to understand
that Tom is lying here, right? Surely she can't sweep up whatever
this mess was. >> I know what he's trying to say. But when
he says like, "Oh, it's not a list of anything." Okay. But the
action, the human action to write up the list has got to come
from somewhere, right? It has to come from somewhere. >> So,
did it come from beird?
Like, it has to come from somewhere, >> right? So, where
did it come from, >> weirdo? They're like that is the part
where I'm like see that doesn't make any sense cuz like nobody
just writes a list for no reason. So it has to come from somewhere.
Where's where did it come >> In fact got added to it just
as like even some girls with the yummy and say >> I was
watching the stream live. Okay. What was the what was the vibe?
Like what was the does anyone have the clip? Can anyone time
stamp me the clip of that stream? Is it still available? Cuz
then I can read the tone to you and we can throw it out the window.
Yeah. Is it a Mean Girls Burn book? Stop. Oh my god. Nail. Is
it like what was the point? But the Mean Girls burn book has
a purpose. So you put the list together. What was the purpose
of the list? Interesting. But no one brought up the stream clip.
Where? Yeah. Where's the stream clip? >> I'm offended that
I'm not on the list. And I say, "Okay, so I typed your name on
it." >> Guys, I'm going to have to point out here that
we have 618 concurrent viewers on YouTube right now and 101 likes
on the stream. >> I don't understand the huge difference,
the gulf of difference between those things. Golf. >> And
you know what? Yeah, >> Kelly still awake, too.
>> I need to buy a few things on Amazon. I
>> like the stream
if you like the stream. >> Okay, so people are like, "I'm
offended. I'm not on the list." >> Cherry said, "Three's
in the chat." If you like the stream, by the way, >> I
got chewing gum on my >> autism. It's a joke. Joke has
to have a punch line. What's the joke? >> Threes in the
chat. >> Yeah, threes in the chat. >> What's the
joke?
>> Yeah, it's the Riot L. >> My bad.
>> I have not stopped doing that.
>> Joe, but didn't get the point. >> I'm just hearing
people screaming in the >> Darius is like dying down there.
>> Is that you guys? Oh, my bad.
Darius is like getting
>> Well, I doubt that's Darius, but maybe it is. >> Accuse
him of transvestigating.
Do it on the stream. It was clearly cheeky stream involving
stuff in my opinion.
Emmer says, "I think Tom's answers are sounding strange." That's
because he's confused as us. He's like, "Wait, did I do something
to get me cancelled? I thought it was a funny drunk context."
>> Yeah. She's desperately searching for any male says
that defending Tom. Yeah. That is defending Tom. Sorry. So the
context would be, "Hey, I'm drunk. It's a joke. Let's type up
all these." Like Ingret says the punch line was to remove seven
from the list. So they made up a list to remove seven from the
list. Like, oh, I'm going to have sex with all these girls except
seven. So here's all the girls I was. It was random. Humans aren't
that random, guys. I don't believe in random like that. You have
to have a Y. The joke was to remove seven from the list after
she got accused. Accused him of transvestigating. Okay. So, he
created the list to remove seven from the list. And that's the
joke. That I can believe.
Okay. Rox says, "I thought the joke was pretending that there
was a list he was taking some off of." Okay, I get it now. Holy.
Okay, I get it. I get it. It's processed. Okay, now I get the
joke.
I Okay, does he explain that to Kyla? Cuz now I get the joke.
Okay, I get it. I'm here. Fact, thanks for the resub on three
months. Anger says, "Lord, you're being No, I'm explaining it
out loud. I just didn't hear it until then." It finally clicked.
I get it now. Okay. >> Actually a list of anything. >> So
then why did you say you didn't know what a list is referenced
to? >> I get that it's not a real list. I understand. That's
what I'm saying. It doesn't actually reference anything. When
I say I don't know, I'm saying it doesn't actually reference
anything. >> Yeah. There's no way he's going to communicate
that, right? Yeah. There's no way being right. I don't think
he's going to communicate it to Kyler >> It's not actually
referencing anything.
>> So the list, it was just a list of names you put down
had no meaning. And that's why you can't. >> You can't
say it had no meaning. The meaning was to remove seven from the
list as the joke. That was the meaning. So when he says no, there
is no meaning. That's not what they're asking. They're asking
why did you create the list? To tell a joke on seven. to pull
a prank on seven. You guys are all [__]
>> that's not the right answer. You can't say, "Oh, there's
no reason for the list." No, the reason for the list
joke on seven
>> because it you know what I'm saying? >> That is
why they have the joke or the the reason they have the list.
>> What the people What the reason for the why the people
are on the list because there is no reason. They're just on the
>> Literally reason. I was literally drunk. No, no, no.
You can't say there's no reason. I literally just piped out a
bunch of names for a race and they off the list and end. >> See,
that's not an explanation. You guys explained it better than
he did. Yeah,
>> it sounds like a lie because my brain can't hold on
to a why. So, you guys explained it better in chat. Okay. And
so, you uh you think that he liked cuz he a the list of women
that he wrote out on stream. He said that he got their permission
to write their name the first time or that he's since gotten
their
>> Uh I believe he's saying he's tried to since get >> Yeah,
he's saying that they were okay with it. >> But even one
of the people he's listening here says no, didn't have consent
to do that. >> Okay. Who Who is this?
>> Uh it's seven. But >> okay, so in the DMs I like
again these are leaks, so I don't have to like >> Yeah,
I don't believe JTO anything he says about anybody. I literally
do not believe anything he says about anybody. >> They're
there. Anybody think about having a conversation about this?
She said, "Why did you lie about whether or not I I said it was
okay for you to put this on the list?" I said, "You literally
DM'd me and said, "Hey, can I jump onto Wix channel and meme
about the list and pretend like this was a uh like I'm upset
about it or something." And I said, "Yeah, sure. Go ahead." Um,
and so I was like that to me and like posting about it on Twitter
and memeing about it on Twitter. Yes, that to me was you like
>> Look, people are very bad at giving consent. You can
literally ask people again and again and again. Everyone does
consent different. It's literally cultural, okay? How people
do consent, okay? everything is like so you get you think you've
gotten the proper consent and then you realize this person didn't
feel like they gave a proper I would honestly if it's a pattern
of theirs I would stop hanging out with them. Seven said to me
on stream on a panel that she has a very hard time socializing.
She's learning about the space. She's very overwhelmed. So honestly
like look I don't believe in a fantasy
I believe >> super based of Britney to take somebody um
you know saying like being vulnerable and then using that against
them to say that clearly them talking about consent wouldn't
actually be accurate. >> Very based Britney. very based.
>> Very based. >> Yeah. And then when someone like
me uh like makes it clear that I do not consent for things, I'm
told I don't have a choice.
>> I don't know where I got this.
>> Yeah. I don't know where I got this impression that
Britney was like super on the considerate side and she was like
super understanding and super about I don't know being more of
like a diplomat when it comes to problem solving. Um but I don't
know. I don't know if this is a change for Tom or if she was
always this way and just never realized cuz I thought she was
a more empathetic person. I don't know. That's kind of >> She
used to be so bubbly and happy.
>> Um, perpetually canled says in YouTube >> Tom
stopped when told >> I mean only after literally coming
into chat and saying I'll keep your t on my stream for the rest
of time or whatever the [__] he said is close to
that. and then coming into Discord and saying in voice that the
same thing and that if he Kelly didn't like it, she should DC
DMCA him DCMA.
listen,
I'm I'm just saying if he if he says, "Oh, I didn't do it." It's
like, uh, well, technically the problem is the things you said.
>> Where they're at is important without
meeting people where they at. If you tell me this is too overwhelm,
this space is too much, you can't handle it, I'm going to take
you away, I'm going to stop engaging with you in a way that could
come back and bite me because you are not ready to handle the
space. So again, it's absolutely fine for people to want away
from the space. It's fine for people to be like, I'm overwhelmed
with this. All of your consent is valid. But again, if you make
your inability to have the proper relationship, other people's
problems, then they have a right to like have boundaries around,
oh, maybe you're not like maybe I don't feel safe engaging cuz
now I don't know if I'm getting proper consent, right? It's like
there are people that I've wanted to be with, but they're like
I only have sex drunk. I only do BB. I'm drunk. Well, then I'm
not going to engage with you. And they're like, why not? And
I'm like, well, because now I don't know if you're consenting
for real. Like, I've had people do that to me. Says, do you believe
people wear their friendship burn >> with peace and love?
I just think like, >> sorry, you can go ahead, Jerry. I'm
just she's just >> I don't want to.
>> Kelly Jean Seven Sassa.
Obviously, something's wrong with them in the nicest way possible.
Like, >> oh my god.
says you
>> actually actually based starting to become a Britney
fan. Okay. All women are liars and they're just wrong when they
say they're so uncomfortable.
>> So even the Zia thing because out of all the people
and I get that like a lot of people say that like Zia was being
like performative and stuff like that, but genuinely the idea
of showing frustration because you're watching a friend self-sabotage,
which seems like it's actually happening would be something to
empathize with. But I guess Britney just kind of wants to cuddle
Tom way more than be like a friend that's going to tell him like,
"Hey, you [__] up." Like, but there are ways to improve.
Yeah. All of these people, by the way, or sorry, not all of them,
but definitely Sass and Zia were both like, "Hey, we need you
to like stop doing this. Like, please stop doing this."
And he was like, "Okay, uh, no you, uh, and you." And like to
the point that they felt like they had to leave because he was
harming himself.
Although I I don't know about Zia. Zia was a slightly different,
but that's definitely I believe O Sassfeld like hey you're just
you can't stop so I have to >> Their displays on stream
is like every there's something wrong with all of us. >> It's
just the kind of wrong that they have is like it's out of personally
no thank you and maybe SAS is different but right now she's not
it's not looking good. So >> again like everyone has something
wrong with them. All of us have something wrong with us but it's
a different shade of blue. >> I want the lightest shade
of blue, the the least amount of baggage and the most amount
of self- responsibility. >> Okay. What is her obsession?
>> That's what we want here. >> We want people to
recognize we're all up in our >> I think it's a new a new
system that she's shilling. That's why it's the categories which
are you. It's like the lighter blues. >> The new system
shilling. >> Yeah. So, this is probably going to go with
some new merch. I would imagine maybe some new courses that you
could
>> You are
deal with peace and love. >> With peace and love. >> Yeah.
But that's not the south of the border though.
South from here.
>> I think Wolf Gang really loves Auga. That's why when
he comes in it says Augaw word.
>> Shut the Who let this guy in here, bro? What the [__]
Pursuing streaming. >> I think this is basically done.
>> So, see you later.
>> Bye, Kelstar.
Bye-bye, Kelly Jean. All right. Um,
where do we want to go from here? This is basically the end of
the combo. Blue, so you and so you can too. Wait, blue and so
can you. Okay, I got it. Reuben, Ruben, I have to check out my
super chats cuz I think I missed some quite a bit earlier.
>> Oh, they weren't like serious donos though. They were
they were spite dono. Hi, Kelly. Shrug, shrug, Tom never broke
in a stash house. Tom gangster.
And then Ruben Ruben with J Stonss. And then I think those are
all the super chats I
What else do we have here?
>> Tom should get a face chat.
I believe everything if he got one.
>> Uh I think it was Hi Kelly asked thoughts on Dune 2.
I didn't see Dune 2 and I don't want to hear anyone else's thoughts
on it yet.
>> I know Rey didn't think it was >> Rey was like
eh right.
>> But I haven't heard any other opinions. I get >> Are
you worried that it's being done dirty or something? Oh, okay.
Gotcha. >> I heard good things about the second. >> I
could see it being really overrated personally, but >> Why
are you doing poo tube right now, Threadpool? What's going on?
>> Is the doom talk the doom talk?
>> Hold on a second. Do we have We got Wolf Gand on a camera,
so I can actually just bounce this over to Wolf Gang's camera
>> Yeah, true. Easy.
Wolf Gand on the camera. All right. >> we might as well
just continue this, right? Just finish it. >> We'll finish
it. We'll get to the other part. Yeah, why not? >> The
kind of [__] up you are is the kind I don't want
to deal with. And that's it. That's all we have to do. Put down
boundaries. Don't deal with the [__] up that you
can't deal with.
>> That's way too much. That's way too >> Mantis
says seven is dodgy. She turned this into something that she
never said. She had an issue with Tom with >> Wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait. Someone get me. Someone get me Mantis's chat
messages from that evening when Tom pulled Mantis up or sorry
when Tom pulled Seven up. So it's so funny that Mantis would
say this cuz Mantis when Tom pulled her up literally asked like
excuse me like why are you this person who's like here in not
this context at all and now she's like oh well seven's making
a big deal out of this.
Ain't no way dude. >> He quote violated my consent even
though she joked and played into the list. Yeah, I don't know.
Sounds shady. I don't like it. It sounds weird. Something is
sussy baka. I don't like >> Start responding. So yes, engaging
in the meme to me was implicit consent.
>> I can see how actually implicit consent to me in the
DMs that she leaked. So >> why did you say to be honest?
I don't believe you got consent. Why would you have consent for
like five seconds? I don't like afterwards.
>> Yeah. Tom's being too courteous, honestly. See, I wouldn't
do this. Tom's going way beyond his need. Obviously, if you feel
like it's weird using people in the space, use celebrities and
just switch it out and everybody in the space. It's like sometimes
we want to try to be inclusive, but by being inclusive, it it
like makes it too much for people because look, streamers are
celebrities or mini celebrities or content creators or public
figures. You can be talked about. The only chance you get of
being treated quote like a friend is if you are one. You know
what I mean? And so again, I don't even know what we're pretending.
You think if I went to Chuglogic and said, "Hey, can you take
down your stream where you called me a genocidal cult leader?"
Do you think Chug Logic's going to give a [__] He
was willing to post it in the first >> He literally called
me a genocidal like cult leader in his title. >> What are
you doing, bro? I spent all my time watching One Piece and my
husband. You think I have time to run a genocide? Are you dumb?
He's not going to take down that video.
Why would he take down that video? What are we talking about
here? Why are we pretending like people in this space are in
any way humanizing you any more than your human? Why are we pretending,
bro? Pick your limits and stick to your boundaries. Use your
values to decide how to act. Don't let people pressure you outside
of your values. If you want to be, you know, thoughtful and open-minded.
I've curtailed some of my language for my audience. I'm happy
to do that. It's a little less authentic, but it's a little bit
more courteous. That's fine, but I'm not going to do it for every
person that requires it of me. >> Kept referencing this
like other people screenshot it started post. No, not just in
my community. Like Wick tweeted it out. Um the other I think
girls who were literally on the list tweeted out. It was screenshot
and posting dwords and stuff and so then yeah afterwards there
was like almost all of the people on the list were like meing
about it and posting it around >> they inter okay so the
the girls who were on the list and were in reference to you took
basically implied consent if I'm understanding you okay if I'm
understand what you're saying you're saying you had applied consent
because they were gauging with it they seem to be laughing about
it there seems to be positive receptivity and nobody said like
what the [__] me off this you anything like that
in fact some people were saying why aren't I on the list I'm
>> or they were people that I already had this sort of
relationship with that yes I was well aware that they would >> okay
so when you say that you got their permission you don't mean
you got explicit permission you're saying you felt that there
was implied permission if that was my exact words that I said
I got permission I think he I don't >> no Tom said implied
permission and I think he's right that's a reasonable amount
of permission. That was what we were talking about. Yes, whether
or not they were. >> And then when you said that you didn't
know what the list was, that was again, I'm just feeling. >> Wait,
do we do we think Tom Do you think that actually happened that
Tom said he got implied permission? So, I have a feeling he said
he got permission like multiple times. We could go back and check.
I also kind of want to be done with this video a little bit,
so
not too worried about it. Tom is a funny and charismatic funny,
charismatic, and highly intelligent guy. True. Tom is all of
those things. And he's got better ribs than Darius. >> I
agree with this. I'm just making sure that everyone understands
what you're saying when you say that you said that you didn't
know what the list was. What you meant was the um anybody that's
me list. You don't actually know who that's who that is. Like
it's not a truth.
>> It wasn't referencing that list. It was just a list
that I typed up that meant >> I understand. >> Oh
my god. I think Tom's Oh my god.
>> He He can't keep saying that. It's driving me crazy.
>> It's driving me crazy. It doesn't mean anything. The
list doesn't mean anything. Stop saying that. It doesn't make
sense. You're not
saying now, but
>> All right. That's a base sign off right
>> Cool, cool, cool. >> So frustrating. >> This
guy's going to get some appetizers. Okay. This guy's going to
load up >> shrimp poppers. Okay. No. So, wait. Wait. Tempura
jalapeno poppers. Okay. He's going to get all kinds of appies
at Applebee's. Uh, no. Those were just generic bar food appetizers.
>> Just want to let you know he did advertising here for
free. Okay. So, I would I would not let him get away with that
next time. Okay. >> Some boneless wings, some deep fried
pickles. Let's go. >> Why you They ain't paying you, bro.
>> Regular me. I feel like maybe you're confused. Okay.
Me typing up a bunch of names on my screen wasn't thought of
as a list. It was just names on a screen. So then later, there
is another meme called the list about me wanting to have sex
with all Ed that Destiny's ever had sex with. I'm not relating
these two things to one another at the time. I don't think as
far as I remember. This was just me hyping up random names and
adding in names like Pamela Anderson.
>> Who remembers this? You know, your predecessor, Willis
McGee, he had some pretty harsh things to say about Buffalo upon
his departure. Let me quote, "Going to Buffalo, it was like hitting
a brick wall. Can't go out. Can't do nothing."
>> Well, that was probably taken out of >> Well,
he went on to >> wait, this isn't even old. Get out of
here. Marshian Lynch was not that old. This is not that old.
>> And again, let me quote the Raven. There's an Applebee's,
a TGI Fridays, and they just got a Dave and Busters. And you
know the women,
>> there you go. Now it's in contact. >> Unlike Willis
Mahi, rookie running back Marshawn Lynch finds the women of Buffalo
terribly interesting. He has embraced the city. >> Sorry,
this is not as funny as I remember it being. Okay. It was really
funny when Marshon Lynch went to Applebee's, though. Okay. Where
is he at? Let's [__] go. >> Matter of fact,
he ate at Applebee's 12 times during the by week.
>> Oh yeah, this spot hot.
I love the ambiance. I love the decor. I spent a lot of time
trying to figure out which one I like more. The ambiance or the
decor?
>> The decor.
>> listen. This when it came out, I thought this was the
funniest thing in the world. Okay.
>> In amaranth and stuff like that. A bunch of a bunch
of women. He also said the majority of these women were cool
with it. And I can see three people I believe three people who
aren't cool with it. Or maybe maybe if you count Cherry who was
added on Twitter or said I think you said I'm adding you to the
list >> Cherry just okay >> I don't I don't >> block
her stop engaging the >> maybe there are women who are
uncomfortable if that's the case I was but yes from my perspective
yes the >> she did she gave you the Norman move >> a
dozen times over the course of the meme and so I can't even remember
like what was or wasn't on it at first or in the end yeah >> like
what the joke was is that it was a meaningless list that didn't
actually mean anything so >> no the list okay >> yeah
I think Tom is not explaining the list enough. You know what
I mean? So, it doesn't make sense
to me the way he's explaining it. And this is the only time in
the whole 5 hours or 6 hours or 2 hours we've been here that
I feel like, "Ooh, this isn't good." You know what I mean? Okay.
So, this is how I felt watching the Destiny and Britney Bridgeburn.
Both of you are on and don't realize it. It's because we were
like double speaking each other. I feel like if Steven had just
messaged me, we could have cleared the air. I don't know why
he didn't message me. We could have just cleared the air. But
then at the same time, we wouldn't have been much closer because
we never were close to begin with. But I obviously can't be close
with people that do these types of things. That's what I'm saying.
There's a behavior pattern. Like there's a behavior pattern where
like if you were so edged, if you're so hurt, you think everyone's
trying to hurt you. You can't tell difference between people
who are actually trying to hurt you and people that are just
speaking their truth through their values cuz you're not used
to people having values. >> She's the one that got triggered.
>> Dude, she's so one-dimensional. After that conversation
with Destiny, I literally messaged him. I've told people this.
I literally messaged him after that first conversation where
she kind of got emotional, but she like she said everything was
fine and then she left. I told him I was like, "You ever bring
that topic up with her again, you won't be friends anymore. That
will end your friendship. I promise you." And I was
I've had private chats with her before um when we resolved things
and I just like
trauma manifests in different ways but I just don't think she
gave a [__] about gives a about how it can manifest
in a way that like she doesn't know or
relate to herself. >> Yeah. Yeah. That's most people >> just
want to let everybody know that >> better claims to be
better. >> Jtock just Nicole K. He's an extremist. I told
you so. I've heard him mention this at least four times on my
time knowing him. Okay. He he brings stuff
>> I just like pointing it out that she's like so obvious
and one-dimensional that I literally saw her leave a conversation
with going like we're still good. We're still friends. We're
great. I was like, "No, you're not. I can tell you're not." And
actually, I can tell his subject is so sensitive for you that
if he ever brings it up again without basically saying you're
right about everything, your friendship's over because that's
how important it is to you.
>> Yeah. I just I don't like making fun of people like,
"Oh, you're so traumatized. You can't trust anybody. You don't
know who's your friend or your foe." Like, okay, so we can make
fun of traumatized
>> Doesn't make it make sense.
>> Yeah. I listen, it's just Britney, okay? Humans are
going to human. I just hit refresh on this. Luckily, I saved
another one, so we don't have to be done
We can finish it.
See how five head I am right here. >> I need to make the
list. >> I don't even >> Maybe I shouldn't have made
a list. But yes, if he did it on stream especially, then why
are we all confused? What is happening? Who?
They're just trying to find something to hate him on. Mantis
says, "Yes, it was on stream where seven accused him of
Do it on the stream. It was clearly cheeky stream involving
stuff. What's up with Wolf Gang's goon glove? What's up with
your goon glove, Wolf Gang? >> So I can like Hold on, let
me show my camera. If I'm drawing, >> he can draw and not
have friction or get grease on his screen. >> Exactly.
Yeah. So it's those two reasons. It slides better and I can't
I don't leave like sweat on my thing.
>> My hands are cold. How did I miss Dude, I should have
just I missed that. Just one hand.
>> in my opinion.
>> Emmeris says, "I think Tom's answers are sounding strange.
It's because he's confused as us." He's like, "Wait, did I do
something to get me cancelled?" >> I'm just going to see
if we can get to the end of this whole thing here. >> Know
if I'm getting proper consent,
>> I can see how that is implicit consent to me in the
DMs that she leaked. So, >> why did you say that? To be
honest, I don't believe the other consent cuz why the [__]
would you get their consent for like a 5-second meme? I'm not
going to like why the [__] >> continued afterwards.
>> it wasn't a It was a thing that I didn't >> Yeah,
Tom's being too courteous, honestly. See, I wouldn't do this.
Tom's going way beyond already past this.
>> The way he's explaining it, and this is the only time
in the whole 5 hours or 6 hours or 2 hours we've been here that
I feel like, ooh, this isn't good.
You know what I mean?
Kaya, this is how I felt watching the Destiny and Britney Bridgeburn.
Both of you are on and don't realize it. It's because we were
like double speaking each other. I feel like >> Okay, guys,
now that we're at this part of the stream, okay, I have to I'm
getting yelled at by my handlers. Okay, I I literally have been
told gun to my head. I need a shill for super chats, donations,
and memberships. Okay, so on YouTube, if you want to help monetize
the stream, if you enjoy the content on YouTube, you could become
a member. You become uh you could send a super chat. Those are
cool. On Streamlabs, we take donations via PayPal or credit card.
Uh, love those. Love those. Also, $5 and up gets your TTS read
on screen. And if it doesn't get read on screen for some reason,
like Kelly interrupting it, I will read it myself. Okay? I promise.
Then over on kick, you can, if you like, you can send or sorry,
you can gift subs or get your own sub. I really love individual
subs. Anyone who individually subs on kick, right, isn't gifted,
but subs themselves, those people are my friends, and I will
never forget them. Okay? You're all very good friends of mine.
We are best friends if you individually sub on kick. Okay? Those
are my favorite kind cuz those are the kind that show that somebody
actually cares and enjoys the content.
Anyway, thank you all for listening. Oh, by the way, uh you could
like the stream and you could also subscribe on YouTube or follow
on kick. Thank you very much. Like if Steven had just messaged
me, we could have cleared the air. I don't know why he didn't
message me. We could have just cleared the air, but then at the
same time,
we wouldn't have been much closer cuz we never were close to
begin. So, what's the Jtock panel consensus on the absurd sweeping
that we saw last night? How about the accusations of bad faith
andor trying to make NYSE look dumb? Uh, listen, I don't I haven't
rewatched it and I would have to rewatch it. I think the the
sweeping is probably that um Erodite was friends with Tom, was
like fairly cordial with Tom and then saw that he's probably
having a hard time with, you know, he lost viewers. He feels
like his stream's going downward and I'm sure he said like, "Hey,
I feel like I was really unfairly treated here."
So, I would imagine there's some defensiveness
Yeah. I don't I don't know. I I feel like although I was the
genesis of Tom's problems or Kelly and and I were at the same
time, I do feel like a lot of his stuff was self-inflicted and
that once I once I saw the pattern of him continuing to hurt
himself in this way, I more or less disengaged.
So, I don't I don't even think I'm the person you have to go
after in all of this, but I don't know. It's my opinion. Uh $5
super chat from Monkey King Ghost. Sorry, you go ahead, Cherry.
I was just going to say I still think that anybody who says bad
faith is a debate pervert.
>> Oh, sure. There was no message on Monkey King ghosts
super chat. Uh Astro $5 super chat. Hey, love you. Love you too,
buddy. Uh $10 super chat. $10 Canadian super chat from Shadow
Sly. She changed the spelling of categories. I wonder if she
had a covert s in your chat. Lol.
Oh, maybe also Oh, she fixed categories. She did fix it. It was
It was like catacombs categories before.
>> Also, what was the weird um thing about referring to
you as a drama frog? I know how drama frogs are. I don't really
trust drama frogs.
>> oh, I don't know. That's just >> I It's weird.
And it feels >> poisoning the whatever it's called, the
>> Poisoning the well. Yeah, poisoning the hole. No, it's
poisoning the well. It's the water in the well gets poisoned.
>> Well's a hole. Shut up. >> Kind of.
>> Okay. No. >> You think a well is not a hole? I
>> think it's a wet hole. Why did you make me say it? >> Why
did you make me say it? Oh, I I literally didn't want to say
it. That's why I said I was going to leave it there and you made
me keep talking. Okay.
>> Anyway, you're turning me into a sex like Tom. Yeah,
you're making turn me into a fest like Tom. I don't like it.
>> Superior sex. No, I'm just kidding. >> What was
I? I was answering a question. Now I've lost I've my mental >> drama
frog. >> Oh, the drama frog thing. So, it's weird to me
when people share a vocabulary. I see a certain number of people
around Destiny who I know share some amount of conversation all
sharing a vocabulary about me. Shut up, Queen.
>> And and to me, it's like, okay, I don't know if it's
schizophrenic or legitimate to connect these dots because it
it could be either one. And it feels weird to me when I have
people like calling me a drama frog when like I do some drama
stirring, but like I don't I feel like I don't do it that much.
And I feel like these people just talk to each other and really
drive this home.
>> Yeah, it comes off like that for sure.
>> Yeah. So I like I don't know what to think about that.
So when I'm getting called a drama frog sometimes I suspect it
to be for other things. I think it also was a poor interaction
with not so erodite the first time we talked. Um
I'm fairly open like I think I'm probably closer to someone like
Max in terms of how I feel like and me describe like I'll literally
just tell you what I was thinking or how I was feeling in the
moment uh as best I can. So I think I was like oh I don't know.
I was like probably speaking loosely when I said you said or
small or something like in regards to that first conversation
and like I just I don't have conversations in a guarded way where
I'm trying to make sure everything I say is measured and correct.
I just don't cuz I feel like I can always clear it up going forward.
So you stirred with cutie. Yeah, I did with cutie Cinderella.
Absolutely. Um >> yeah, but they don't even know cutie.
>> Well, I'm sure they know about it. But I'm just saying
that I think the implication she got there was, "Oh, I was willing
to just have this conversation in a way that made her look bad
for the sake of drama." That wasn't what I was trying to say.
I was just like, "Oh, it was like funny on stream to say it that
way." Like it it's a more heated way to say it. I don't know.
I'm not totally sure where I was at. And I think she took that
to mean like, "Oh, I don't care about hurting people."
In that moment, I think she took it that way. Like, I don't really
care about hurting people. I'll just say whatever I have to to
be entertaining.
You saying you're not a drama farmer? I mean, I don't I feel
like I don't cause drama and I feel like when I when I perceive
drama as really with somebody else, unless they are really malicious
themselves, I probably don't press that
>> Later on, she did acknowledge that she sees you a bit
different, at least from the Chud logic and the queens. Well,
I don't I actually don't think I think I am less accurate than
Chud and probably a little nicer maybe, but I don't think like
I think probably
if if something got leaked to Chud about me, I think he would
give me a heads up and if he felt like it was something that
if he just squashed it, he could squash it. I think he would
if it was something that he felt like wasn't relevant to public
discourse. But if it was something relevant to public discourse
or something that was going to come out, he'd probably just be
like, "Here's a heads up. Uh, I'm probably going to run with
this because it's coming out anyway. And I think that's about
the most you could expect from any news source in the world,
too. So, I don't understand the level that he's getting held
to. I think I think Quimman stirs a little more, but I think
Quimman's funny, so it's fine.
It's fine. Also, I really feel like you're doing your own thing
here, not just DG leftovers. Hope you keep up the great work,
man. Oh, thank you, Astro.
That's very nice.
J boy up huge. True.
the tiny hat gang up huge up massive
>> with. But I obviously can't be close with people that
do these types of things. That's what I'm saying. There's a behavior
pattern. Like there's a behavior pattern where like if you are
so edged, if you're so hurt, you think everyone's trying to hurt
you, but you can't tell the difference between people who are
actually trying to hurt you and people that are just speaking
their truth through their values cuz you're not used to people
having values. Bro, it is so frustrating. Isn't that all just
perception? Isn't that all like doesn't that all get answered
by humans going to human?
That like the people who are edged are just that way because
of some trauma or or because it's a part of their bubble and
like you shouldn't engage with them if they're edged like that.
I just don't I don't get like you can just literally humans going
to human your way out of that super easily.
>> Again, I only disagree with people on principle. I'm
not I don't have any issue with anyone in the space except the
people I talk about and I've blocked. I haven't blocked Steven.
Why not? Because I'm not I don't think of him in that category.
Jtock and Cherry and all those people had to get blocked because
they couldn't maintain.
That's what's so frustrating. It's like Steven's not even in
that
to her. >> She's ridiculous.
>> I mean, yeah. I don't I literally don't know what she's
I don't even know what she's talking about. He can't maintain,
but whatever. Just face the fact has more clout than any of us.
That's why he's not blocked.
>> Uh probably. He literally said that she's barren from
disease.
>> That's a pretty up thing to say about
>> Yeah, but the door's still open for her. Wonder why.
>> I don't know. I I mean, you know what? I guess that
wasn't a lie is is her point.
>> Weird. Okay, moving on. You know,
like with peace and love, like I there's so much inappropriate
behavior and so
much assuming words mean more than they do, so much assuming
people are closer than they are. It's so inappropriate and I'm
just here to call it out because this is like not common in healthier
right? And yes, it can sometimes happen with friends and family
that are like, "Hey, we're not spending as much time together.
I miss you." But they have much more reasonable reason to be
complaining about that
than this.
This is so weird.
You know what I mean?
>> I think she's also completely ignoring the fact that
I didn't ask to join that stream and was invited that I actually
explicitly said I don't really want to go on that stream and
set up like a dono goal. That that was too high for that.
H maybe it wasn't. It wasn't high enough. I made $45
instantly out of both of my chats. I should have set it at like
$200.
Feel like if I set it too high though, if I set it too high,
people don't donate. They're just like, "We're not going to make
it." So, >> this is just so inappropriate.
>> Yeah, I should have just I should have
>> I underestimated the uh the value of the Tom certain
people in the community. And both of you were not in
inlishing
>> so badly. It was frustrating to watch. I mean, bro,
>> could have talked it out in private. That's what I'm
saying.
>> Wait, does she not understand that Destiny doesn't want
to be friends with her because she has opinions of him that are
in congruent with what he thinks about himself and that basically
anybody who holds the opinions she does, he doesn't want to be
friends with. It's like, if you think I'm a terrible person,
if you think I've done all the things you're accusing me of,
then we aren't friends. Does she not understand that? That is
like the basis of him not wanting to be around her. Hey, if anybody
thinks this about me, you like, off, I don't want you around
me.
Why is she acting like he's just being immature?
It's literally like the things you're saying now are the reason
he doesn't want to be around you.
>> I'm just saying I can't have this conversation on stream.
That's what I mean. real. >> How many times does she have
to talk about his child and how he is as a father before she
understands? Like, don't stop. He doesn't want to hear it. >> I
don't know. >> Friendships don't happen on stream,
>> 600 viewers. We need to manufacture some more content
to keep those numbers. >> If this was real, there's >> this
would happen in private. >> I'm sure somebody will get
a an unsolicited dickpick at some point soon, okay? And then
we can just ride that drama, too. >> People would understand
each other or they'd agree to disagree.
Okay?
That is in no way an endorsement of somebody sending an unsolicited.
Do not do that. Okay. >> Was wrong. Okay. Um now Erdite,
if you go to the the channel in information that is called the
list in this discord, what do you see there? Yeah.
really the list. It's girls. It is girls. Girls girls.
Cute girls. What is this? That's a thing for a show that we were
making that we asked people to contribute to a list of girls
that they would want to be on a
>> and the panel was for like >> it's supposed to
be like a whatever podcast style panel where like we did the
same thing just over Discord. >> So it's like a play dating
panel. Is that correct? >> Yes. Yes. Again, >> what's
your disagree that's what it is? >> I think it shows very
clearly that he knows what the list is. He's continued to meme
about it which is fine if you lean into it. But then when you
go I have no idea what it means. I've got no >> That is
what Yes. That is not what it was at first. That is not like
what the plan was. The idea was more so that I was trying to
say that like, "Oh, I with seven so badly I made myself look
like such an idiot by misunderstanding this joke that she's never
going to want to talk to me." Like that was the the joke at the
time, but yes, it evolved into something else over time. That
was not that. Yes, that's just not what it was. >> Oh,
we are so close to the end of this. >> Um Oh, here we go.
What is this? I'm dying here. It was I was just erasing seven
from the list. I think I up. Okay. What is the list? You know
what the list is and you know what the list is. Um I'm trying
to see. >> Believe that you know what the list is. It's
coming from me.
I thought I thought they were reading a transcript because this
was literally the the actual way the conversation went on the
wick panel. >> Oh, sorry. >> It's my bad for making
that assumption.
I'm sorry. I'm post
about the list.
He started list up and his list Tom and people say you know what
is the list? >> Oh yeah. Did Wick message Tom like what
is this list? Did he blow it out of proportion? Was that the
problem? Do you know what I mean? Was that the problem that he
like blew it out of proportion?
You know what I mean? It just doesn't make sense.
Interesting. Interesting.
yeah. I think Wick might have [__] up here. Maybe
he blew it out of proportion and thought it was bigger than it
was. Like when he freaked out about ADHD meds, he saw it on Twitter
and he thinks he's curious and asked and Tom stayed vague and
went from there. Oh my god.
It feels like this space is like full of people that haven't
bubble hopped enough to like actually be curious on why things
originate. Like no one asked me why, but then there's alsoation
happening. Cony's explaining this very >> Okay, so Wick
sent him the picture and he probably I'm assuming didn't do it
calmly. From what I remember from a screenshot I saw, it was
like very like what is this? And it's just like yeah, Wick Wick
does I think Wick is a little bit more sex negative than probably
I am. But also again considering all the history in this space,
Tom is the least offensive. Like he's definitely there if you're
going to make a list. >> Wait, who else is doing pesty
in this space? I wonder. >> But he's not actually like
why are they holding Tom to such a standard? That's what I'm
trying to figure out. They would never >> really hold certain
people accountable the way they're holding Tom. Why is it about
Tom that makes people go after him the hardest? >> Wait,
people didn't know. We saw the list meme. There it is, boys.
list anybody Destiny before.
Uh, it it is a fantastic meme. Okay. It's one of the best. Oh,
[__]
>> It is. >> Because he's healthier than them. I
would definitely say Tom is on the healthier side of the other
shades of blue. What is it about Tom?
What is it about Tom that makes people go for him? Is it because
he's like,
what is it? What is it? What is it?
What is it?
Britney, don't go suggesting making lists now. Bro, I'm telling
you, there's something here, right? Isn't it gnawing at your
brains? Like, why is Tom
so interesting? Like, why is he the target?
You know, he's more attractive than them. Mikey, please.
>> Headphones just died. Just give me a
course, his headphones die as soon as Britney acknowledges that
Tom is more attractive than Jtock.
How convenient. >> Can't deal with it.
>> Cannot handle.
>> He's trying to pretend like he didn't throw those across
the room and they snapped in half. >> That's why they die.
>> Hold on, guys. I'm switching headphones as he's holding
up. >> Oh, hey. What's up, buddy? >> Not back. >> I
lied. Gotta solder that thing together, huh?
All right, we're back. >> What's up, bud?$20
super chat. Thank you very much. First super chat ever on the
stream. Sup JSDLK. Love your takes in the stream. Off topic,
but I've been a computer programmer for less than a year. How
do you complete tasks and maintain productivity productivity
when working from home? uh
probably like a stringent need to keep my my workspace separated
from all other spaces, refusing to engage with anything nonworkreated
in that space. But that was also when I got a lot of tasks done.
The problem is I let those blend together. So the last job I
took and probably all jobs in the future, I'm going to try really
hard to work from the office cuz I like having an office to separate
these things. But I'd say probably having a space where the only
thing you do is work is incredibly important in my opinion. >> Yeah,
I'm very glad that you're saying this because I always thought
this was like some woo nonsense where it's like, oh, separate
your sleeping space from your working space. Like, what difference
does it make? But I I do kind of agree with you, the more I'm
kind of realizing that I'd like to step away and work somewhere
else. So, I'm glad that you're also another person saying it
cuz
>> don't tell if it's Mhm. >> I share an office with
my husband now. I don't know how he gets anything done because
I always want to show him something
like look what I painted. Oh, look what happened.
I don't know how that does anything.
>> It's Wub. That's what it is. >> Uh, anyway, thank
you for that super chat there, uh, underscored. Thank you very
much.
>> Your comments are so >> Oh, wait. What else? Oh,
yeah. I want to go into the office, but I think this separation
is really important. Um, also just having lists, by the way,
I think
I think the most productive I ever get is having like a to-do
list and then a >> like I redo my to-do list in the morning
and then at night. So, sorry, when I start work, I look at my
to-do list. I like figure out what I'm working on in probably
the order. And then after work, I basically rewrite my next day's
to-do
Sorry, not after work, but like in the last 30 minutes of the
day, having those opening and cool down periods was really important.
Oh, I forgot. I'm talking about a Yeah, not a list, like a task
>> I'm so focused on that I need to do the list in the
morning and then after work.
Nice paste.
>> Both feeling racist to me and I hate that vibe. Okay,
let me see. Inappropriate. Somebody inappropriate. Tom is on
my list. Discord says ABA or Gaba emoji. I think Tom is just
the easiest target during the content drought cases. Maybe he's
more willing to accept his mistakes. He does do that too much.
He's too nice to these people.
>> Tom is just too nice. Okay. He's just too nice to everyone.
That's his true downfall that he was just way too nice to everybody.
>> Too accepting of his mistakes for sure. >> I don't
Yeah. I don't know. >> Is fair. >> It's crazy. It's
wild. The amount of sweeping was just wild. >> Do you find
that the separate office space outweighs the time spent in transit?
Um, it does for me because I like
I can't work I don't know how to explain this. Unless I'm trying
to be like a top performer at a company, I'm probably I have
a really hard time um just putting in like the required hours
because I'll get really disinterested and fall out of work. So,
I can either be like an overworker or a no worker essentially.
Um, so I find going into the office I'm like very engaged all
the time. Uh, there's no real worry about having to do or like
doing anything that I do at home. There's no there's no um distractions
from anything. It's just mostly about work or about socializing
with people at the office and maintaining like office relationships
and
and like uh yeah, just building like my life around work. I can
do that or I can like not work. It's like I really can't do the
in between. So again, that's for me personally. I like doing
that. I like having, you know, a lot of my people I work with
be my friends. We go out after work. We do that kind of thing.
That's like what I enjoy doing. But that's not for everybody.
Okay. Some people really do like a lot of good work from home.
Yeah, that's rough. Underscored. I think um
how would I do this?
I would at least try to orient differently. So I don't know if
you work if you work on your computer, it's going to be really
hard. Like if you work on your computer where you play video
games, I'd try to like Yeah, I don't know. I'd try to orient
differently somehow so that you be in like a separate work mode
and a separate um home mode.